so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to round four of the
tata steel chess tournament 2022.
we are your hosts for the day i'm
fiona style anthony almost forgot my own
name there
and i'm joined by grandmaster robert
house robert how are you today
well fiona i didn't forget your name i
also didn't forget my name so i guess
i'm off to a half decent start but i'm
thrilled to be back yesterday was such
an electric day we were so privileged to
watch
gujarati take down daniel duval that was
the absolute highlight and of course we
had three other decisive games so we're
spoiled funeral that's all i have to say
absolutely what a day it was if you've
missed the game between daniel dubov and
uh vidiq you definitely want to look
that up also we did a rapid recap of the
day on that so you can find that on our
youtube channel elsewhere uh richard
report beat niels guandalius cesipanko
uh beat his fellow countryman sergey
karyakin and jordan van ferece got back
to winning ways uh by taking out uh
pragnan andals so after three rounds
robert we have a seoul leader already
it is quite early but for the fans of
vidiq gujrathi they probably hope the
tournament ends now he is in the sole
lead two and a half at a three and on
the other side of things if we look from
the bottom up niels grandilius not
having that great of an event
unfortunately for him he has two losses
in the first three games and there's a
whole pack chasing bit at the top with
two out of three so fiona really
exciting stuff thus far and it's
anyone's tournament more or less
absolutely and today i believe we have
two standout
uh pairings uh as we see the the
matchups there uh i think like every day
something for everyone niels who as you
said will be has been struggling he's
playing pragnanda an interesting one but
this one i think magnus against jordan
is one that's going to take a lot of our
focus jordan has joined team magnus for
the match so it will be interesting how
the dynamic is of him facing uh his boss
and the other pairing that i've been
waiting for here it is vidiq rightly our
tournament leader playing against andre
sepenku has also had a great start to
the event
it shows how many great games there are
when karwana dubov is not the center of
our attention but you're absolutely
right fiona those other two games you
highlighted magnus carlsen taking on his
second jordan von forrest some people
may think it's awkward for jordan maybe
he'll get fired of course not that's a
joke but it's actually i believe pretty
awkward for magnus because he has to
decide what to play against somebody
who's worked on his opening so for
magnus we'll see even what his first few
moves are and the other game you
mentioned the leader of gujarati chasing
him is andre yesapanko after a very nice
win over sergey karjakin shore karjakin
made a pretty fatal error in judgment
late in that game but it was because of
the sustained pressure so yesapanko he
may be quite young he's just a teenager
but his age belies his strength and
we've seen him thrive in vikanze fiona
yes absolutely last year he beat magnus
carlsen here a game i shall never forget
that the reaction of andre
um i think that video is everywhere in
the internet you can find it that was
just such a special moment
and it will also be interesting to see
how uh vidit will he be able to keep a
level head after yesterday playing what
was probably one of the best games of
his life so a lot of action to look
forward to today and you too can get
involved at home
they certainly can just like i voted on
video gujarati's win perhaps being an
early candidate for game of the year
people can get guess the results they
can vote on the results so don't forget
to vote on the result of today's games
go to chess.com events navigate to the
tournament select a game click vote
which should be the third tab up at the
top there and select your winner you
could win a piece of the one thousand
dollar prize pool for best voters or
free diamond memberships voting ends
after the 10th move of each game so
don't miss out remember to vote on all
the games fiona and i will be back
shortly round four and vikings a we'll
start soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back and round four is about to
get underway here in just three minutes
as we see anish who is he talking to
robert what's your guess
i can't quite recognize
the backside of whoever this is i i will
work harder on being able to know
players just by their jacket put my
money on irvin lemmy
oh that's a great guess because it's his
main second his trainer and he is
playing in the challenger section so
that feels like have we gotten i think
now with the big view into the playing
hall i think that's the outline of irvin
lammy who was his second here last year
as you said this year he's playing
himself in the challengers and instead
aneesh is this year seconded by none
other than arientari from norway
you trade one fantastic second for
another so it seems like anisha some
great friends and we see pragmata he's
sitting now playing as niels grandilius
that promises to be a fun game as well
and we saw neil smiling there good to
see him as still seemingly in high
spirits despite a tough start and i saw
that richard report he wrote on
instagram posted about his game against
magnus yesterday and he said
i'm
excited or i'm paraphrasing but that he
was excited for his match against the
shahriar and he didn't know what to
expect was he also going to have to face
some early g4
stuff we shall see and here comes our
tournament leader vidit
yeah there's vinit there's yesapanko we
know yes pink has been sitting there for
a while did it joins him at the board
and one thing about mama jaro he's
wearing the g4 hoodie i'm sure he wore
that hoodie way before he played three
g4 but that's what i'm calling it so i'm
hoping that we see some fighting chess
from chakra yard today that hoodie has
done wonders in this tournament in terms
of delivering the goods
we see both players dressed up quite
warm
dude actually looks very cozy in his
woolen
sweater or jumper what you want to call
it this year it isn't as cold i feel uh
as some previous years here in vikings a
the weather has been quite mild and i
don't know robert why i'm talking about
the weather but uh we're still waiting
for world champion magnus carlson we see
daniel duboff
has just arrived for his clash against
fabiano carrana they're coming in so
fast sergey koryakin
exchanging a few smiles with anish giri
and uh it's 59 and once again everyone
is there we see some fist bumps and
clocks being started but magnus carlson
a few seconds late once again
and
there is richard report um
i think this one also a very interesting
game between sam and
richard
it definitely should be and better late
than never for the players who are
getting there at the last possible
second or even as the clocks are
starting so i am really looking forward
to today's matches uh the players
settling in
of course just going to feel out the
first few moves what their opponent has
in store for them but i know that the
players have in store for all of us
great fighting chess so many decisive
games thus far fiona
it's funny to see that although the
action has started most of the
photographers in the playing hall
they're not bulging they're staying
right in front of that board because
they are waiting for magnus carlsen they
want to capture the moment of i think
we'll see a handshake here i don't think
it will be a fist one
but
maybe it
may be a friendly slap on the back of
the head you know when you're good
friends when you work together uh you
can get away with things like that but
jordan von forrest nobody should forget
he is the defending champion
sorry just walking into the playing hall
so we will see what's it gonna be a
handshake between the two players with
the photographers all getting the shot
that they came for
and have you noticed fiona that magnus
tends to wear a lighter suit color when
he has the white pieces and then a
darker suit color when he has the black
piece during the world chess
championship i noticed that he would
trade off the colors like that and i
know it's interesting i don't think
magnus used to do this and i don't think
in general that he is a superstitious at
least i've never heard anything i've
never noticed anything but it seems like
it started indeed in in dubai uh when he
got the other magnus on his team magnus
i believe his name was barstat not
bastard that someone called him in one
of his press conferences
who seems to have fun sorry about how
he's saying robert i would say we should
never speak of those press conferences
again i think the world is a better
place without those press conferences
but yeah it seems like the other magnus
had some influence on the the style um
and the dressing race of magnus carts
and who has just opened the game with
knight f3
i would say that i wasn't expecting that
move and knight of three of course is a
flexible approach you can play in the
ready opening for g3 bishop g2 and a
catalan fee encountered bishop
or you can go back to some of the main
lines with d4 and c4 so magnus not
making his intentions very clear at
least not yet and i'm sure jordan even
though he made a quick reply here with
d5 he was just wondering what does
magnus want from me today and will i
allow it so d5 played very principal
chess in the center we're only on move
one nothing too exciting just yet you
think that magnus is going to try and
steer clear from
some big theoretical discussion and play
something more speed
and he plays g3 i think he will avoid
mainline theory because it is awkward to
play the person who trains you
they have been working tirelessly on
openings that fit your style you've
discussed your opening plans your wants
out of the opening with them so to play
something that they can't expect that is
just sort of a casual opening without
tons of theory that they can't so they
can't memorize things i think that's the
right way to go and it will make
magnus's life easier as he gets out of
the early stages of the game
yeah so uh we will come back here of
course we see jordan has just played g6
and maybe we can bring up the bird's eye
view to get an early impression of do we
have anything
crazy going on here today
well we see a petrov from report and
that's not crazy
but i from reporting i don't want to see
a petrov i mean petrov can still be a
very fighting opening five minute
carwana he is playing down in the bottom
left side of the screen there he is
playing against dubov but he is the main
proponent of the petrov he's played with
great success but from rapport i usually
expect hectic opening lines hectic games
and against sam strength and he decides
to play something a little calmer
yeah i'm curious what will happen in
that game sam has had three very long
games
i'm curious to see how much uh is he
still willing to try today but i think
some is a fighter
uh but yeah report choosing one of the
more
solid lines so we will see how that one
develops i'm curious also about
mamedyarov's game with that queen coming
out so uh early
yes and temporarily mama jarv is up a
pawn but this is still part of
standard opening fair the queen on d4
had recaptured upon uh that captured his
and fiona before we continue talking
about the games preparation such a big
part of chess right sam shanklin known
as one of the most prepared players on
the planet and he had something
special in the interview he did on a
podcast
where he talked about his preparation
and in particular for this opponent so
we have the image here
it's hard to see at first glance but
then you zoom in to number six
and does that say report random bs
because i haven't read a book in a while
and i still think that's what it says
there
it does and i mean
i don't know if some realized that this
was gonna be screen grabbed i'm very
curious
uh to know what's in that file i wonder
if we can get away with asking some
about it after one of his games but
an interesting folder for sure
well
that game is still in just the first two
moves i've pulled it up here it has been
a petrov and after a knight of six d4
was played so sam he is choosing a an
interesting line the main continuation
typically is knight takes e5 d6 and the
knight hops back to f3 knight takes e4
and white has the choice do i play
knight c3 and trade off the pair of
knights do i play for the move d4
straight away
many options at this stage of the game
but sam chooses to move d4 and after
takes bishop d3 d5 he gets to take with
his knight on e5 so both knights in the
center these lines fiona can get sharp
pretty quickly and if the players don't
know what they're doing then it can get
iffy for the black side because white of
course has the first move advantage
yes indeed and um well we will see for
now both players uh blitzing out
their moves um
we will see will we get something more
sharp or uh or more peaceful petrov but
now shall we maybe check in with the
tournament leader um
with it who's playing with the white
pieces against panko
sure let's go there
not many moves have been played but
perhaps gujarati has been inspired by
his opponent yesterday because he is the
white pieces he chooses an italian he
had success on the black side of an
italian that was really wild and happy
memories used the opening for himself
and it's andre isapanko who hasn't made
his reply so
for forbidden to play the italian and
yes thank you to sit here thinking it's
clear that andre did not expect the
italian from vidic today
yeah and uh well i don't know how often
vidit has played it uh before
but it has played the italian before but
uh yes panko goes for knight f6 of
course black always has two main options
either bishop c5 or knight f6 and what
kind of approach do you expect here from
vidit will he play something offbeat
like
duboff did yesterday or will we just see
a joko piano with some c3 d3
it's really difficult to predict because
even vidit's first move comes as a
surprise he's a d4 player
and i've considered him a d4 player
through and through and yet in today's
game against the young russian star he
played e4 so
from the very first move of the game
guess the pancreatic what does he want
from me uh why did he change his first
move for specifically for me and we get
to the italian he chooses d3 rather than
knight to g5 and i think many of our
viewers will be more familiar with the
fried liver and after d5 pawn takes d5
you don't take on d5 with your knight
that is losing to knight takes
there i can't even do it that's how bad
the move is knight takes f7 this is a
known opening that is very very bad for
black because the queen comes to f3 with
check and the king has to go to e6 just
to save the night and it's just bad news
from the the black side so
in this game
vivid says i don't want to deal with
these lines with knight a5 and black
sacrifices a pawn but gets a very quick
initiative white's pieces have moved a
bunch of times and then black will
develop and go for a counter on the king
side so vidit says
i'll play calmly d3 and c3
no real surprises but just interesting
note what choices the players are making
at this point in the game
and we will see here i think we will uh
it's actually it's not just a repeat
funnily enough of a vidit's game from
yesterday with the black pieces but
desepanko uh himself yesterday was
playing the italian game with the white
pieces
against karjakin so
we will see here who keeps the upper
hand out of the opening who will be able
to land the first surprise well i mean
you're right in that vidit landed the
first surprise with
e4 but andre well familiar i think with
this these positions from and on both
sides so we will see what vidit had in
mind
and there was a good question and yes i
did read the chat i can't believe it
myself
why don't more top players go for the
fried liver the knight g5 lines it's
because they're more forcing that
in those positions
if we go back here there is so much more
theory and computer engine preparation
whereas the game continuation
is a bit vaguer
where you can
like sort of
wander around and try to find a way to
outplay your opponent on the board
rather than over the engine preparation
so i do think that players like to go
for these lines and just
go for it at the board to their own
devices um
it's really a rich opening with many
different variations
and i think vidit might have been
inspired by his opponent yesterday that
night a3 variation was quite cool
and we see he has just castled here so
uh for now well no repeat um
of yesterday but we we shall see um how
this game develops
shall we have another look robert at the
the bird's eye view
let's do just that we have all games
just getting underway here uh looks like
caruana against dubov they've followed
some spanish variations the roy lopez
we can get into that there has been a
grunfeld in pragmata against grendelius
it looks similar in karjakin against
giri so if karyakov was queen a4 check
he will enter the similar lines that we
saw pragnanda play
and that can be awkward when two players
who are playing quite near to one
another they repeat lines and mama jarv
against by the way you mentioned that
first look at that game there's no
queens on the board everything's been
traded off so
maybe we should head there first
in case uh we miss
anything major yeah let's head to my
media free and study it's funny that
those two games which are mirrored so
far i think we were both on site it was
such a
funny story in the isle of man i'm so
bad with the years but i think 2019
2019 that's correct 2019
uh when two games were mirroring each
other
in this case were quite at the early
stages but they mirrored each other for
over 20 moves and the problem with that
was they were sitting one next to
another one of the four players was uh
karjakin funnily enough so he might be
involved
once again uh sheriff i've forgotten who
was playing who you probably remember
robert you yang yi and alexei dreyev
were the four players exactly and they
ended up actually moving one of the
boards to another playing hall to
preserve the player's peace of mind
because there had been a big group of uh
of spectators and just gathering around
around that so i'd never seen anything
like that before or after
and i was playing in the tournament and
i just remember that all of a sudden
they're picking up a you know like a
chess board and bringing it over and i'm
like why is sherov on the last board
like he's doing well in this tournament
and it's because of that incident it was
uncomfortable it generally speaking is
when players are going deep into their
preparation and like wait do i play what
that person's about to play or do i you
know sit and figure out what i should do
it's just not a good place to be in so
uh we're just joking and referring to
that but in this game uh the move c5 was
played by yanchez of duda and that's a
relatively rare move it is still
comments played thousands and thousands
of times but at this point in the game
there are so many options for black c6
getting into the triangle position that
we've seen in many games already you
could bring your bishop out to b4 these
kind of vienna positions are
quite fighting so in this game we see c5
into a semitash and after cd5 we don't
see
the move knight takes d5 which duda
played against pragnanda instead he
chooses c takes d4 and now fiona we're
getting into this variation that i'm
pretty positive i've seen gujarati play
a number of times in the last couple
years where the queens come off the
board here and white plays knight g5 so
temporarily down a pawn but you're
immediately winning the pawn back the
white king can castle as it has done in
the game black's king is going to be
stuck in the center but
players have shown that this variation
you get the bishop pair and eventually
you win your pawn back you check
here
then take this knight and you win your
pawn back on e4 the players from the
black side of this position fiona have
shown that honestly it looks a bit iffy
your king's in the center but it's not
that bad
yeah i mean i'm i'm curious
if you can enlighten us
the only difference is here in terms of
pawn structure is white has just one
pawn island on the king side with the
pawns on
f2g2h2
while black has two pawn islands there
with
the isolated pawn on h6 and then the
pawns on e6
and f5 so i guess one of the questions
is how much of a problem
is that
but then we also see that the bishops
are of opposite colors so if if we
picture a scenario where the knights
come off the rook maybe come off that
would always just be
a dead draw but the question is where is
white's
um supposed to come from here
yeah we have to assess sort of the pros
and cons of this opposite colored bishop
dynamic and when you have bishops of
opposite colors you need to note that
you i mean this is kind of obvious and
sort of inherent to the nature of having
obstacle bishops that black will fight
for the dark squares white for the light
squares so when pawns are on light
squares the dark square bishop has more
space in front of it it's got a longer
scope but the problem of having pawns on
light squares in particular pawns on e6
and f5 is that they're
can be attacked by the light square
bishop and a pawn chain is only as
strong as its base pawn if you know this
pawn e6 that looks quite loose you'd
probably want to put your pawn back on
f7 that would be black's best move here
and we are in a new position so that's
why duda is sitting and thinking because
um
rajab and carlson have played uh this
variation before i they played it during
the pandemic years where online in some
of the champions chess tour the chess 24
events knight c5 has been a choice
immediately putting some pressure on the
pawns probably trying to provoke this
move b6 to open up the light squares
over on the queen side so knight g3 is a
new choice and i guess as i am sort of
going all over the place trying to talk
about the whole dynamics here this e6
pawn is the most problematic piece on
the board for now
yeah and we see that uh duda has gone
into the tank for the first time shakia
blitzing out all his moves so clearly
this
is his preparation i guess white's idea
is to try and put pressure on that point
you've highlighted e6 as fast as
possible bringing the bishop to c4 if we
can we have to be a bit careful while
the king is still on c1 to not run into
any trouble with a pin along the the c
file but in generally i bring a bishop
to c4 a rook to e1 and target the
weakness on e6 as fast as possible
and it's not like black is well
developed either white has a rook that's
in the game thanks to the queen's eye
castle a knight in the game that's
hopped around quite a bit and so black
needs to be careful right now it may
seem like
five different moves look pretty decent
knight c6 bishop g7 uh one other move
that
comes to mind for me i i'm not sure if
it's any good is move h5 to try to go h4
to kick this knight out of its g3 square
because uh that knight right now
could even go to h5 which is quite a
nuisance for black to deal with in many
different positions it's a light square
can't be kicked out very easily and it
limits the scope of this bishop so h5
makes sense to me knight c6
if that move were to be played it
wouldn't shock me but bishop c4 rookie
one happens so fast that i'm very
worried about the location of the black
king
yeah i think a lot of things to consider
here
uh for duda i think he's just going to
have to decide with a long-term plan
figure out how he's going to deal with
the weakness on e6 and i think we'll
leave him for now because as you said a
lot of different options
and very often the players when they get
faced when they are faced with a new
move they will take some time so we are
back in the bird's eye view
to see what else maybe of the games we
haven't looked at yet uh robert is
anything drawing your attention
uh let's see so
so many options here i see that yes
panko has not castled yet he played h6
still
going into familiar territory the game
between caruana and dubov i'm in general
curious about these two players and
their opening preparation they're two of
the best on the planet uh dubo of course
has worked with magnus carlson in world
championships past five minute caruana
has played a world championship against
magnus carlson so
trying to learn from them see what
theoretical lines that they're diving
into and
one part about this if we bring up the
game is that fabiano is actually
has more time they started with and
dubov has spent about 10 minutes that's
not a lot of time to spend but for
somebody as well prepared as do buff
typically is maybe that's not the best
sign fiona yeah it's
especially in this tournament so far
we've seen uh
duboff two days ago he made a draw
against karjakin and ended up with more
time on the clock than he started with
yesterday he was also the one to spring
the surprises uh on with it so maybe we
can go back
to the start of the game here and as you
highlighted i think very important dubai
was already part of team magnus for the
match against fabiano of course things
changed a lot uh in four years but still
he is very familiar with fabiano as a
player and and with his openings
and it's interesting because in that
match magnus was playing c5 the sicilian
uh against fabiano but here duboff
chooses to play solly play the king's
pawn and this bishop e7 move rookie one
b5 this is mainline stuff played it i
can't even tell you how many times i
wouldn't be surprised if it's hundreds
of thousands at this point a bishop b3
castles
a4 so
we've seen magnus play rook b8 he even
did that against dubois he did it
against um
jana panashi i almost forgot john's name
in the world championship
[Laughter]
these types of moves but bishop b7 is
very principle are you developing you're
making sure your rook is defended in the
event of a pawn trade because previously
it was left hanging and now d3
d6
and c3 so another interesting choice
because here white can play the move
knight c3 which applies pressure on this
pawn on b5 and it also
let's say after the move knight a5 is
possible b4 is possible you can move
this knight even into the d5 square so
you're playing first with your pieces
rather than with your pawns but fiona i
think you had
some insights or things to note no sorry
i was just i was like curious as well uh
openings aside you know fabiano so well
he started with three draws yesterday
was maybe a somewhat frustrating game
and not getting anything from this um on
the white side of the the berlin wall
against sam and then in the end even
having to defend how impatient does
fabiano get when he is after these three
draws and now with the white pieces how
much risk do you think he is willing to
take today
i don't think he's a major risk taker in
the sense that he is going to lose his
objectivity he's a very very practical
pragmatic player he wants to assess the
board and he's going to choose openings
that will maximize in his opinion his
winning chances but he's not the type of
player who's going to play g4 on move
three right that was a fun thing that we
saw from mambajar but that's not
fabiano's style and i also don't think
he's rattled he understands that in
chess at the highest level that draws
happen with regularity so three draws
against three very strong players i
don't think that's going to bother him
and in this game you know if he can get
a win in this one for example he'll go
to plus one which is a great score in
this field after four rounds so he takes
it generally speaking game by game a
move by move of course like any human
there are things that will bother him
there are if he's not playing his best
chess he's not making the most of
opportunities that's going to get under
his skin but i think a new day is a new
day for him and that's not always the
case for other players indeed and today
well he has the other added benefit that
uh for duboff sometimes it's tough to
two rounds back uh from a loss
especially what was quite a painful loss
for him
yesterday but yes back to the game so uh
fabiano chose instead an approach not
with knight c3 but by putting the pawn
on c3 instead
and we're already in very rare territory
because
at this point here
the knight can come to d2 first we've
mentioned in previous days in previous
games that the knight often re-routes
over to the king side to squarely g3 or
e3 but here fabiano leads with the
bishop another idea by the way is knight
a3 which is very clearly attacking this
pawn on b5 putting some pressure and my
honestly my opening knowledge will end
right about here i i don't i think queen
d7 just to protect uh makes sense and i
mean the position is very complicated
because no pieces have been traded and
fabiano going for a rare continuation
with bishop to g5 and i have to imagine
that this
d5 square will be important whenever you
see pawns two squares away like this e5
and c5 you know that the square in
between is one you want to take
advantage of so if this knight does get
to e3 you will get that d5 square and
it's true in
many different sicilian positions and in
a spanish where black has committed the
pawn to c5
and i think once again this is a
position where
i might pick your brain about all the
tensions we see uh here uh first of all
on the queen side there is this tension
with the pawn on a4 and on b5
looking at one another so the question
is does white i guess black never wants
to take but when does black white want
to take um the other question about
tensions is in the center does white
ever want to go d4 does he just want to
try and play for this outpost
on a d5 does black ever want to push one
of his pawns so a lot to consider in
terms of the pawn structure here well
you only asked me like one question
there so it's gonna be easy to answer
um i i think you more or less answered
one of the questions immediately that
because black doesn't really want to
take on a4 white isn't in a huge rush to
take on b5
taking on b5
can help black in the sense that you
make this rook active and
there is a bit of an issue for white
down the a file if you're not careful so
one idea that black often plays is the
move pawn to b4 not necessarily in this
position but in positions where you
played
your pawn at b5 you're pawn to c5 and
you're not on a5 b4 is a common idea but
that loses your grip on all of the light
squares so you push your pawn now you
don't have to worry about a takes b5 but
you see in a position like this white
controls all these squares thanks to
this bishop on a2 it's not the end of
the world for black black is creating
new tension on the queen side but still
that's a big concession that's not going
to go away anytime soon so for black as
i look at this position i mean the first
move honestly that comes to my mind is
h6 because the
bishop was put on g5 but then you have
to wonder was the bishop put on g5
simply to take on f6 and then why did i
play h6 if that was the idea white is
probably going to go for that anyway and
so is h6 helpful to me
not especially we know what white wants
to do knight d2 knight f1 knight e3 and
getting d5 will be very difficult for
black because even if you don't lose a
pawn immediately this pawn on e5 you
hand white a lot of the light squares if
those bishops get traded you have kind
of bad dark square bishop staring into
your own pawn so just like in king's
indian positions that bishop can be
quite a bad piece here we see the bishop
doesn't have the clearest future yeah so
instead of h6 we see that daniel decided
to go for a move you mentioned a couple
of minutes ago queen to d7
yeah and it protects b5 and you asked
the question does black want to take now
white does need to be careful about that
we didn't want to take a move ago
because then we're left with an isolated
pawn on uh a6 and a knight that's
hanging on a5 this bishop takes f7 check
ideas to work
together with these
rook and queen here so that actually for
example bishop c6 i think queen takes a5
is which is winning a pawn you sacrifice
your queen just to win it back that is
check the rook opens up and white is a
pawn ahead so taking on a4 is out of the
question immediately but after the game
continuation with uh queen to d7 here
now
perhaps we do take on a4 and if white
doesn't gain that pawn back black has
opened the b file for rook the bishop
can slide up to c6 to defend that a4
square so now
fabinho does have to really consider or
he's just well prepared he's already
considered it can i give away that a4
pawn is that something i can allow if
the answer is yes he'll just develop his
knight probably to d2 if the answer is
no we'll see him take on b5 first yeah
it's uh well we will see fabiano taking
his time for the first time in this game
we see that he's already gotten a
15-minute edge on the clock meaning he
had played all his moves
instantly up to this point and now well
we will see uh i would be surprised if
quindy d7 came as so much of a surprise
to him
but we'll come back to this game i
suggest robert that we quickly go to the
bird's eye view
have a look that we're not messing
anything dramatic and then we'll go to
our first quick break of the day and
come back with all the action here
at the start here definitely the most
interesting game is mama jarvis duda
with that king on e7 uh duda did just
develop his knight he put h5 first so
uh he moved his h pawn and then brought
his knight to d7
that means rook c8 is an available
option his rook can maybe come to h6 at
some point
but
rookie one does look a bit frightening i
have to acknowledge that unless rook c8
and that pin that you mentioned earlier
fiona that may be the problem that
allows black to get away with this kind
of slow developing try
yeah we just saw my media on the on the
camera thinking about these options so
that's definitely one of the interesting
games we'll come back to in a second i
know there's also a lot of prague fans
uh in the chat so we'll definitely look
at his game against glendale's but for
now we'll take our first quick break of
the day and we'll be back with all the
action here from round four in just a
few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome again in vikings a shrek stands
for forbidding for bending here in the
dorby
fence over the hills
a
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back round four here in vikenzie
and robert unfortunately we already have
our first result of the day
what do you mean unfortunately you know
i love early draws and draw offers so
i'm very happy to see that game conclude
uh
i don't know what to say fiona
we didn't even have time to look at it
we saw
uh it was a grunfeld and uh well maybe
we can just we don't want to spend too
much time here but uh see the the quick
repetition that the players found
and this is a known variation and you
can't really blame anish giri for this
he is the black pieces he's playing a
very very strong player and at this
point in time after the move queen a5
knight to d2
castles
here white has some options bishop e2 i
believe is a move here a knight b3
of course played the game rook c1 which
does give up the a2 pawn in some lines
but gets some quick activity so
here the move knight b3 was chosen and
after queen takes t3 check bishop d2
let's count the squares that this queen
can safely go to no no no no no no no
no no no no no oh okay and no over there
and no there so we only have one choice
and after bishop c1 i'm not gonna do all
the same highlights but the queen can
only go back so the draw by repetition
is forced from black's perspective at
this point uh karjakin lost yesterday's
game he probably is not in a great mood
after his blunder his huge mistake
against isapanko so he's like let me
just get to the rest day and that is
something we see top players do fiona is
after a bad result they just want to
make sure that the losing stops that is
true and i also my feeling is that um
very often before the rest day
we see more peaceful rounds i don't
think we're going today to see i don't
want to
i don't want to bring any drinks in but
i don't think we'll see four decisive
results like we did yesterday because i
think on top of what you said about
karjakin not wanting
to take too much risk after losing
yesterday i also think tomorrow is the
first rest day and in general the
players don't want to go into the rest
day on the loss
so i think in general those rounds tend
to be more peaceful but here with so
much uh so many
rating differences i mean it's such a
diverse field i don't think we'll see
all quick draws and thankfully uh
thankfully that is so i think we'll go
back to the bird's eye view and see what
other interesting games that we still
have um going on here which is most of
them yeah the games do look quite
interesting especially the pragnanda
grandelias game the shanklin report game
is also heating up about one game i do
want to go back to just if you don't
mind quickly fiona is the one between
mama jarvan duda because i was thinking
about a number of variations during the
break and if we just go back a few moves
here after knight to g3 i actually i
mentioned h5h4 but i did it in a way
that was like that's my dream i didn't
actually think h5 would be that great of
a move with the king on e7 but i
understand it much better now that i put
some real thought into it and the reason
why is knight to d7 that looks like a
very natural move bringing your knight
close to the king but then there's
bishop to b5 now your knight's under
attack twice and i'm just trying to play
rook to e1
very straightforward chess if you say
move your knight to a square like b6
then i'm going to bring my rook to e1
and now i'm threatening knight takes
pawn on f5
if you bring your king to f6 i have a
knight h5 check which we mentioned
earlier it's very annoying and the
knight can often reroute to the square
f4 because the knight on f4 will put
even more pressure on e6 and if you make
a move like king to f7 then bishop d7 is
a really nasty idea i'm just going for
your e6 pawn if your knight takes the
bishop to remove the immediate threat a
new one lands and the b7 pawn is lost so
i think that's the reason why
duda instead of moving his knight where
he could also have gone to c6 that would
allow knight h5 knight f4 type of ideas
the bishop can't develop because g7 is
under this knight's control and then
even g3 bishop g2 fianchetto rookie one
white's play is just much too easy very
natural moves and black on the other
hand has difficulty adjusting to this
dynamic and it says about level slightly
better for white but fiona i think that
it's just much much easier to play from
zero's perspective it's incredible to
see just how fast after a new move like
knight to g3 if you're not careful as
black just how fast you can already get
into
some very concrete uh trouble here
yeah and the move h5 i mean seriously
like i i didn't mean it as like oh i
know for sure i was like oh i would love
to kick this knight away because the
knight has to go back but the reason why
it's so good is now after bishop c4
knight to d7 there's the pawn is already
on h5 so if bishop b5 were to be played
it looks similar but the pawns here
rather than h6 now once this knight
jumps let's say it goes to b6 and the
rook comes to uh e1 going for this e6
pawn the king can go to f7 because after
bishop to d7 now we see why it's so
important the pawns on h5 rook h6 is a
possibility defending the pawn e6 and
now why did you put your bishop on d7 it
looks really awkward it's actually not
that helpful because black has covered
all of his bases and now the dark sword
mission will develop this rook on a8
will get out of there and black as you
see is actually better so clearing the
h6 square really important and this
particular line showcases why
indeed and while shack had no interest
in putting the bishop there instead kb1
makes a lot of sense we talked about the
c file
earlier you don't want to keep your your
king behind the bishop and run into some
rook c8 with trouble
because now well you're a bit late
already if you maybe there are still
ways like i guess there are
complications maybe after rook takes e6
but you're not in time
um well this is also not the way so i'm
curious robert what is the way is it
with knight f5
uh i was thinking we were not in time to
play b3 because of b5 but maybe
then
there is some
knight f5
yeah actually this
it looks like it should be pretty good
for black because you're winning this
bishop but and it does say that black is
slightly better uh this king if it goes
to d8 oh hates that oh my gosh that's
why look at this you're attacking this
pawn on b5 and after pawn takes c4 and
96 check i don't think you really want
to walk your king to the e file but you
have no choice because your kings out of
options so this would at the very least
win back i think knight c5 check is good
even knight takes a fate is possible but
you're winning this night here on d7 and
white is well ahead
yeah so uh a mess here and shah said
no thanks i'm just gonna put
my king uh to be one instead avoid all
of this messiness
but keep my own threats very much alive
after uh king b1 of course his next idea
is to bring the rook to e1 put pressure
on e6 put pressure along the e file
knight f5 will still be a threat and i
think uh do that we see him sitting
there
at the board he already has some some um
very serious questions to answer here
he does because if you think you're just
going to play h4 and kick this knight
away you're going to be in trouble with
this knight on d7 being loose and this
knight can reroute itself to e2 maybe
into f4 or d4 so this e6 pawn is going
to remain an issue i guess h4 is
possible i actually thought it was not
going to be a good move
at least tactically it looks very iffy
but apparently h4 still is okay for
black i just getting into that territory
where one mistake could even lose due to
the game not just end with the worst
position absolutely and robert i'm
laughing because i see iraqis in the
chat is asking is hess a bit calm down
from yesterday i don't think i can
handle that much excitement two days
in a row yesterday really was a special
day but robert would you be ready for a
repeat of the madness we saw yesterday
you know there is a rest day tomorrow so
i am going to give it my all before i
get some rest and i did promise that
we'd go to the pragmananda game against
grandelias because if any game is going
to get me as excited as the vivid game
did yesterday i believe it's that one
because there's a pawn on h4 there's
potential for an attack
the black king does look safe and tucked
away for the moment but whenever i see
h4
simon williams is somewhere right fiona
he's very happy to see this kind of move
indeed he
i was the one that famously dubbed the h
pawn harry the h pawn um i think he'll
be watching that game and he will be
approving of what prague has done here
maybe we can go back to the the start of
the game and see how we got here for
sure it was a grunfeld and unlike the
game between
karjakin and giri this queen a4 check
was played and it seems like a very
strange move because black can block the
check with the bishop and then attack
the queen
but then white can sit this queen on a3
which is what happened in the game and
in these types of positions black is in
the grunfell generally speaking black is
playing for c5 and with the queen
sitting on a3 like this it seems very
difficult to make c5 work so you give
black a developing move but the bishop
is not very impressive on d7 if the
knight goes to c6 it will not be
impressive there upon three squares away
dominates a knight and the c3 pawn in
combination with the d4 pawn makes that
knight look a bit useless so that's why
we saw knight to d7 here in the game
blocking the check
knight f3 castles queen a3 and still c5
it's a temporary pawn sacrifice but
fiona in the grunfeld it's all about
this fianchetto bishop
indeed gruenfeld a very active opening
where very often black is even happy to
give up some material
um
to to activate that bishop on g7 which
is the all-important uh square
the all-important piece
yeah well also square because if you
don't have the piece there then the
square is quite uh vulnerable so d takes
c5 not a movie you really want to play
from what you see the evaluation tank
because black plays queen c7 goes right
after this pawn and if you say i'm going
to protect my pawn i'm going to try to
be greedy while b6 is played you can't
take on b6 you lose c3 the bishop on g7
reigns supreme over the position so
these kind of decisions are sort of made
for you when you play this opening
bishop e2 if there's a swap on d4 not a
big deal
b6 and then h4 so i love this move fiona
and part of the reason i love it is it
encouraged neil's to play e5 because
when we're getting attacked some players
think we need to react on that side of
the board but one great method of
defense is attacking the center
especially with the white king still
sitting here now e5 does just that it
strikes in the center tries to hit the
d4 pawn but look what pragmata does he
goes d5 and now this bishop on g7 it
turned from a grunfeld bishop which was
open trying to slice through the
position into more of a king's indian
bishop which is staring into its own
pawn so i really like the nuance here by
pragnando because i think strategically
he now has an advantage even if
objectively for now the position is okay
going forward this is a big deal where
you have a protected past pawn in the
center and this bishop on the dark
square is blocked by its own pawn indeed
a very interesting fight coming up here
but robert i actually
we've got a little surprise for you and
a little surprise for our viewers as
well so we're gonna go to a quick break
get something set up and be right back
so stay tuned you don't want to miss
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up manish hi robert your room
looks so sad man where do you live
uh you know you could i'll invite you i
won't tell everybody on stream where i
live but i'll let you know i'll just
shoot you a message real quick but uh
speaking of sad
what happened in today's game i mean
that was that's that's a good segue sure
no i was uh yeah it was quick i have to
say especially you know i i thought uh
yeah
you wouldn't do it this way but um sure
possible also is it short move
repetition in the greenville probably
that that exists you can do a lot of
longer ones if you
well i think we all wanted a bit of a
longer game from you so uh you know you
go into the rest day you
have one half of the four i'm sure not
the result you're looking for of course
uh but is this the type of game you get
to just relax a little more and if two
rest days in a row
well you know as they say in such cases
that today's game was not the it's not
the one to blame you know for for my
standing
and i have to say blank sergey uh who
also lost yesterday uh i was uh
really preparing myself for a very
dangerous game for a battle because he's
a very good player and i thought he um
he would definitely give it a shot i
don't know how much risk he would take
but i didn't know but i thought he would
definitely give it a shot
i i guess i surprised him with grunfeld
and then he just didn't have anything
ready and he decided to just call it a
day
but yeah
i have to definitely um
yes
some say do better
well how much do you think this has to
do with him playing the candidates later
like even if he has something up his
sleeve right when you're playing in a
candidate's year you don't want to play
your new opening ideas before that no
it's not that i i think
uh he just didn't expect griffith at all
uh because if you expect it a little bit
you can come up with some kind of a
small try that is a little bit better
than this uh
i just think it was more him thinking of
like i don't know
the knight of six e6 and the slav maybe
and maybe not considering griffith at
all which is
i don't know a little bit odd because i
think i played it a couple of times last
year
but yeah
i don't know also sometimes you don't
know like people uh
um yeah i don't have the mood like i'm
definitely like feeling like i have to i
have to do something i feel like i want
to give it a shot in this tournament
obviously it's many rounds to go
but maybe he
yeah maybe he doesn't like the way he
thinks things are going and uh they
didn't want to fight it uh today at 20
well he did lose yesterday's game
against andreas panko after was
uncharacteristic mistake from him so why
don't we if you don't mind if we go to
the game between vidit and uh yes panko
your buddy did it and what has gotten
into him
yeah he's played well i mean the first
round was just a normal game he played
sam shankland uh and he was playing a
good game sam uh had some opportunities
to defend he didn't and we did one was
characteristic usually he did let's say
uh then um
yeah he made a draw with hobby with
white that was also nothing nothing
spectacular but then of course he had
that game with duboff and
i've been in that situation myself as
well a few times you know you are not
really
the headline maker you are just
getting surprised
you are in a dangerous position and you
just try to fight for your life and as
you fight for your life somehow the best
of your qualities um come come out and
you and you've been a great gamer i mean
i've had that happen to me a lot and in
some way we have similar some of our
traits
mind and video
are similar so in some way we have a
little bit of a similar style and so
such games can happen you know when um
when pushed with the back against the
wall um
um yeah he just played really really
well and uh i did think like his defense
deserved more than half a point and then
as duke blundered
i thought that yeah well it's uh it's
happening i i mean i have to say that
also for daniel it's very unfortunate i
mean
you know it's so rare that your opponent
gets to defend such a position and he
was putting pressure very well as well
so it was very unfortunate for him for
danny but he got zero points out of that
game
yeah it was a beautiful game through and
of course uh with the f3 move was the
big culprit but to find queen check
queen g4 you know it's within daniel's
very much for sure for sure i remember a
game of his uh against swan
i think it was funny right there this
very very famous game where he was
chasing the king to like a3 i believe
and then uh
actually
daniel sometimes
has these calculation errors but when it
comes to like chasing the king and stuff
he can be very good and i remember in
that game against swan
it was a european team championship i
think he found a very very beautiful and
a difficult sequence of moves to check
made the king
and so in that sense i am actually a
little bit surprised that he didn't um
that he didn't find that quincy a check
but at the same time you have to imagine
that in context of the whole game it's
like you know you have this uh
it's a bit like this i don't know tennis
or table tennis battles you know when
you keep smashing and the guy returns
you keep smashing the guy returns and
after you smash so many times at some
point yeah you just like you don't even
touch the ball anymore because like you
can't believe that he keeps returning
the the smashes i think that's more or
less what happened like he was he was
just so shocked that you know
and and i i think he was yeah if he was
in a good state he would have found
quincy and chrissie g46
is a kind of a study-like thing that
someone with imagination of daniel is
very capable of finding
i agree it was a long exhausting game
i'm sure both players had a rough night
asleep they slept like a baby but still
were exhausted when they woke up and how
about we transition to today's game
because vinit was in that battle
yesterday and now we have a completely
mirrored image the board is the same
through and through so what do you think
vid is aiming for by for starters he
played e4 on the first move which
undoubtedly caught andre off guard
a little bit maybe i i do think with it
has played
i'm trying to think how often he's
played e4
yeah okay it's not his uh probably not
the most often played move by with it
but okay you know it's when you play top
tournament like uh
andre knew this tournament is coming up
for so long he didn't play the european
rapid sorry world rapid and blitz so
he's still taking that time to prepare
clearly and you know when you prepare
for top tournament you have something
prepared for e4 so i don't think he was
shocked to see that move it's the best
by test so called yeah the italian
bishop b6 system i think it's it's a
system that andre borrowed from
his match against magnus where he was
playing with the white pieces battling
against that system every day in the
world cup and magnus was playing this
bishop b6 business
and now um
did we play a4 or not that's the move
that andre played and now
yeah andre played it with 9297 first
but anyway transposed
we should be 36 knight f1
yeah interesting uh
situation now of course it's symmetric
but at the same time white has an extra
tempo and the question is is black going
to mirror with rookie eight allow d4
or is black going to try to
try to be the first one and start with
d5 which i suspect is the the way to go
and after ed5 knight d5 d4 we keep the
symmetry but after ed knight d4
we've got that control of the e-file and
what often happens here is rookie eight
uh trade trade bishop d5 cd and then you
play
this kind of position where you've got
an isolated pawn but you have a bishop
pair and i i think that i've seen this
position before
as well i think it's some sort of theory
we might see that happen because if
rookie 8 now instead of d5 then you've
got a uh
reply to d4 because if you don't strike
back right away with something like d5
which probably doesn't work
probably doesn't work i mean
isn't isn't this uh
territory where
i guess i don't know this position uh
that well but these kind of positions
were the rook and bishop of four and e5
yeah usually
yeah
yeah so you can't maintain the symmetry
this way so sort of the symmetry is
temporary yeah we are definitely going
to see some something some what also
people sometimes do is they go bishop e6
uh you can do it right now
no move move earlier here as well but
maybe move earlier okay you can do that
sort of always and play this position if
it takes then takes
or d4 yeah
and then at least you gotta trade the
pair of bishops
but yeah
i think i think d5 i mean pretty sure d5
is the way to go uh and i suspect that
andre will play it as well um
i mean when we look at this position as
you said white has that extra tempo and
if you get d4 and it should be pleasant
at the very least so when you're making
these decisions and you seem to know
this position you study it and if you
haven't studied it do you think a player
like andre is more likely to accept the
isolated pawn knowing that that is a
weakness that he'll have to deal with
but at least he can work around it or
just allow you know a situation like
this where d4 happens before you know
black gets that play himself
well generally when um
when we play these italian positions
nowadays
we sort of tend to tend to think that if
white gets d4 uh without blacks able to
strike back in the center or without
black having grabbed a lot of space on
the queen side
with like b5 a4 which sometimes happens
the white should be a bit better so
as a rule uh your first instinct is to
try and avoid uh getting yourself into
that position where white has more space
uh and so d5 is really the principled
way to go and of course the
justification is that if you take on d5
95 and 95 which would be the question i
suspect there is some takes in bishop f2
kind of trick uh there
king of two queen f6 and this is sort of
a standard tactic that the whole thing
is based on and i mean uh andres knows
this uh inside out and i suspect he also
knows this position but i'm wondering
why he thinks this long although
actually both of them take a lot of time
uh beat it as well so maybe they're just
trying to you know take the time make
sure they're not
confusing things
yeah and as we're talking about i think
andre even if he's familiar with the
position he almost certainly didn't
study it for today's game because vidi
usually does play d4 he played against
carwana earlier in the event but uh you
know both players are doing well whereas
what i suspect with andre is that he
thinks he thought that since he knows
this a lot with white he can play it
with black but you know if this was not
his uh the direction he was looking at
with white then he doesn't know it you
know what i mean like he was going for
d4 with the knight on d2
these are very different uh positions
and now he realized that this is not
what he prepared with white and he's
trying to figure out why not
um
but yeah you can see his hand movement
he's calculating d5 ed there's a hand
movement you know knight d5 d4 yeah it's
coming it's coming d5 there it is yeah
question for you though when you play an
opening from one side do you enjoy
playing it from the other side as well
or do you hate it because you like it
from
like let's see plane opening is white do
you not want to play that same opening
for the black side because you prefer to
play it as white yeah it's a very
interesting question
i was thinking about these things a lot
uh because you know one of the strengths
of players
is
uh being self-aware and knowing
what positions you play well because you
know many people are very delusional and
it's easy to be delusional because of
your arrogance you think you play
everything well
and you think okay i lost that game once
and whatever and you know in the french
defense yeah because i had bad luck that
time i also lost because you know i
slept badly that time i was lost because
you know i was not even trying to
concentrate but you know
you have to be self-aware and try to go
for things you you're good at and i was
thinking indeed
whether being good at an opening with
one side makes you good at this position
with the other
because essentially maybe it's just the
fact that you understand the position as
a whole you know what i mean
helps you play it with both sides
i'm not sure
i'm not sure you have so many of these
positions where one side is attacking
the king and the other side is playing
on the queen side and you have so many
players who only want to play um
the attacking you know for the for the
king so i don't know i don't know
honestly position like that this italian
it's
you can be pretty good at both sides
because it's pretty pretty simple but
it's about these asymmetric ones that
are much more complex some kind of kinks
indian you know uh that for example
today i think we saw it in arjuna
geysers game i think that that was a
king's indian
um
there it's much more different because
it's very asymmetric
yeah that's for sure i mean this right
as you're saying the position is pretty
much the same except the rook is on e1
versus the rook on f8 um
before we hop to another game besides
rookie eight i mean another move that
comes to mind is bishop c7 for black uh
rerouting that bishop into a new
diagonal i'm wondering if at some point
black can think of putting a knight on
f4 as well so we reset rookie eight that
is a
position that i feel like i've seen
before but is there some merit to the
move bishop c7 here yeah for sure there
i mean there is merit to not playing
rookie rookie 8 because if you don't
know about the sequence with taking and
taking on d5
you might assess it as very uh
you might just think it's better for
white because besides the d5 point
you've got the b5 square weakness and
this is pretty ugly though you can cover
it with a bishop bishop to somebody you
could try to stay away from this
position and indeed any other move than
rook 8 is possible and bishop c7 like
you said comes to mind as well
and then it's a question because uh now
we have some structural
trumps we've got this isolated point but
in bishop c7 you don't have that so we
can we can see instead we have the e
file
we can see what's in this
doesn't this feel like a video type of
position like from the white side
playing against an isolated pawn and it
doesn't seem very tactical in nature not
that of course he can handle tactical
positions we saw him do that yesterday
but this feels like the type position
that he ground sam scheinken down in
round one very different more pieces on
the board but still like that kind of
dynamic well there's definitely that
potential and if white trades the right
pieces imagine the dark squared bishops
leaving the board
some let's say some knight c2 takes
knight takes
uh and imagine now also queens
you know traded and the knight coming
like to d4 or whatever then of course
the white is much better at the same
time black still has the bishop pair and
that bishop from b6 is going to going to
go to c7
and
black at some point at least and black
will
you know might try to set up some sort
of
kingside
thing even at some point maybe knight h4
you you don't know uh b57 queen e5
lining up against
you know the king is pretty safe for now
but who knows who knows so
black has some
black has some ideas but
yeah it depends whether andre will go
for it like the move you said just the
bishop c7 looks also very natural
without burning any bridges
yeah and now now it's also later
sorry go ahead yeah it's a it's a
question how white will
proceed
you can develop the queen but also maybe
hope with a knight 125
and some knight df5 as a question for
example
um
i don't know if the knight is stable
there but it is quite threatening um
you know living with the bishop from b6
like on one hand it does a good job on
c7 but it was also doing a pretty good
job on b6
right
it's just one of these things that you
know if not for bishop c7 or rookie 8 do
we have a a third move because either we
have to accept an isolated pawn or we
remove our bishop from what has been a a
good looking diagonal to this point i
don't know
you know what sometimes happens like i
don't think it's here but there are
variations similar to this where black
does a crazy move bishop e6
it's not here but the point is there
that uh if knight is six fe then
suddenly there is a huge pressure on the
f2 pawn
i mean if that doesn't work like like 94
for example here i i think here it
doesn't work and then it's really like
really bad
but if it does then uh there is a line
like that there's a game i think of um
how you found against lebron aronian
from a world cup many years ago where
this kind of thing i think she took on
e6 in a similar position bishop of two
and it was king h1 i think it was kind
of
uh yeah very exciting complications and
um
so that that is a possibility sometimes
this bishop sees this crazy bishop is
six
there are options for black for sure
yeah and actually options are likely
what's making andre think so much right
now because he's familiar with those
types of positions but not this specific
one most likely and
that's a big mistake that players make
sometimes even at your level right a
niche where you've seen a familiar idea
so yeah that could work out and then
it's refuted because there's some subtle
difference in the position
yeah i mean that is there and also what
usually happens is the mistake is not
only that the mistake is that
you haven't anticipated your opponent's
going to play you know for example one
e4 or the italian and then you haven't
really repeated your file and you know
you've looked at so many things over the
past couple months
and yeah you don't really remember which
which was where and
yeah you've seen the things you've seen
the ideas but you don't quite recollect
and then sometimes trying to recollect
only hurts yourself because just playing
good position without knowing anything
can can lead to better results than
trying to recollect something
for sure and uh well why don't we hop
away from this game for the moment
because uh andre's still on the clock we
have six games still here yours of
course finished in the draw
so probably not as pawns in h5 so that
catches my eye which of these games
catches yours
uh i like that you said yours of course
i finished the draw
yeah let me see well the shanklin
rapport game uh it's it's my uh
uh
i know this because it's my uh
petrol of course it's not probably
accessible course yeah i have this
recommendation for white
to do this exact thing against the
petrov and i think they followed like
almost all the way
uh
for sure until move 11.
okay
better
so this is all a niche kiri
surprising that rapport played the
petrol right he's he's not the kind of
guy you expect to play the petrov but
there we are
that was my exact reaction i saw the
petrov and i was confused because
rapport i mean he's such a you know an
energetic player for the most part i
would not have thought that he was
playing that these days yeah richard is
really fascinating the combination of
his play
his demeanor and
like he's so random
so random
i think you mean that in a complimentary
way right oh hard to i predict random is
a very complimentary word
[Laughter]
uh well okay so you said through at
least 11 moves rookie one c5 yeah
i think that's also the the main line of
c4 bishop f5 knight e55 de5
now i think there's also a k8 here but
also bishop c5
and um
yeah you can take on c8 i i think this
is actually a game also of
jordan against friedman and and you're
inventor of d1 collecting the pawn
okay so here in bishop v3 rook b1
yeah
but black you know he's he did some f6
stuff and uh got some counter play i
think in that game
but you're the one anyway in the end but
bishop e3 is much simpler and now after
trade
um
a lot of simplifications but white does
have a bit of a
bit of a potential there and the
question now for example is if black can
play queen b6 trying to simplify further
because rook and game of course
has a tendency to be very drawish but
now white is still a bit better because
you're easy to pile up
on the open files against the pawns yeah
rugby one rook d1
yeah it looks like
i mean it looks to me like black might
just
be in some trouble but i guess the a2
pawn yeah i would go to k8 okay two you
know and simplify and for example if we
get four against three at some point
that's going to be good enough for black
to make a draw so i need to trade like
four points for three points
and uh
yeah sam will probably take the queen
there for sure and now but richie can
also play queen a5 instead queen music
is a bit too desperate you can play move
like queen a5
okay
and i mean but can't white just play
sort of uh you know f4 and play
you know advance on the king side
because white's foundation is very solid
and black will always have these pawns
yeah for sure i mean again after f4
black black is like has two ways of
dealing with this kind of stuff you can
just try to trade quiz with queen c5
or sometimes i'm not sure it's here but
you can try to
[Music]
do something about the pawn storm and go
for something like f6 but here it's very
suspicious but something like f6 if e6
and f5 try to isolate that pawn
it's it's it's sort of a standard way of
okay here is c7 wins but it's a standard
way of dealing with these um uh with
these spawn storms just that here you're
not in time you need one more tempo with
q5 here just 26 and it's lights out
because quincy
yeah sure enough forever yeah after f6
e6 you had to trade queens right away
probably but then if f6 e6 and queen
trade then you've got also f5 afterwards
i don't know yeah let's say queen c5
here
instead of f6 or maybe i don't know do
you want to include f6 so you don't
i mean i was just worried about f5 yeah
that's why this i'm not sure we want to
include f6
queen a5 is a bit on the slow side did
he play b6
he played b6 yes okay yeah the problem
with b6 is that you no longer uh have
that queen trade option
which is very tempting because you know
if i get these pawns going like the f1
goes to f6 it's like some checkmating
ideas are there
right and f4 seems automatic but i think
something that we keep highlighting is
that even in the event of these queen
trades like let's say we did that queen
c5 line can't white just trade and then
bring this king right to d4
yeah
you'll try to do that definitely and
then
because the pawn structure is somewhat
close and somewhat isometric
like struggling to find a way to trade
everything down yeah because
you you want to trade pawns uh as many
points as you can and open as many files
as you can but now with the king
marching to d4 i don't see indeed an
easy way for black
to somehow get rid of the pressure so
yeah i can't quite recall what exactly
why did you take on e3 by the way
maybe that is an inaccuracy yeah yeah i
think that that that's i think is an
inaccuracy from what i would say maybe
you told him to maybe in your you know
no no no my course is for white my
coursework so i'm only responsible for
what sam is doing
sam is my man
so okay you are in in a way indirectly
one of sam's seconds because you create
a whole course that yeah but sam is
second to everyone with so many courses
of his like yesterday he ended up
playing his own course right
yeah berlin
so rookie eight first uh that way you
can trade on your own terms and you you
know if the trade happens your rook
comes up to c5 too many courses you know
actually besides the courses courses
it's fine at least horses you have to
buy but you've got these youtube videos
as well
that are free and like there is one
youtube video if you look at mamijarov
duda perhaps the
the second the most uneventful game of
this round after a clear clear first one
i don't know what you're referring to
yeah
uh this end game you know it was
analyzed uh on youtube by
alexander khalifman
and you can just
check out those analysis really free of
charge which is very nice
okay um so we're in this game here
between mama jarvan judo you said this
whole thing has been prepared well i
mean uh for sure the opening and the
11 bishop g5h6 is also his
recommendation and then okay at some
point i think shakhria was on his own
and um he didn't get
he didn't get to press here like the
final position uh is comfortable for h5
is good
you want to be able to
to push h4 and you also need to actually
protect the e6 pawn that's your only
worry you need to somehow guard the e6
pawn uh
don't fall for like rookie 1 rook h695
yeah
but your arrows you know you are setting
up people for for blunders
well we went through this earlier don't
worry anish i actually was talking about
some of the nuances here for example
knight d7 the problem is that after
bishop b5 and the knight comes somewhere
like b6 or c5 and rookie one king f7
there's this move bishop to d7 so uh
with the pawn on h5 there would be rook
right here and that's a big difference
but now duda has got everything under
control right
in the game yeah it seems that way so if
we uh return to the game position his
last bunch of moves he brought knight to
e5
his game there's another
another reason why h5 is so important
there's no knight h5 check so
rookie one and
would you take black's position here
what happens if i sneeze if you like to
get disqualified
do you sneeze yeah i'm about to sneeze
i'm just warning you okay don't get
scared like it's not transmittable over
a webcam
no i i'm more i'm more concerned about
how loud it's going to be in my ear i
don't worry i don't think that you're
going to give me whatever little
sniffles you have do you guys do this
that's what she said jokes on the
broadcast or not
uh we have we've steered clear
but if i am going to sneeze at some
point don't worry
okay okay i'll make sure to keep a very
comfortable position for black like he's
got everything um he wanted uh from from
this and uh his only weakness which is
the a6 pawn is very well covered and his
pieces are very
good uh shaq has nothing here um
probably we'll try to just uh
simplify things further and actually i
could already think to prefer black
somehow i don't like the g3 knight at
all it's pretty awkward
yeah my coach growing up always said the
worst knights are those on b3 b6 g3 and
g6 they tend to tend to stay there too
long and then when they get kicked
around it's generally not very good for
uh for the side and i mean chakra he
doesn't look phased he kind of looks
like he's just hanging
yeah hanging you you will but uh
you know i mean as soon as like five
moves
happened in that game shaq already knew
that it's not gonna be fireworks
so i guess by now he's accepted the uh
his fa his fate there but i'm sure there
are more exciting games by the way that
that video is pencil game is it
it is
it is yeah it is exactly what i was
yeah it's sort of the engine uh
recommendations i'm not surprised the
cpan code produces it
he so just to
show everybody what happened rookie we
were talking about this exact line
isolated pawn on d5 bishop e3 and bishop
c7 so he did spend some time to get to
this point anish and
at the very least it looks pleasant for
white i get what you're saying that
black is the bishop pair of course that
black's mission is okay objectively
speaking but from the way optically it
would appear i would definitely prefer
to have the white side for sure i'm
trying to be annoying with black here
i'm trying to right now i'm threading
bishop take g3 i'm trying to be a little
bit annoying and that's all what i can
do
in return for my bad pawn structure so
now you have to decide like how do you
protect do you protect the knight on g3
or do you allow like do you protect the
bishop on e3 instead
and how would i even go about protecting
the bishop like which i'm going d32 uh
kind of move
it can get very concrete yeah 95 maybe
some
i don't know you can play queen b5 or
not
i like it
you're trying to trade queens this d5 it
makes me wonder if 95 was accurate maybe
bishop d7 first
yeah
and then i'm hitting the pawn if b3 i'll
go
yeah i have a feeling that
what you're doing so far is very decent
yeah not if
uh go ahead i said coming from you that
was a huge compliment that what i was
doing was decent i'll take it yeah for
sure for sure you know whenever i'm
complimenting you it's full of full
filled with sarcasm so don't get too
flattered
[Laughter]
but i'm a big fan in general of your
play robert and actually our last game
we played uh we played some tournament
on chess.com you're really tossing me
around so i have tremendous respect for
you
i i don't remember our game no i don't i
do i do remember that
okay um well here this position looks
very nice for white i mean if bishop
takes g3 i think we should show
everybody that the opposite color
bishop's position that's no problem to
have these double pawns for white and
this d4 outpost
for white's pieces the bishop on d7
that's the problematic piece
yeah the d4 outpost and like the
absolute control of that square is
really nice uh the knight is there
bishop can also be placed there and very
little counter play i wouldn't
rush taking on g3 with black frankly
that's really
selling your bishop player too short
like they say one of the advantages of
the bishop player is that you can get
rid of like you can trade one of them at
the right moment
uh but this maybe isn't the right moment
so just so easy to give up the bishop to
just double these pawns i don't think
it's worth it
i think that many people hear that
obstacle bishops positions are just
drawn which is very extreme and is not
the way you should look at chess but it
does hold true that in many positions
with those opposite colored bishops the
dynamics
when they're queens on the board you can
actually launch an attack you can
control certain squares and in
particular it's this d4 square and this
isolated d5 pawn in front of it that's
giving white the
uh the pluses of the position
yeah exactly like what you said with the
queens on the board the opposite color
bishops could make things more exciting
because you don't have the bishop to
protect all these squares right so then
the bishop uh the attack let's say if
you've got the dark bishop the attack on
the dark squares will be very hard to
defend from while with queens of the
board and also rooks heavy pieces of the
board with only the bishops of course
then the drawing droid tendencies are
super high you can give up a pawn or
even two sometimes and still be able to
block all the pawns so it's all about
having queens on the board or rooks on
the board that makes a difference but
let's see some other games we still have
a few games too
sure i was actually going to ask you to
you know channel your inner danny wrench
and read vidit's body language for us
but we can look at other chests that's
what danny does oh this is videos face
number 27. this is oh i forgot my
youtube password face
now and now i can get all my subs and i
have to ask anish for a raid when i
start a new channel
[Laughter]
no it's uh
yeah yeah it's it's a video phase which
is like you know i'll pretend i forgot
about my yesterday's game but deep
inside i'm still celebrating it with joy
wow i really prefer your analysis to
danny's don't tell him that but uh
that's good it's all good
let's go to the the uh pragmata grand
dealers game which you can see in the
bottom right hand side screen here
there's a pawn on h5 so obviously
it's very unusual what's going on i mean
this is this is the kind of griffith
game you want not the kind of grumble
game you get
i mean it seems strategically terrible
for black with his dark square bishop
white opening up the h5 looks almost
like a king india now it's
very interesting what has happened uh
white is able sometimes to give up the
dark square bishop if in return he gets
this dominance over the light squares
and there is definitely potential for
white to be much much better
strategically speaking you've got this
unquestionable um protected past pawn
and the full control over the light
squares and you've got that h pawn to h5
which is huge because if it's get
blocked on h4 it's very different story
and the way this happened in ish uh if
we go back it was a grundfeld uh where
white one queen a4 check
yeah it's a very broad sensible line
a3 back okay
and right here so h4 was played and i
was joking that simon williams would be
thrilled that harry the h pawn is going
up
niels played this with e5 and i actually
used the same reference that it went
from a grunfeld bishop which is happily
poking at
white center and it became a king's
indian bishop as soon as he went e5 so i
felt like that had to be the move that
was the culprit of getting black into a
bad position
well
yeah i mean e5 is something they do a
lot in the grim field and like peter
swiddler has had a bunch of games with
that it's a little different to king's
indian in that after e5 d5 you've got
the d6 square so often the night
reroutes itself there and the knight on
d6 is very efficient because it blocks
the deep one but also
uh
keeps an eye on the e4 and c4 squares
reinforcing b5 and f5 breaks
and i feel that niels maybe thought that
somehow by closing the center this way
yeah he weakens the h5 push but i'm not
quite sure how did he follow up like f5
right away is a bit
can i go a five right away or it's just
very bad um it could be it could be
actually
like a must as well you know it could be
bad it could also be like the best move
by far
nigeria got knight f6 i'm not that
scared
can i just try to you know
go for uh yeah it's a very wishful
thinking but i see what you're trying to
do
maybe i block it with the queen just
queen d6 can i
i guess you can but what if i just like
attack you everywhere i don't know i am
of course worried at the same time do
you have like f maybe f e or not bishop
to f5
you're a brave guy no i'm a c4 it's very
ugly i just c4 no no just c4 let's not
go fe let's go
i was thinking h6 can i even yeah h6 and
no no i wanted to go h6 with like
movable fp is a very bad move
maybe h6 with black and knight e6 maybe
i can take on
on
on e6 actually no no this is only give
up a fade
i mean i don't like it i'm just
trying i don't like taking this this is
very soft no this is very sauce no let's
go let's go back let's go back
okay but it was not so bad for me so f5
i like uh how did you play knight g5
knight f6 is only move quinn b3 now
let's see how i can
how i can treat that
d6 is a very big threat if i take only
four with the knight
i
i'm happy
but i'm happy if you take my exchange
probably
okay so then you're telling me that i
should just play yeah this is very ugly
i don't like just this position it looks
very sad i've uh yeah i'm i want a pawn
but it's an isolated pawn going to be
blocked with a bishop on e3
yeah then i'll probably and then you go
h5 c4 and i have
no knight to use the d4 square so it's
very sad i don't trade knights with
black
i don't mean to make you sad just just
for the record well i mean we are trying
to justify e5 which is by no means a
good move um
and it's not not even clear if b6 was
the right move but okay uh
instead of instead of e5 what about
bishop
b7 just
just
attack in the center
yeah are you going to go d5 or go h5 d5
maybe
i can't i can't decide between d5 e5 h5
e5 as well or e5 very very much very
much so
e5 very much so yeah i like that with
the knight on d7 it's very effective
because the weakness of the d4 pawn is
not so felt uh unlike the knights on c6
yeah i like that bishop b7 is also not
maybe cdcd first yeah what about cdcd
and then bishop b7
this looks
more to the point
yeah it's actually the same same thing i
could have traded there as well
yeah i'm lacking i'm lacking a little
bit of counter play here and i can place
my bishop on d5 but then you'll go h5
and i wonder what i've achieved
f6 comes a bit too late
i i often wonder what i've achieved so i
get the thought process
you're accommodating come on robert
[Music]
what about knight f6 by the way instead
because if knight f6 e5 i would have
knight
d5 square
but now i know h5 also haven't achieved
much
no not good not good
so maybe this is just a good line for
white it's what we're getting no no
black could also i mean b6 is a question
i don't think b6 is a must
so b6 is the
the move that
you wouldn't have gone for
we would find out certainly the game
would be more interesting if sergey went
for this line instead uh
what he did
there are also deviations earlier
but yeah uh here
b6 h4 e5 after d5 how did he proceed
so it went uh knight f6 and that's why
he has that bad bishop in the uh game
yeah bishop g5 again yeah
it just takes an h5 yeah this this is
h5 is a huge achievement bishop g4 kind
of playing into white's ah he goes back
yeah he goes back okay
nice i see he's trying to
somehow you make use of his bishop
player maybe he will reroute his bishop
to g5 that's where the bishop is more
attractive
and it's the question for white hop away
right i mean you're gonna go bishop g5
and i'm not going to let you take my
knight
no no the question here i would think is
whether you want to play c4 and kind of
fix
something or you keep that square for
for your pieces
well it's definitely a pleasant position
for white anish we're gonna head to a
quick break i don't know if you're gonna
stay with us you're welcome to you don't
have to no pressure either way but uh i
think people are loving that you're here
with us
how was the toxic chat
i don't read the chat so
i'm saying
chat is nice having banned like 200
users in the last two minutes she's like
it's very nice they're all very friendly
well i i was saying they're enjoying it
i don't know for a fact that they are i
just assume because who wouldn't you're
not reading the chat company
no that's not how you grow your game
robert
didn't we message one time where you
were on a stream on mute like you just
you weren't saying anything so you you
grow your game in unusual ways i'll try
to do it for myself as well we're going
to break we'll be right back for more
from tata steel 2022
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes welcome back everyone my name is
bick i'm the producer here so if
anything goes wrong you know who to
blame now uh we have the challenger
checkup right now every day next to the
master section we also have the
challenger section where we check in uh
to see how they are doing the winner of
the challenges section will be playing
in the master section yes next year so
there's a lot to play about there's not
the fight about and today i have a game
of maurizi versus pierre uh two grand
masters now playing in the group piero
actually was the one that we had on the
first day but now looking at for round
number three
we have a pretty equal position right
here uh the king is still central
black's king is already castles already
very safe so the first thing why do here
is the castle long make sure everything
is defended and knight trades off that
knight for the bishop and goes away
queen c7 to make sure everything is
handy danny we see a slight edge for
white because we have the open file here
for the rook but nothing too crazy just
yet now the next move rook to d6 is a
little bit provoking why doesn't black
just play b6 hit this pawn here it is
very weak it is for the simple reason
that we are going to double up we look
at this bishop if you play bishop e6
there's a bishop here on c6 as well
bada bing bada boom that is my rook row
so we cannot play that if you're
thinking about well i'm just going to
defend it that's going to be the way i'm
going to do it then we're going to take
away this pawn make sure the queen
is taking the pawn uh so you lose that
bishop so those are things that are
unfortunately nothing we can do so black
played rook to e5 hitting that pawn with
the rook very smart idea still looking
for the weakness
and after rook to d1 we have a little
bit of a
pressure on the uh
default and now bishop to a file which
is a very interesting move to make sure
we're all going to get out of the way it
makes all sense
boom we hit him with the a wait with the
e4
e4 is being played it's uh chasing the
bishop away not really by the way
because if a pin on the queen there's
nothing uh forward then
block queen h5 and here's where things
get interesting we see two rooks looking
at d7 and we see this queen hitting f7
so you have to make sure that f7 square
is defended so black plays a very normal
g6 defends everything and uh all is fine
and danny but after queen h4 we still
need to make sure that the bishop is
fine if you play something like bishop
e4 it is possible rook to d7 things can
get a little bit tricky let's say we go
queen to c8 which makes a lot of sense
we trade these off and finally the queen
comes to f6 you have to defend but
even though this is a position that is
equal look at these pieces being trapped
f7 there's so much pressure on it these
pawns are going to go up and attack on
the king side so this is not something
that we can go for so after queen to h4
black plays bishop to e6 hitting it back
make sure to have some nice attack on
the queen side and we don't have
anything
here
queen comes to f6 jumps in there haste
hitting this bishop and this rook is
being completely cut off by
by its own bishop so bishop to g4
actually has been played and this is
where things get very interesting
because white played bishop 2 f3 it's
defended by the queen
and you cannot take it however
black did take and what happened bishop
takes f3 rook to d7 and we actually had
a resignation because this f7 pawn
cannot be defended anymore if we lose
this rook
queen f7 check king h8
we have a mate on h7 or on g7 whichever
one you prefer so
what else can we do there's a very
interesting position very cute little
idea there at the end that let's say we
go we go back
we return to c8 we're going to say like
well this is not something i want to go
after
we're going to do this after rook 28
rook to e6 hitting this one we give a
check we give a check
rook to d6 and now you can see
after let's say bishop e6 all of these
pieces are trapped in especially the
queen cannot even trade itself because
of all the background so
the the move the engine suggests which
is actually very funny is
play king d2
with the idea is to
walk its way to h6 and deliver the
checkmate on g7 and it's actually very
difficult
to stop
this king
from going over all the way there or
making some random moves but you get the
idea that after this queen
king gets all the way to h6 was actually
made in threat now
why don't we just play after king d2
let's say queen to e7 which makes very
much sense after take take check king g7
which is the only move we play our rook
all the way back and we start eating
these pawns up so
the position it all starts at all ends
with this pawn on c5 which is an amazing
idea amazing play by white well deserved
win and he is not in the lead he has two
out of three there are three others with
two and a half out of three just like in
the masters group nobody is at a hundred
percent
but there's definitely going to be some
interesting games some fighting chess
and let's hope we also have that this
round in the masters let's bring it back
to fiona and robert hess
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello and welcome back here to round
four at the tata sinchas tournament
robert i'm afraid you're gonna have to
make do with me again
i'm not afraid i'm happy i missed you i
mean you know i was here dealing with
anish all by my lonesome that's a
difficult task but in all seriousness it
was great to have anish girion he had a
pretty quick day at the office so i am
glad you are back fiona
yeah and uh well it i was uh here all
the all the time over don't worry i had
you back off screen
um and i noticed that uh there's so many
interesting games that one game we
haven't looked at in a little while is
actually uh the carlson game where we
just see some things happening right now
a lot of the other games uh i think in
general we see fewer pieces on the board
considering that we are only uh two
hours into the game
yeah this carlson game which we see in
the top left it's just two minor pieces
per side off the board but you notice
that black has a knight in a bishop
white has two bishops and fiona in a
closed position the bishops can't thrive
so much so that's why we love this
triangle pawn structure for black of
course we can go back and see how we got
here but in general this kind of
triangle pawn structure for black limits
the scope of this light score bishop
yeah and magnus i think magnus of course
will be be eager to show
uh to show jordan who's the boss last
year he was held to a draw but he was
playing magnus was playing with the
black pieces so this year of course he's
out
for blood we see him there play bishop
d3 but how do you fight against this
triangle pawn structure
it's going to be a slow build up of
course right now there's an attack on
this knight on e4 and the big question
for jordan is do you retreat the knight
or do you play the move f5 which
protects the knight and makes sure that
you have two pawns defending it but the
same time you weaken some of your
position because if white and i should
say when white eventually plays the move
f3
if white is able to
open the board up for that light square
bishop when you make moves like f5 your
king could later be in some trouble i
don't think the king has any trouble
here the position is so close and it
will remain closed in particular because
the d4 pawn will always need defense so
even if you get f3 you can't follow it
up with e4 and that's the type of move
you need to blast open the position on
favorable terms for white
so jordan
does far
doing a good job
but yeah here a few
well just as we say that he goes for
f5
he has no fear and why should he
it's a very solid setup no weaknesses in
the position for either side and we can
go back in time to look how we got here
it's funny that the game between magnus
and jordan the reigning world chess
champion and the defending tata steel
champion not an important game i would
say
it's just i mean it's also a testament
to just how many exciting games we have
going on here i think it doesn't happen
so often and once again it's also i
think the start is such a great
uh tournament with a big field 14
players a 13 round robin uh
13
round robin event
robert i don't know what it is today i'm
struggling to speak but uh always such a
diverse uh field and so much action for
us to to look at
yes and not every single game will be as
sharp as duba versus vidit uh we can
trust mama jarv usually to have those
kind of games even if the results have
said three draws for him and he's
looking like uh this game might not go
in the winning direction for him but i
mean the way this one that we have in
front of us went it was just a solid
affair like we if we stop here a pair of
knights have been traded the only
tension that exists is between the c4
pawn and the d5 pawn and so it's a slow
build up i like the move bishop e4 and i
also like what magnus did in response
because this is
quite instructive for people to see that
the bishop moved away from f1 because if
you look at the pawn structure we talked
about how
black has this pawn triangle and it
limits the scope of white's light square
bishop in the game it limited the scope
of black
light's bishop to this point and there's
a reason why bishop takes f3 was played
because if you make some move like just
randomly like rook a7 and then the
response knight d2 happens your bishop's
not going anywhere in fact it's about to
get trapped with f3 so let's go back to
eight f3 happens and then g4 and your
bishop is lost it's just trapped so when
you have pawns on the same color as your
bishop
that means that the bishop is limited in
terms of its mobility and that is why we
saw the move bishop takes f3 and we got
to the position we see first of all
knight c5
taking advantage of a hanging bishop on
c3 so you can't just take and then we
get to the game position fiona where i
don't know i'm kind of impressed with
how jordan's playing generally speaking
and i think it's a good start for him
but when you you've commentated covered
a lot of magnus carlsen
while i like what jordan's done
is this not the type of magnus carlsen
position that he ends up winning like
five hours from now
yeah absolutely i like you i i like what
urine has done
so far but
it isn't enough just yet against magnus
you can never relax he's going to
to play this position here with the
bishop
pair until
the cows come home as they say
also all eight pawns still on the board
magnus i think very often understands
pawn structures better than anyone
in the world so jordan very impressive
so far holding his own but he's gonna
have to continue uh doing so for the
hours to come here you like when you're
sorry no go ahead
i would say i like what you were saying
that no pawns in between he knows when
to trade whether or not he'll play c
takes d5 of course black is not going to
take on c4 that would give white the
whole center and maybe white will play
c5 at some point and start targeting the
queen side so back to you if you know my
apologies no don't worry i was just
gonna say before we move on to that game
we have magnus here on camera and his
portrait is now ready as well so let's
have a look at that and see what magnus
had to say before the start of the event
i think the first time
i heard about
the tournament here was um probably
sometime in 1999 uh but the first
tournament that i actually followed was
the one in in 2000 so i would say that's
my like first firm memory of the
tournament here
probably my best memory from the village
here uh
was the year that i i won and uh people
of baikon say song sang a nice little
song for for me i really appreciated
that
i think there are people in
my team who are better than me at
working with
with engines so i would say
i'm not so
good at finding ideas with it so i
generally prefer thinking on my own
solving chess is way way out there and
frankly i hope that it won't be
in a very very long time
my goal for this tournament uh is to
have 13 days of good preparation
and
a good mindset when coming to the board
hopefully i'll i can get back to to my
best after a couple of
let's say frustrating performances the
last couple of years
[Music]
magnus carlsen who has been coming here
to vaikonzi for 17 years this is his
18th
participation here uh invike robert and
as we heard he has plenty of good
memories from the tournament
i wonder why why would magnus carlsen
have good memories in vikings it can't
be because he's won this tournament so
many times can it
certainly not uh certainly not i thought
it was very cute how he said you know he
has great memories of when the the
villagers uh sang a song for him magnus
carlsen he has won this event i hope i'm
not getting this wrong but i think a
record seven times
a few years ago he overtook vichy who
was the previous record holder with five
victories but he is gonna be looking uh
to get another one here as he said
in the interview as well after a couple
of um for his standards subpar
performances
yeah i think magnus is the type of
player once he has a bad event he
remembers that and then he wants to
right the ship and then win it so he
feels that energy
from
a substandard performance for him and i
i
kind of echo what you're saying that
it's really sweet to hear him talking
about that experience with people who
are from vikings a people who are from
the netherlands who usually in
non-pandemic years come to play in all
of the amateur tournaments within the
festival and also to celebrate the top
players because the netherlands has such
a rich chess history so many people play
the game and they love the game i
remember the opening ceremony several
years back where there was somebody i
believe in his 80s who told me that he'd
been coming to vikings a for the chess
festival since he was in his teens so
he's been to many many
of the festivals and that spirit that is
throughout the country of the
netherlands indeed a tournament that is
so dear not only to the locals here from
vikings and the surrounding
villages and towns but to
dutch chess players from all over the
country and we certainly hope to have
the amateur groups and our spectators
back next year but for now we're back in
the bird's eye view
and robert what is catching your
attention here well honestly it's the
game between shanklin and rapport and
not because it's an endgame and i want
to torture you without queens and attack
but if we go to that game
it's a bit surprising the transition we
saw anish was on he was talking about
how he's made a whole course that to
this point uh and i'll put the position
back where that point was here and then
with b6 happen you can see my arrow is
still there push the f pawn try to take
advantage of the fact that black has
this backwards d-pawn white can push the
majority we cut the board in half white
from the e-file through the h-file has a
four-on-three pawn advantage so you want
to use that and push your pawn up the
board maybe go after this black king
what sam did rook d1 that makes sense
for sure queen d7 and he put e6
immediately trading queens here and
after rook c5 the rook protects d5 and
is coming to a5 to attack a2 honestly if
if anyone is better i would say it's
black
robert i'm so disappointed because while
i was sitting here the whole time that
anish was on and listening to you guys
and when anish pointed out this idea of
the airport running up the board i
looked at it and i thought that looks
really really good
and uh so i am uh quite disappointed not
just to see
the queens come off but yeah to be in
this endgame now when
i don't know how easy was f45 to parry
of course it it was far from a decisive
advantage but it did look very promising
absolutely i mean f4 at the very least
it
keeps your pawn e5 very safe and sound
nothing needed more defense but just to
deal with f5 let's say you play queen to
d7 which does stop the immediate f5 you
can keep playing rook d1 there's no rush
for this e6 move i actually don't know
how
sam thought white would benefit from it
but you keep up this position where
black is stuck in place and white is the
only one who can kind of press forward
and queen f3 comes to mind next to try
to get f5 to work
everything is well defended in white's
camp so i think that e6 what she did in
the game here rook d won first and e6
that was a rush decision and he might be
upset with himself after the game
because he went from having a plus to
now where he has
to my eyes really no winning chances and
if he's not careful this can do a sort
of a caruana shanklin from yesterday
where the side that has the advantage
isn't quick to notice that he's lost the
thread and then black could even be
better in this game yeah and i'm i think
uh richard report is uh is going to be
quite relieved here and i'm i'm curious
to see if we will hear from some after
the game what his thought process was i
wonder if there was anything he could
have
missed
or if
maybe
he thinks this end game might still
be better for him but that's hard hard
to believe surely
because i don't believe it and i yeah i
don't think that sam believes it either
as you're suggesting so that's just why
i want to bring us here not that the
position is really uh that exciting at
the moment but it does give black some
potential because black has the better
pawn structure and if you can win this
a2 pawn you'll have an outside pass pawn
uh c2 and c3 double
uh isolated pawns we've talked about
that in previous days in particular
yesterday we're trying to come up with a
name for progananda's pawn structure uh
it's just not a good thing to have in
end games whereas with queens on the
board with more pieces there it was
perfectly fine now these pawns can be
picked off
yeah the only thing i'm wondering is
as white currently i am controlling the
e-file
of course the dream for white would be
to get both books onto the seventh
but it it seems like a distant dream at
the moment
and whenever one rook comes to the
seventh black can play rook f7 so we
could just see uh you know a draw i mean
look for example rookie seven i could
see this kind of situation happening
where you just repeat moves but i don't
think that black is forced to repeat and
that's really the essential aspect of
this position is that black can at any
point try to trade a pair of rooks if
one pair of rooks get traded white's in
huge trouble what's keeping white about
equal in this game is both pairs it
works because of what you're saying
fiona an ability to go after the seventh
rank an ability to pile up pressure on
this pawn on d5 because if those rooks
get traded and i just want to put that
on the board to show everybody now the
king will support the it's already lost
the evaluation just went all the way
down the king will just support this
pawn on d5 and the rook will either sit
on a3 and win the c3 pawn or you'll just
win the a2 pawn directly and white's
toast
and we see sam there looking at the
board i wonder uh he's not giving away
too much right now but i wonder if
there's maybe already a little bit of
regret about playing this uh hasty
e6 and just as i say that it's almost he
looked into the camera almost like he
he heard us
um but yeah
definitely at least a small missed
opportunity here
from salmon as you said now he's the one
on the defending side but let's go back
to
our bird's eye um
bird's eye view one more time
do you think robert on the bottom right
board is prague going to get his first
tata steel masters victory here today
against nils
well at the very least he's earned my
favorite game of the day award uh his
pawn going up to h5 putting pressure on
neo's grandiose the bottom right hand
side of the screen and bring it up on
the full screen here
white has an attack possibly brewing
along the h file and as we're discussing
with anish that even if what black is a
strike with f5 you don't really want to
take on e4 that leaves black with this
isolated e5 pawn the position is closed
and black has a bishop pair bishops love
open space so f5 is an attempt to open
the position but maybe it opens it in a
way that gets the king in too much
trouble for example
yeah and we see nils actually who's down
to only half an hour on the clock i
think it's the first time that we see
prague being so much up on the clock and
kneels
uh so low i think
it is a testament to just
how many uh problems there are already
f5 it is a move that you would like to
play but as you pointed out i mean it
does create weaknesses and with pawns
and we talk about it every day pawn
moves are always committed once you play
f5 you can never
go
back
um and if not f5 what are the
alternatives here for for black
another question i want you to ask me um
i think part of this is
and we've made mentions and it's
important for people to really take this
in and
use it on their own that when you're
getting attacked you do often want to
create chaos on either in the center
that's usually the way to go or on the
other side the board because it's not
like this is a one direction position i
don't want to talk about you know all
the the band members not the story of my
life but either way white can't just
focus all of his attention on his attack
let's say the move a6 is coming you know
b5 is next so do i have to look out for
that b5 move
maybe it's not so scary but we know at
least what black is trying to drum up
some kind of counter play but this
particular position i'm not seeing the
type of counter play you need to start
feeling comfortable and if f5 is the
choice you eventually make after h takes
h6 which isn't force white doesn't have
to rush that decision
we have this open h file that could be
dangerous the king does have the f7
square and can eventually run away um
and that's good news but like let's say
white plays a4 and decides to play on
the queen side as well you don't really
want to see a5 in an opening of the
other rook file and if you play a5
yourself you're saddled with this pawn
on b6 which isn't a very good piece so i
just feel like
even though objectively the position
isn't that amazing for white from a
practical point of view black is forced
to kind of
shuttle back and forth and white on the
other end can keep up with various ideas
rerouting this knight from d2 maybe via
b1 to c3 or coming up with another score
to go to i just think that it's so much
easier to play for white that it's going
to be difficult for neil to play this
game
yes and we will come back here but it'll
uh prague definitely with the upper hand
here uh in
this game
uh oh and we've had a result we just
came from there but the game between uh
sam shankland and richard report has
actually
ended in a draw they just repeat that
move immediately you were saying richard
could
play on but he decided to repeat the
moves and
as we can see that the players are
already gone and our arbiter arno is
gonna put the pieces back
yeah i wonder if
there was something better i mean we
have the benefit of the engine off to
the side
it just looks like a position where
black isn't really in any danger
although with the rook on e7 sitting
here i completely get it like i don't
want that rook to remain let's say we
get greedy and take on a2 rook takes d5
happens and you're about to see the
consequences because rook f7 no longer
draws it loses rook d8 check a second
rook comes in the rook has to block and
then this rook comes d7 fiona this is
what you were saying dreaming of not
afford yeah you were dreaming from
white's perspective and you had a
nightmare about it from uh reports
perspective so that would be a disaster
and just a loss for black if he were to
allow this
so that's a second game to end
peacefully today after uh karjakin
against uh geary and maybe we can go
back to the mamedyarov game i don't know
um yeah so let's bring up mamedyarov
against uh duda i believe one of the
last things
during our last break i was complaining
that i was feeling a little cold here in
the commentary room
but it looks like like i'm not the only
one
yeah or mom and dad was just trying to
drown out every other noise every other
person in the room and you know he's
just
a man by himself trying to figure out
what move to play
i love that
i think it's so rare i think in some you
know in open tournaments we might see a
lot of this but
in an elite
tournament
sorry this is funny i think it wins some
fans honestly look
it's good to be dressed well i don't
think he's dressed badly i think you
know he's
comfortable and
people like the hoodie right
yeah and there is no i thought there was
always questions i don't think there is
no dress code here in vikencey and i
also think it's not an outrageous hoodie
i don't think uh this is shocking and it
could just be it could be that his cold
it could be that he's drowning out the
noise um but yeah it's just an unusual
image
and to see
during an elite event but let's talk
about the position is he
maybe trying to to hide himself what
what do we make of of the position on
the word
i think he's a man of the people you
know he represents the masses
people wear hoodies that's what they do
but on the chess board he is really as
unique as they get so mama jarv he is
trying to figure out a way forward here
but when we had a niche on he was saying
how honestly i might start to prefer
black's position so why is that black
has these this pawn on e6 which has been
a problem but right now it's actually
quite well defended and this bishop that
has gone to a4 can eventually
come back to the b3 square and that
would be a nuisance for black to deal
with so it's going to be interesting to
see right now what mama jared plays
because he can retreat the bishop to
attack the pawn i see what's happening
here i'm going to defend my pawn on e6 i
can't afford to lose it and i would be
thinking about rook to d7 going after
the b7 pawn the issue here for white is
you're just thinking i'm gonna get
active i'm going to be aggressive i'm
going for e6 now b7 but what about your
own pawns h4 is already hanging bishop
c5 develops and not just attacks a pawn
but attacks a very important square if
you play f3 no longer do i win a pawn
but i win a piece because bishop f2 is a
dual threat of rook and knight so i
think that mama jeff has to be very
very careful at this moment with his
bishop trying to land on c5 it seems
like black has coordinated quite nicely
at this point and this h4 pawn that's
why the rook is up here on d4 fiona
that's not really the type of defense
you want for a pawn on h4
no and uh well shakira mama mediaev here
clearly has a little bit of grappling to
do do you think this is a an opening
novelty gone slightly wrong this knight
g3 do you think it has backfired
it's a really good question because if
we go back to that moment h5 perhaps
that's the only move and there are other
moves that keep the game within an
objective balance but it was the only
move that allowed duda to neutralize
most of white's initiative and then come
up with counter play of his own so i
love the move h5 i didn't understand how
deep it was it was sort of something i
threw
in there because i realized the h6
square could be important kicking the
knight would be great but the way duda
has played this he's fended off the
novelty very well and he's getting
activity for all of his pieces his king
up in the center and it's odd we have to
say that you know playing rookie 8 to e7
not developing your bishop bring your
king all the way up to f6 which is
defending a knight on e5 this is not how
we typically see chess played
no indeed the very
sort of fresh position here
not just fresh but unusual
uh position and uh
well he is
at home usually in this kind of
battle
but yeah we see him there
deep in thought and we will see what he
he comes up with
we will leave him to it
for now and let's bring up the words eye
view
again to see
the two results two games have ended
karjakin against geary and shankland
against uh rapport has ended peacefully
maybe we can go back to
uh we haven't seen or at least i haven't
seen fabiano in a while and of course
we'll have to to go to our tournament
leader with it where would you like to
start robert i have a quick question for
you fiona
is did magnus carlsen go up a pawn
somehow
am i counting correctly does he have
eight pawns and
jordan has seven yeah correct somehow
the there's always there seems to be one
word that both of us are missing for you
yesterday it was the word on the bottom
right corner for me it's the the one
in the top left corner and you've pulled
it up let's see where that pawn has
disappeared
so rooksy won
g5
and then after queen e2 he played g4
which allows the capture and in general
in these types of positions so you want
to play f takes e4 and if your rook gets
to f3 let's say you had two moves at
once all of a sudden black is better and
then we'll start trying to push pawns up
the board open up the position this king
is not very safe here black's king is
way safer because of the control of the
board so he wants to take on e4 that did
drop with the f-pawn he did drop the g4
pawn because taking with the d-pawn that
keeps your rook closed and you're not
ever going to get the f4 move in and
then d5 happens it is a position where
white is ready to open up the center
thanks to the placement of the rooks you
say oh wait that's a free pawn right i
go up a pawn is black and then this rook
lands on c5 d5 falls a5 is in trouble
i'm not even sure which rook you take
with on d5 it depends how black plays
here because you might win this second
pawn or you might take with a c rook and
land on the seventh rank so black's
position just falls apart immediately
had he
uh taken with the d-pawn which is why he
took with the f pawn but fiona a pawn is
a pawn if my math still serves me well
upon is most
certainly upon and to be honest i i'm
confused because
we talked so much about giving up
materials sacrificing upon
the compensation
it doesn't always have to be something
concrete very often it will just be
active piece play
but here
i mean i will have to ask you robert to
explain to me
why did robert
why did jordan go for this
g5 g4 which clearly the idea was to give
up the pawn
um
what does he have in return where does
the compensation lie
i like how you framed it because it is
intentional on jordan's part so if we
just go back a couple was before he
started marching his g pawn up the board
after rook a to c1
and then uh g5 well i don't want to make
the g pawn move let's start here that
black doesn't have an active plan so
while the position is all right for
black
in chess we think about strategies not
just moves if you're just making
individual moves you're not really
playing chess because it has to be a
coordinated effort so jordan sits here
he's like what do i want to accomplish
and the answer is i don't really know so
his plan is not very clear whereas for
magnus we have potential to take here
bring our rook up in the c file rook c2
rook c1 queen e2 maybe f3 all sorts of
ideas come to mind so it is easier to
picture a path forward for white so what
he did in the game which does lose
material here let me get rid of those
arrows is he made his life easier at the
same time i could see a rook landing on
f3 a queen to f7 and if the center of
the board and queen side can remain
closed that's a big if then black has an
initiative over here on the king side
like he's down the pawn i am not
convinced the queenside will remain
closed so ultimately i really like how
this position has gone for magnus
because the bishop on e1 doesn't look
like a very good piece but it defends
this f2 pawn and that's an open file so
having the bishop here is of the utmost
importance i do think that jordan has
play and some sufficient play at that
but as this game continues he's going to
need to prove it because if he doesn't
have some threats of his own magnus is
just up a pawn and will
try to convert that pawn venge into a
win and you talked about the queen side
i mean it's very hard to see how black
can manage to to keep the queer inside
closed white will be able whenever he
wants to try to take on d5 also the pawn
on a5
as soon as the the rook from from a8
leaves that is going to become very
vulnerable so uh this is not the kind of
position where jordan
can just bring all the forces
to the the king side without having to
worry about the queen side so i'm um
well i'm starting to like magnus but of
course jordan
he
let's not underestimate his idea he went
for this quite
confidently and we'll see if he can
prove me wrong
and we can give everyone a visual of how
the locked up queen side can make
black's life that much better because
i'll just make some moves and they don't
have to be good don't worry about the
evaluation part let's just do it so c5
b5 b4 a4 i did made it so quickly the
evaluation bar at first didn't move but
look at it now white is up a pawn but
according to the evaluation bar is just
in huge trouble and the reason why is
the queen side is closed which means
that white can't make any in-roads there
there's nothing to do it's a pawn chain
you can't get to the base pawn a pawn
chain is as strong as it's baseball good
luck getting there now black on the
other hand can put one rook on f3 can
bring this rook up over here can play h5
and white is helpless to do anything on
the king side besides sit and wait and
that's why this position is maybe just
winning for black even though you're
down a pawn so that shows you that
magnus cannot close the queen side he
would never do that but his attack on
the queen side if you will his potential
to win a pawn over there and open up the
position that is what is keeping him
ahead not just the extra pawn
and
we'll move on from here in a second but
we saw that magnus captured
on d5 and of course jordan recaptured
with the e pawn you don't want
to allow white to open the c file
although the bar is starting to
again go into black's favor here he goes
rook c5 trying to get after this pawn
and b6 is
not really a recommended move because
the rook will retreat to c2 where it
covers the weak point and you can double
on the file over here it is saying
though that black is doing well i think
it's because when this rook comes to f6
it defends the queen side and so the
queen side is closed enough and black
can bring that rook over to the f-file
double rooks and
honestly i see the promise in the
position maybe this was a really deep
sacrifice by jordan that i saw magnus up
upon like okay has to be good for magnus
but credit to jordan von forrest who has
given a pawn to his boss the world chess
champion and saying i don't care about
material i'm going for your king
and i agree with you
completely robert i think i
was all for so maybe uh and i think it
happens to so many of us to be
blindsided by the bar for a second
especially when it's magnus carlsen
playing um but
jordan and i think jordan not only does
he
uh have this position you know where he
sacrificed the peon upon he is playing
for the initiative i also think he might
have a slight psychological edge because
he has nothing to lose playing black
against magnus but if you're a magnus
you're the world champion you're playing
your second you're playing the title
defender one of the lower rated players
in the field and the last thing you want
to do is to lose and especially to lose
as white as so i think
certainly a very interesting decision
here from jordan putting pressure on
magnus carlsen
and if this queen side can't be opened
up magnus is going to be in trouble it
may not be
that terrible for him
his king side is defended for now but if
that h file opens up we see an h5 h4
pawn takes g3 like we are seeing in the
pragnanda game uh where you see that
probably not in the game in the bottom
right and the magnus carlson game in the
top left if jordan can do what prague
just did of pushing the h pawn up the
board and trading it and opening up that
file that could be big danger for
magnus's king
indeed and robert we will take a break
in just a couple of minutes but maybe
before we do that we can quickly update
the game of the tournament leader vidit
against panko
for sure well we've been discussing
lines where black's bishop pair is no
more and as they pull the game up on the
screen here
the
white pawns are doubled on the king's
side but there's opposite colored
bishops so there's a bishop on e3 and
bishop on d7
i don't really think that white has all
that much but as anish and i have been
talking earlier that this d4 square is
really important so if this bishop can
replace the knight on d4 if that can
successfully happen then i think white
is doing pretty well and then you try to
put the knight in a better square but
for now it's hard to arrange those
pieces as if the knight moves the c3
pawn is loose and if you move the knight
to a square where it defends c3
with the 92 it's actually black's turn
but i was going to say rookie would have
been a response anyway with pieces in a
row so i just feel like black has
sufficient play thanks to the queen in
the center on e5 uh this rook can slide
into the game on e8 right now and i do
think that yesopenko is doing quite
nicely yes after
vidit sprung the surprise of one e4 on
him it seems like
andre has kept things under control
all along of course
the game is still young we're only two
hours 20 into the round so a lot can
still happen but for now uh
things seem quite level here we will
come back to this game and to the uh
remaining for well the remaining five
games after a short break so don't go
anywhere and we'll see you in just a few
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i was watching this tournament when i
was a kid
when i wasn't a strong player and i was
just watching all the best players in
the world come here
and
i remember the first time i played here
back then it was there were three groups
along with the open section and i was
playing in the c group that was in 2008
but i was already watching this
tournament many years before that
there's there's a huge amount of people
uh who love to to play and to watch
chess here uh now it's of course a bit
different times have changed a bit uh
but hopefully uh someday we'll we'll go
back to that
yeah i grew up analyzing with the board
but things are very different now most
of the analysis is done on on the
computer but still it's nice to go back
to that sometimes and i think it's also
useful to
analyze over the board because
um it helps your understanding of the
position
even if you have the best analysis in
the world it might not help you
over the board if you're not if you
don't fully understand exactly what's
going on and it also helps your
memorization
if you see it over the board rather than
seeing it on the computer so i think
it's still very helpful to to work over
the board so it's also up to the
the guys who are you know who have been
there a bit longer to to adapt because
all the younger players are improving so
quickly
uh yeah my goal is to is to win the
tournament
[Music]
good to see fabiano's portrait there he
has been coming here
since 2008 one of the many players who
have played in all three groups the c
group the b group and of course the a
group which is now known
as the masters and robert i thought
quite quite the understatement there by
fabiano when he said that times have
changed a little bit
with the situation here
yeah they certainly have but one thing
that he hopes will come back you know
he'll rewind the clock to win invite
gonzale again because uh he had that one
phenomenal show i think
he had like hit a monster score like 10
out of 13.
yeah that is absurdly good and his start
here honestly fiona not looking like uh
he's gonna get near that score because
we have his game in front of us dubov
has neutralized most of
white's initial advantage out of the
opening and i think that daniel after a
loss yesterday he's playing quite nicely
on the black side
yeah this position
looks very solid
for daniel not clear to me at first
where
fabiano
can put pressure one of the things
is maybe the pawn on a6 could this
become a target
in the long term and of course my second
question as always is what about the
tension
in the center at which point do you want
to do something as right if you decide
to do something what's it gonna be are
you gonna take on
e5 do you ever want to play d5
and same for black
do you want to take or as black do you
just want to sit
all great questions and i think one
thing that benefits black here is
there's no presence of c pawns because
when there are c pawns in the board the
bishop can't safely go to b5 because
white would have a pawn to push to c4 to
kick the bishop out of there so this
bishop can just sit on the b5 square he
goes rook b8 first which i really like
attacking this pawn on b2 but if that
pawn on a6 which you point out fiona is
attacked then the bishop just goes to b5
and it's an active defense of that pawn
so maybe we can go back a little bit
just to see how
we got here because the queen was on d7
that was i think one of the last times
we looked here and he took on a4 which
in some ways you don't want to make that
move but dubov he said yeah looks good
to me
yes so he captured
that pawn which right now cannot be
recaptured but after fabiano retreated
the bishop
to b1 there's already two attackers on a
for the white queen from the one and
rook and uh
daniel tried to hold on to that pawn for
a little bit longer bishop c6 and
fabiano decided to strike in the center
yeah he went d4
d5 could be an option the pawn e5 is
already loose and after swapping a pair
of pawns danielle said i'm just going to
play h6 deal with your bishop fabiano
retreats rather than captures because if
he captured on f6 the bishop takes back
and applies pressure on white's center
so he backs it up and then knight to h5
so seeing your bishop's coming off the
board let's get rid of those pieces and
after bishop c2 it's clear a4 is going
to be lost but duov had no issue with
that pawn uh leaving the board and he
played a clever little move knight to b3
if you're going to win my pawn it's
going to be without this knight hanging
behind it on the a file and that a6 pawn
so knight b3 swaps off the knights in a
way that allows black to regroup quickly
and attack his pawn the center and then
fabiano retreated his bishop so he kind
of
stole a couple tempe from fabiano who
would have loved to take on a4 in one
move and had a knight back on d2 so
let's just show that to make it as clear
as possible if knight f6 the move bishop
takes a4 this knight defends e4 as does
the rook if you take and i take back
with my rook on a4 i'm already putting
pressure on that pawn that you pointed
out fiona and white is much better
yeah so daniel uh cleverly
uh playing this here in a way not to
give fabiano any pressure along the
a-file and after
those few moves we saw the bishop went
back to c2 and fabiana has just decided
to go
b3
so defending that pawn by advancing it
where it is well defended by the queen
and the bishop
one question i have for you robert as
black do i want to try and push my a
pawn try and get in a5 a4 i can't do it
right now
um or do i want to keep that
pawn safely tucked back all the way on
a6
it's a good question i think for now the
pawn sitting on a6 is good and bishop b5
is a natural follow-up because now the
pawn and bishop defend each other so you
don't have to worry about leaving a
more major piece like a rook to handle
that pawn and the center is defended
from both sides e5 of course defended
twice e4 defended twice from for white
and i could see this game um
turning in a way that is more
comfortable for black because
this bishop on c2 it's
protecting this pawn on b3 but look
who's bishop is better both bishops are
doing the same job but blacks is better
placed so it's i would slightly prefer
black's position even though i
acknowledge the
position is quite level and i think that
this game
if you force me to predict which
sometimes you like doing fiona i would
say that this game will be a draw in the
relative in your future
yeah i agree with you and i i think not
a sign like i think very often we can
pick up on these little
um
on these little buddy signs i don't know
if you you saw it but
after
daniel played bishop b5 he gave fabiano
this quick look which
sort of often indicates okay i'm quite
happy here i'm comfortable
um
it's not an implicit
anything explicit but just
very often a sign of things to come i
agree with you i think this would be
another
peaceful game uh but let's go back to
the bird's eye view and see maybe where
are our decisive games going to come
from today
okay the mama jar of duty game still
looks really interesting uh there's
potential there
the game between magnus and jordan on
the top left of our screen we see that
magnus remains a pawn ahead but jordan's
pieces are just so nicely positioned
aiming towards the white king
in the bottom right hand side of the
screen with pragma nanda and
grendelius i mean that game open h file
the king on jet not looking too safe but
safe enough for the time being
we have options of where victory can
come from but often times a victory at
this level requires a mistake from one
of the players
absolutely i was thinking can we maybe
start by going to pragnanda because i
see that niels
uh has just played bishop f6
and of course my first question here is
bishop f6 well the one square that the
bishop was defending from g7 was h6
and now my queen is given the option
to infiltrate is that something i want
to do or not
i guess the downside of bringing our
queen all the way here is that we know
black will play queen g7 and offer a
queen trade so we have to evaluate is
that what i'm looking for the queen
trade or would white be happier with the
queens on the board and i i know you i
know you know the answer and i know that
you do not want to trade the queens at
all so you you you're very kind to uh
help
explain this to the audience but i know
you're like there's no way i'm playing
queen h6 to trade the queens if you are
going to go the h file and actually this
is an important point you can go to h3
which still keeps the same threats
without attacking g6 but keeps the same
threats of putting the queen on
h6 and one of the benefits of queen h3
is black does not want to move this pawn
uh if you move this pawn you know you
think oh i'm taking a free pawn your
queen's under attack now white plays
bishop g4 and the game is just over this
is how games are lost very quickly this
is a terrible bishop this knight can
recapture on
e4 and there are just tons of problems
for this black king for example if we
trade here and even if we defend this
pawn with our king knight takes e4
happens this knight
just a gorgeous piece this bishop is a
dud
yeah so queen h3 definitely the more
tempting option maybe we can also be
more patient uh as white i know that i
was the one that suggested bringing the
queen in immediately the second question
i think um or the second comment i think
you always when you play chess you want
to look at blacks
well at your opponent's last move and
ask yourself
why did they make this move what are
they trying to achieve and bishop
d7 at 2f6 i guess the idea is that
bishop maybe wants to come forward 2 g5
and activate itself this way and at the
same time also defend by keeping an eye
on on h6 from a more active square
that's right so i mean it's not just
about queen g7 freeing the square for
the queen defender which we're talking
about in the event of queen h6 queen g7
and now we have to evaluate the queen
trade
white has the benefit something we
talked about earlier of being able to
play on both sides of the board and just
because the queens go off doesn't mean
that white can't play for an advantage
and that advantage could come from
playing a5 so white can open the other
flank and something to be very careful
about is if this rook let's say i play
a5 and we trade queens here this pawn is
under attack so we'll defend it with
king
this rook believe it or not is going to
come right here and so rook h3 rook a3
and then try to play pawn takes b6 we
take over another open file we have no
access on the h file so let's go over to
the a file where when we take on b6 our
rook will land on this a7 square or an
a6 to put pressure on this pawn so
that's the type of vision players have
to have
and i you know that pragma nanda is
thinking about this move a5 because he
put his pawn on a4 the very last turn
like that was his move and then niels
won bishop f6 yeah and i think a5 unless
he can find
uh unless there's something that bothers
him about the immediate a5 i think that
is the likely move
that we will see appear
on the board here and uh pragnanda still
very clearly in the driver's seat niels
grandelius has had a tough start
to the tournament and he will have to d
dig very deep here uh to save this
position again i have a question for you
uh fiona sorry to interrupt you there
but i i need to ask you you look at the
clock situation where pragnanda is well
ahead we know he's better objectively
but what kind of
stance do you take from white's
perspective do you start trying to get
ultra aggressive because your opponent
doesn't have time to think i mean how
would you think progananda will handle
this position with the edge but also the
lead in the clock it's an interesting
question because i think
very often younger players and more
inexperienced players and they will be
tempted to try and punish the opponent
immediately as their time is ticking
down but pragnanda although he's still
only 16
years old i think he already has the
maturity
and the experience
to try and put neil's clock situation
to one side not let his uh
his moves be influenced by that and i
think he will try and make
what is objectively the best move on the
board and i think in general it is good
advice
don't let yourself be rushed by your
opponent's time very often if you try
and play against their low time uh it
tends to backfire
that's for sure correct and i've had
experiences of that myself usually i'm
the one down on the clock and my
opponent's trying to win on time and
what the mistake we often make is
thinking that if we go for some kind of
checkmating attack that's scary for our
opponent but oftentimes if we're going
for checkmate there's only like one or
two ways to stop the checkmate so that
moves in fact are easier if queen h6 is
played queen g7 will be like the
automatic response uh by niels there is
potential for the king to escape to f7
and i'm going to acknowledge that but
the point is that this type of move is
so natural for nils to play whereas if
the situation is a bit more ambiguous or
if there are some
instead of immediate threats we're just
maintaining the pressure in a way that
leaves it for a while
that is where our opponents often have
to spend the most amount of time of
course if there is a checkmate attack
and it's going to work you go for it but
in a position like this i wouldn't be
surprised if a slower method is chosen
by pragnanda absolutely and
before we move on from here i see a lot
of comments in the chat of people uh
liking nielsen's sweater and where did
he get it why is that a little insight
and niels gwandalius he does
most of his shopping pretty much all of
his shopping in second-hand shops so go
neal's a a great way to
to
to promote to do something sustainable
at the fashion industry i mean there's
so many clothes being produced but niels
he is not supporting that he is buying
his clothes second hand i know he got a
new
suit in a second-hand shop before the
tournament he was very happy with that
so i encourage you all to do more second
hand shopping as well and with that
little plug out of the way robert let's
go back to the bird's eye view
i was about to say is neil's trying to
become a
clothing model here and you're just
his pr person you're doing a great job
like now i want i'm curious i wasn't
curious before now i want to know where
the clothing came from but this mama
jarv game against duda we see that a
second from the right on the top level
here in our bird's eye view the eval bar
swinging in duda's favor
that's bad news for the fans of the
hoodie uh mama jarv he's going
super aggressively but he's down a pawn
and if he can't justify it with an
attack he will simply be worse
yeah and i loved our camera work there
swinging over
and what's happening there sorry robert
but did you
i think shakira offered a draw did you
see that
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna take my
breath
okay so
i don't blame him for offering a draw
the position is very complicated he
probably thinks he is worse here
but the draw should not offer should not
be allowed i'm just again
i know i've been repeating myself from a
broken record
but
yeah okay so i'll talk about why this is
an interesting position and the result
is unclear
in the last few moves we saw rook c7
bishop b3 attacking the pawn e5 was the
choice of duda his palm was under attack
he pushes it
now mom drove goes to the last rank that
rook was doing a job it was defending h4
the pawn is captured and he made the
move rook to e8 i don't know why that
move is frowned upon by the engine duda
doesn't have an engine at his side
helping him figure it out but this pawn
on e5 is under attack the rook can stop
one square short with rook e6 check and
then that king is in some danger for
example if you play the move e4
you are protecting your e5 pawn but
after rookie six check where is your
king going i think you have to fiona
play king g5 because king to g7 or king
f7 of course is never going to be played
you don't want to walk into discover
check and after king to g7 f5 is no
longer defended so rook h1 hits the
knight and then f5 falls and that is a
really and maybe we can just point out i
think bishop e7 here there's some
tactical problems right if after rook h1
if you try and defend the knight i guess
we can capture uh the knight and after
bishop takes
in comes knight f5 with the fork and
we're going to get the two pieces for
the rook
exactly so too many tactics available
to white to be able to just retreat your
king which is why if e4 were to be
played which is a very logical move
defending your pawn that's attacked here
uh but e4 rookie six check you have to
play king g5 and if i'm buddha and i was
just offered a draw and i'm visualizing
this position i could see myself being
like yeah i don't really want a part of
this because my king is here
one check could be to mate
it's
that's not the spot you really want your
king
uh though the g2 pawn is under attack
it's not clear how white continues
putting pressure on the king here so
it's a position that's just interesting
which is why we should not see them
agree to a draw even though it may feel
best for the tournament standing
let
them play
and the funny thing is i mean you can
almost see the pain on duda's face
it's almost like he didn't want to have
to deal
with that draw offer because it is a
tough spot
maybe he senses that he is a little bit
better but it is uh quite a a wild
position despite the reduced material
his king could in get into into some
trouble we see him actually shaking his
head you know frowning
uh he took off the mask to take a more a
more clear look
just so funny to see him but a tough
spot here for do that do you take the
draw or not
well what kind of draw decliner are you
when someone offers you a drone you
don't want it do you just make your move
or do you say no
i think it depends probably on the
opponent also on how the draw offer was
made either i'll just play
or i'll say
i'll play
yeah i mean you know if it also depends
on the ass like you said they say uh you
know would you like a draw yeah exactly
it's very pleasant right like would you
like one i'm offering no thanks
yeah no thank you i would like to
continue but if they're just like draw
and then are you like no
i actually
you know i missed the days when we were
playing in the youth competitions and i
think it's so funny we still see it
sometimes it's so rare but um well you
spoke english already of course i didn't
as a as a child and uh well i am not
going to be able to explain it i have to
wait until we're back on the camera
because the way of course that the
drawers were offered
back then was with the the cross line
with with the fingers and there was so
many times when his children would go
yeah
and then i did okay
i i remember those days for sure and you
know i think someone needs to become
clever enough to have a witty response
you know someone's like you know offers
a draw and they have just they're
they're saying that they use every
single time
you know like like noted you know
you
instead of just like i'll think about it
just something that is a funny response
i i do understand why mama jarv offered
the draw it's an unclear position
he's probably nervous about his chances
and duda undoubtedly senses that uh the
question becomes how to play on the e5
pawn is under attack there's a check on
e6
i think fiona if he plays on his king
will very likely have to go to the g5
square i don't really see a clear way
around that um rook e7 i guess is a way
to save your pawn but it just looks so
strange when there's this rook on the
last rank knight takes h5 check is not
out of the question because you're
distracting the rook on h8 from the
bishop on f8 so maybe that pawn will
fall it's really an unclear situation so
if duda accepted i wouldn't blame him i
just
well maybe hopefully the last time i
have to say this i just hope that the
draw offer is removed from chess i agree
with you on that i think as long as it
is allowed from shakia's point of view i
think it makes a lot of sense because a
he probably senses that things haven't
entirely gone his way and b
at the moment where he made his draw for
they were roughly even on time and
throwing in a draw for
um
very often is gonna make your opponent
if they play on at least spend more time
before they make their move because they
are unless they feel they are
overwhelmingly better
and immediately no they won't take it
sometime will have to be invested into
the decision do i want to play
how much risk am i taking so from that
point of view
the draw offer makes some sense if
shakia is not feeling completely
comfortable in this position
and dude he's working hard because he
has that offer on the table he can spend
quite a deal of time working through
these complications here um we mentioned
the move rookie seven the move e4
another move candid and everyone should
have moved candidates sometimes a
position if someone captures your piece
you have to capture back you don't need
other options but in a position like
this you need to check your lines and
one other move i would say is knight g6
the knight was there before it stole
upon an h4 now might be the time to move
back you protect e5 you protect the
bishop you protect them sorry to
interrupt you robert we just had another
result come in as the game between
fabiano caruana and daniel dubos i think
you called it has just ended in a draw
and wow and they played down to this
[ __ ] game real fast
they did there was nothing
really in the position after we saw
uh bishop b5
it looks like they just forced all the
pieces off very quickly knight g5
instead of trading queens just
trade pawns trade bishops they knew the
draw was coming this was their way of
offering they played it out to a
position that was extremely clear trade
rooks
protect
protect
trade pawns in a funny way and then it's
rooking for looking for pawns are
exactly symmetrical it's just completely
even i am
okay and more than happy for them to
offer the drama and you're about to be
even happier robert because duda has
played on oh
okay well i think that will likely make
him even more of a fan favorite he has
gained so many fans by winning the world
cup uh but even
ignoring for a moment his successes his
tournament victories the way he plays
chess is so exciting and he has the
respect of everybody you know that
magnus carlsen deeply respects yanchez
stuff due to his game in fact it was due
to who eliminated magnus in the world
cup and so in this position he played
knight back to g6 saying no draw for you
rookie six check and fiona it's time
king has to go to g5 because if you step
back you lose f5 with check your
position falls apart
duda is bringing his king up to g5
yeah the king well as you're pointing
out has no choice and then the question
is
how do we try and get to the king on
on g5 can we try and open
some more lines uh
is the death ever worth trying to
consider giving up our f pawn do we want
to bring the knight into the game how do
we proceed here that's a good question
i mean the king actually is kind of safe
here it's like
it's tucked between all these pawns and
f5 h5 the knight on g6 is helping out so
it's not really obvious how mama jaro
should go for it you said something
about giving up the f-pawn that's not
another question
and actually just one thing for a second
i thought oh could i consider taking on
e5 with the rook and then f5 is uh not
to be defended but then i realized
actually rook c5
uh and well yeah rook c5 still defends
the pawn
so that i don't think oh
oh my gosh
i also was like oh rook c5 looks pretty
good but 94 check there's a pin here and
after king f4 rook takes the rook has
takes c5 because you take with your
knight you lose your rook and then white
will lose the knight but then it's even
material obviously colored bishops
that's pretty wild so rook c5 i mean
that from a distance would be
my first instinct as well uh like oh i
think you can play h4 here
if the rook takes you bring your king
back and now if the knight moves you
lose the rook if the knight doesn't move
you lose the knight and if the knight
took on f5 instead you have your move
rook c5 forcing a trade of rooks and
then black is completely winning in the
ensuing end game
yeah so kg5 is on the board and
uh well very interesting moment here
what is shakia going to respond we will
leave him to think about it we'll go on
a short break
we are only an hour away from the first
time control so things are going to heat
up don't go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fastest
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we're back here with the action from
round four well you saw the bird's eye
view throughout the break but robert i
think we're going to do a deep dive here
with the world champion and the title
defender
because jordan has just given up another
pawn
he is playing some brilliantly
aggressive chess
he started off by giving a pawn away on
g4 we'll just quickly go back to that
moment where he pushed his g-pawn up the
board magnus said i'll take that don't
mind me and then look at what happened
here so the rook went up to c5 h5 played
by jordan attacking the queen the queen
drops back queen f7 played and here was
an opportunity for magnus he could have
tried to open up the queen side
on this board maybe he would have to
bring his rook over play b4 things of
that nature instead he retreats and
after the move a4 b4 played this is the
kind of locked up position he didn't
really want to have happen and look at
jordan go h4
rook c1 rook f6 and after the trade in
g4
jordan says i have no fear
h3 is here giving up the pawn to open up
more lines
was that a rhyme uh it
hopefully it's not a crime to give a
little rhyme fiona but it's just that
kind of day isn't it
it is and it's funny because we were
looking
at
this position here during our break and
you were just saying oh once magnus
gets to play h3 himself he will be uh
fine and jordan said no no no
no h3 for you
yeah i was wondering if white hat let's
say black just made some move to the
corner and white played h3 how does
black ever increase the pressure because
you could put one rook on f3 but you
can't attack this pawn a second time so
i felt like it would be difficult to see
a way for black to ever punch through
not that i could see a way for white to
do anything either so this could have
just been a standstill instead we see h3
queen takes and rook f8 and now we're in
a situation where the h file is open so
a rook can swing to h6 and then maybe
the second rook can join the h file the
f file is open so it's just a very dicey
position where this rook is going to
come to h6 this rook is going to come to
f3 and magnus's king is going to be
feeling the heat
i mean a couple of hours ago i remember
when jordan gave up the first pawn i
wasn't too sure where is the counter
play where is the compensation going to
come from but he has certainly
shown me and if anything although in
general i prefer the material i think i
would like
to play black here and we look we see
magnus and not looking too happy
he definitely has reasons to be
concerned here this is everyone's game
anything
could happen here
um
[Music]
so the question is how do we try and
consolidate now as white
i don't know if it's about consolidation
as much as it is about hope because
rook h6 rook f3 these ideas um
come quite obviously so one idea i have
is tied to this pawn on c6 so the good
news for white if you can even call it
good news is that black can't just crush
you as this rook does need to stay
attached to this pawn so let's say i'm
trying to make this work how do i do
this um
okay i'll start with queen g2 rook h6
and then i'll
i don't really want to play h3 but i
just want to make a point that i can
make this move g5 because this rook
if it captures on h3 loses sight of c6
and then it's white who has a big attack
of his own where rook c8 check is now a
threat this king on g8 doesn't have any
shelter you've given up all your pawns
in front of your king so this kind of g5
move could force the rook back somewhere
in this direction potentially or you can
move your rook and try to take with the
f3 rook because you want to double your
rooks on an open file and go for a check
mini attack it's very unclear to me i
see the evaluation bar staying in the
middle that means there's some kind of
draw by repetition in the works but who
knows where and why and how i'll leave
that to the engine such a double-edged
uh position and i have to say jordan
really
well last year he had the standout
performance but he has really matured so
much over the years another player who's
gone through all the tournaments here he
started from the amateur groups
when he was only a child and it's
interesting because when we looked at
magnus's portrait earlier he was saying
when asked about the influence of
technology in computers he said there
are a lot of people on my team who use
computers more than i do and one of them
is probably you're an event for race
i wouldn't say probably i would say
definitely jordan von forest he showed
in his own preparation not just for
magnus at the world championship but
jordan last year every game was fresh we
had vishy anand on commentating
for part of the event and he was super
impressed by
how jordan
was playing i mean it just was a sight
to behold and right now giving up not
just one pawn but a second pawn a
sacrifice initially so deep that i was
when we had the bird's eye view up i was
like wait fiona am i counting right like
is it managed up a pawn but that's why
we can't just count material i am sure
i'm not looking at chat sorry everybody
please forgive me but i'm sure people
are chesting wait how is it zeros black
is down two full pawns but material
doesn't tell the full story what black
lacks in material quantity he makes up
for in material quality he has these
great rooks on the same line
heading down the f file he can bring
this rook over to h6 to attack the queen
the g4 pawn sticks out like a sore thumb
if white could put the queen on g2 and
that pawn back one square on g3 we would
like white's position and white would
probably be close to winning because
everything is protected but when you
move pawns up the board they are harder
to defend and easier to attack and that
is why black is absolutely hanging in
this game if not decide to be preferred
yeah and i'm very curious to see what is
going to happen you mentioned the zero
zeros which sometimes indicate there
could be a some kind of repetition on
the horizon uh we'll see what happens i
think
it is also a thin line there there's a
position where you can't take too many
liberties one wrong step and you might
find yourself in huge trouble that's
true for both
sides so we will come back here magnus
carlsen right now deep in fought and um
i would like to to go back actually to
the bird's eye view see what are the
other develop developments elsewhere i'm
curious what has shakira media have done
and maybe we can quickly go back to my
media and do that before moving on
elsewhere
well that's a very interesting position
we see on the top line here the second
from the right the one game that's still
in play there mama jarv
he's brought his rook up so his knight
was attacked and he didn't move the
knight which is an interesting idea for
sure so let's just uh see king g5 was
played the bishop came back to c2
attacking this pawn on f5
and look at duda's skill he plays h4
because if the bishop takes on f5
now you see that this knight is under
attack and once i take your knight you
can't take my knight with your rook as
your bishop lost its defender if you
take on the knight with the bishop my
pawn reaches f2 my bishop will come to
c5 and i think that black is winning
even if the material will end up being
even because of this beautiful pass pawn
on f2 the loose bishop on g6 as well and
if you start trying to take the pawn now
we saw how
vidit did this yesterday up goes the
king you give it a check hey guess what
king to g3 you know where the king is
safe on h2 maybe even on g2 but black is
going to win this game
with that past pawn i mean what a
position this could have been had mama
jarv gone for it so he did not take this
pawn on f5 with the bishop fiona and if
the knight took on f5 we have a tactic
similar to one we saw earlier the rook
could take this bishop on c2 and after
the king takes we get two minor pieces
for rook
yes so do they manage to uh
manage to know sorry i've managed to
avoid that but he might not be faring
much better in the game so what's
happening now
yeah rookie three please take me i would
like to take back and get your knight on
g6 you're in check so
dude shuts down the diagonal e4 and
after knight takes up five he's hoping
for king takes f5 i i think at least and
then after a rook takes on e4 there's
problems on this diagonal but no matter
what
black is going to play rook take c2 at
some point it could be in this position
to start with just rook takes c2 but
king takes f5 you can't take on e4 with
the bishop because the rook is loose and
if you take on e4 with the rook then
rook takes c2 i believe is forced
because of the king's placement and then
we're in a messy situation where it's a
knight a bishop for black it's a rook
and pawn for white if we just do a quick
count that's six points or six points
but typically speaking the minor pieces
outclass a rook even with that pawn
absolutely agreed and i saw a question
in the chat
duda isn't winning is he well he might
not be winning just yet but he is
certainly got a big advantage here
robert
he does uh this type of position is one
where he can play for a win without too
much risk even though his king is up the
board that knight on g6 is such a good
piece
and he's just about
to make a move and he has taken
on f5
immediately
so what do we expect after a rook
capture uh they will he will take on c2
i think he has to because your king is
in line with this bishop and if you move
your king to g5 i will take your knight
with check because i'm giving up more
material to put your king in the line of
fire with my bishop and this is
important at this point you don't go
rook e7 check because the rook can take
the bishop you go rook c4 check to
interpose on the file steal a check and
then i win your rook and then white is
up a pawn so that would not be good for
duda of course
no and while rook takes c4 is on the
boards and there he goes
uh he has snapped off the bishop on c
two and we will see at this end game
here unfold uh where duda is playing
four two results uh with the the two
minor pieces um against the rook and
robert i guess you fancy his winning
chances
i certainly do this rook on e6 has one
move that's safe
because this knight on g6 so for
instance
if bishop c5 or bishop g7 i think the
future for
mamajara's pieces will include rook to
e8 but i'm really concerned about this
pawn on h4 if you ever try to trade it
with g3 you're welcoming my pawn to the
other side to promote so i i really feel
like this g2 pawn will be a target uh
maybe bishop g7 isn't the correct choice
but if bishop c5 is better and which
attacks a pawn and then you move like f3
white is frozen
it's not a fun position to have for mama
jarv and actually i just want to go a
little bit deeper if that's okay fiona
at this point if i kind of force the
issue let's say i make this move to get
the rooks off the board here i think
that this bishop will land on g3 and
this knight first comes to f4 because
after rook g8 there's bishop f2 bishop
g3 pawn and bishop protect one another
g2 is in trouble and that's exactly how
black could win this material imbalance
yeah once the g pawn uh drops that will
be the end of the game because the h the
black h pawn will then decide the game
so that is one in the ways uh in which
we could imagine rich uh not richard
young krishna
winning this game richard is a long gone
by now but let's have a look at who else
is still fighting it out here
uh so the two main clashes we were
looking forward to are still ongoing
carlson against van ferecen
against panko shouldn't we maybe go to
video and yes he panko first robert and
then check in with uh pragnanda and
grand elias
let's do it because the position has
changed between avidit and yasipanko we
saw opposite colored bishops earlier now
we have a bishop for white and a knight
for black so let's see how we got here
because it was just a few moves ago
there was a queen on e5 queen f2 rook c8
going after this pawn rook to f1 don't
take on c3 you lose a more important
pawn f6 don't take on c3 but never play
f6
um
yeah i don't believe we should uh
promote never doing things
very often
most the time almost all the time do not
push your f-pawns because your king is
less safe here f6 is a great move so
ben it's okay you'll be all right
rookie one played now don't take on c3
because there's a
nice little move here of bishop to d2 or
maybe actually bishop f4 traps no bishop
d2 looks good enough you win the rook
because the queen's under attack but for
a second i thought the queen is trapped
and then i noticed that the queen could
come to h5 so it's not quite trapped
even if it's still good for white but
either way there's a rook in line with
the queen so you should probably move
out the way he did knight to f5 and
that's where we saw the traitor pieces
and the knight came to e7 knight rook
both under attack it covers the rook it
attacks the queen and fiona as we sit in
this live position here um the pawn
structure is probably better for black
in the sense that no double pawns but i
really don't like isolated pawns in
general
yeah on the on the other side thankfully
at least on the other side uh
at least the pawn is on the light square
so it cannot be hit by the the white
uh bishop
i'm wondering if as white we can make
anything happen i wonder how safe is the
the black king i guess it is safe but
the pawn structure is looking somewhat
weird in front of the king with the
pawns on
on g7 f6 and h6
but yes i agree with you d5 is
definitely a weakness
i imagine that it will put
his bishop well i guess first of all
first things first we have to deal with
the pawn that's undefended on c3 and the
queen of course which is under attack so
i guess the queen
will come back to d3 or can we create
some threats and
avoid uh and and give up the pawn
yeah the g3 pawns i just noticed that on
two was under attack um i was going to
actually compliment black's pawn
structure on the king side because
these three pawns here restrict the
axis of this bishop if this bishop gets
to d4 we
of course know the queen's under attack
but just speaking in terms of strategies
here the bishop doesn't attack anything
the pawn on f6 is blocking it and it's
protected by upon g7 so the queen needs
to move
where to if you go back on the f-file to
protect g3 you lose c3 which does not
seem like something you want to do you
can call queen d3 but as we mentioned
you lose the g3 pawn so queen to g4
could put some pressure on the h6 pawn
because the pin queen f4 is also
plausible because after queen f4 we're
attacking the queen and if we see a
trait of queens i'm pretty sure you can
take with either the bishop or the pawn
and the reason why the pawn works is
because after rook takes c3 there's a
hanging knight on e7 so bishop d2 will
at the very least pick this pawn back up
because the rook needs to drop back to
defend the knight
and fitted has just made a move and he's
dropped back
to g4 so
that is looking down at the king on g8
and we're threatening to take on h6 i
was wondering robert what happens here
after
rook takes c3
yeah it's one of these moves where i
think a lot of players would say no you
can't do that bishop takes h6 is hanging
but then you realize that that's not the
end of the world and in fact it's not
going to be good news for white because
the rook on c3 it attacks b3 sure but
look that way the g3 pawn so rook takes
c3 bishop takes h6 and uh oh let's wait
for the bar to drop oh it didn't drop
too much but rook takes g3 is an issue
for white g7 is protected by the rook on
g3 the bishop is
uh able to be captured if the queen
moves out the way there is queen f4 and
that probably saves the day because
you're offering a queen trade and if the
queens do get traded here that's not a
good thing for black rook and knight
both under attack so i think you have to
give a check
to save the queen and then it's a mess
fiona i mean this knight is a bit loose
on
e7 but the rook is hanging and the
bishop is
stuck over here so it says slightly
better for black
and the computer is funny i have to say
i didn't expect for us to get into such
a mess here
and we see that it is back and not like
this not like this
pose
um
so yeah rook c3 seems to lead uh to a
lot of complications
but they could just be
favoring and they could just be favoring
black
because i don't think we found a way for
vidit
yeah no i'm with you i think that uh
bishop takes h6 rook takes g3 such an
important point and if you can't take on
h6 you've lost a pawn in the position
and i don't think that video's position
is that bad i think his bishop has some
promise the knight on e7 being loose is
really essential because otherwise white
would really be in in trouble i mean i
think in many of these variations that
knight being under attack some rook end
games you can even be down upon and
still hold a draw so vid it has good
chances to hold this position but now
it's yes panko's turn to play for more
and yes panko i mean he made his debut
here last year and he was in a way
almost unlucky
that jordan
won the tournament so unexpectedly
because that overshadowed pretty much
everyone else's accomplishments but
jessie panko on his first year here last
year he shared third place which was
simply a phenomenal a result beating
magnus carlsen of course on the way
but today if he can beat with it he
might just be uh the the sole leader
himself going into tomorrow's uh first
rest day
yeah it really depends if duda is able
to win his game against major because
duda entered the round tied with yes of
panko you never know what's going to
happen especially these games head
towards time trouble
but yes panko has to be proud of the way
he's been playing i mean seriously good
chess um
i i the way he handled mama jarvis g4 in
that game he was not phased he played
quite well and he was never in real
danger so
yesapanko is a promising player and
having a very good event indeed and
maybe a quick look
at pragernanda unless something is
happening in the cards and maybe we can
bring up the overview for a second to
make sure we're not
missing anything
um
so quick scan well actually robert maybe
we have to go back to magnus against
jordan because what is happening there
every game that we have left is exciting
i mean look at what is going on with
with dude it's king over there i mean
look at that
there's a king on g5 if we look on the
top row uh second from the right there's
a king on g5 and f4 check was just
played and i wonder if duda overlooked
this variation i know you mentioned
magnus's game i'm excited about that one
i don't know where to go fiona because
all of these games are fast let's go
first i think things are happening right
now in my media if you're right so let's
go there uh and
indeed could it be
that dude i missed this here so let's go
back to where we left it off
oh my gosh look at mamanjarov he found
this move g4 check
that was
oh my goodness you know this move looks
really bad because you're inviting a
past pawn but if you take on bassant
then we've traded here on the
uh
the only benefit really in black's
position and so black will not win this
game i mean the two rooks are good
enough even if you trade a pair of rooks
and win this pawn with pawns on the same
side of the board it will be a draw so
duda plays king g5 and then f4 check
this pawn can be captured this pawn can
be captured but no matter which one you
take you lose one of your minor pieces
incredible resource by shakhir
mahmedyaarov i think this was definitely
missed by yanchez of duda who took on f4
but after rookie five check as you said
uh there goes the bishop uh on
c5
and now the question is well suddenly
black is in exchange down he still has
that outside passer
on h4 how much is that pawn worth robert
i'm just still
in a bit of shock by that tactical
resource he had that's why he offered
the draw he saw all this well ahead
he's not in trouble but the h-bond is
worth its weight in gold h3 you always
think about pushing a pass bond and h3
makes sense rook c4 will be the response
and then the first question is can i
just push my pawn the answer seems to be
at first glance yes then you see
there it goes and the reason why this is
so good for white is that this rook can
come back to f1 to take care of this uh
pawn here and then there's going to be a
rook c7 at the end and i'm not even sure
you can queen right away if you are
black because if you move your king back
here rook f1 we get this situation takes
takes rook c7 i mean you're just losing
this
end game you get a rook back but you
lose your pawns
yeah so this has really uh turned around
let's go back one more time to the
position on the board
so
h3
rook here i guess the rook has to come
to f8 if you know to defend but then you
don't have your rook behind your past
pawn
yeah and it will also be it might be a
bit tricky to to untangle
so let's have a look at that um if we go
h3 rook c4 work f8
i think we have to bring one of our
rooks to the seventh rank i think this
rook is going to get behind the pawn
i think this rook is uh better to bring
because if we bring the c-rook at some
point this king can move in with a tempo
against the rook on e4 so because that
looks closer to the king i want to move
it away and if you play h2 then the rook
simply goes behind the pawn and starts
putting it in some trouble but this king
is still going to g
oh my gosh
i mean i'm shocked to be honest that the
the engine bra is going up into white's
favor now if i was right here i would be
terrified
same um it looks really worrisome to
have that pawn here i think the good
news for white is and then plenty of
these positions uh you could maybe
sacrifice your rook for the past pawn
and then start taking the queen side
pawns because a rook and knight versus a
rook if those are the pieces that are
remaining that's a theoretical draw so i
don't think that white should be
too worried but i i do see your point
fiona that this h-pawn is very scary
especially as it starts darting up the
board also a young question of duda we
hadn't seen this at all there was so
much happening in the position that we
completely forgot to look at the clock
but
if they are correct which i believe they
should be he's only got three and a half
minutes robert
thankfully he only has six moves to make
but still six moves in this position
especially when you've just had this um
what must have come as a shock this
tactical resource with this whole g4 f4
check one minute you think you are
pushing with no risk
at all and suddenly you find yourself
here not an easy spot to be in
yeah the emotions are going to be
running high
for
duda he probably felt like he was better
if not closing in on a win after
declining a draw for and then when you
miss a tactic i think that's even more
important than the evaluation the
position because sometimes like how
could i not see that like
of course that was going to happen
what's wrong with me why am i not
calculating well you get in your own
head so duda is a professional he won
the world cup and the world cup is one
of the hardest tournaments to win it's
so nerve-wracking getting into tie
breaks but here he has a tough task to
settle himself with just a couple
minutes in the clock i do think that
with proper play he should be all right
thanks to this pawn but now it's mama
jorah who is in the driver's seat and
well the hoodie speaks
yeah there will be no more draw offers
here
and that's also a problem sometimes you
turn down the draw and then it gets hard
to not you shouldn't beat yourself up of
course you should never beat yourself up
for turning down a drawful but sometimes
that can later on linger at the back of
your mind robert we're gonna go on a
very quick break the last one before all
the time control action so don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
will he take revenge robert that's the
question on everyone's mind well magnus
carlsen he certainly is hell-bent to do
so and things are happening uh in his
game things are happening everywhere
we're half an hour away from the first
time control but let's look at magnus's
game first
yeah we'll jump everywhere don't worry
we will do our best to cover all of the
exciting action here and we were just
looking at this during the break and
fiona white pushed those pawns forward
first with g5 then with h4 and you see
the eval bar creep up in white's favor
bishop e7 was played but not because of
the move rook to b2 it goes back down
you see that black is aiming all of his
firepower at this g5 pawn trying to
sacrifice the bishop there to win the
queen on g2 because it's in line with
the king and
might
you know with the engine helping us i
think my uh inside says king f1 should
be the choice just to run away but rook
b2 was magnus choice and i can't really
fault him for that this rook is getting
the open file the second rook can join
it and b7 and b8 probably the
destinations for the rooks
yeah rook b2 um not the engine's
preferred choice
we see it plummet down again and the
question is why has it done so
can we take uh on g5 i guess is the
question we have to answer
i think it's kind of funny because
bishop takes g5 you want to take with
the least valuable piece but i think
that's the mistake because after bishop
takes g5 the problem is you're actually
in a pin here so you can't move your
bishop and that may give
magnus the time to move his king next so
he allows his opponent to make a great
sacrifice that turns out to be maybe not
so great after all once the king escapes
and then perhaps you can capture their
problems on the b file the problems on
the g file just because a rook is there
doesn't mean that it's always going to
win the battle against the queen robert
is what you're saying that we can
capture on g5 with the rook
i think you might have to take with the
rook pawn takes g5 and then rook takes
g5 and we get a messy position we know
what happened in the game between
carlson and the palmashi in game six it
was two rooks against a queen here
though
the
black queen is about to swoop into g4
and at the very least that
seems like it should be a draw for black
but if the game continues here and this
rook comes to b1 and the b7
both sides have their chances
yeah for sure i think if i had to to
place a bet now i would probably go with
a draw but the time is ticking down
nerves are creeping in i think a draw is
the most likely result we will see if
you're then captures on g5
for now let's go back to the overview
for a second maybe we can see um
duda in duda's game did they repeat
moves let's very quickly uh update that
and then we'll finally go to pragma
nanda promise
oh this is a big moment because what
happened here was the king went to f3 to
attack the rook the rook went over to b4
to save itself h3 was played rook c3
check the king has to go back to g4 to
keep in touch with the knight and after
king g4 rook c4 we saw this position but
the rook had been on e4 this b4 rook was
here but i don't think it's i think it
makes a difference excuse me i just say
i think it's even worse for black now
because we saw why rook takes f4 but by
rook f1 is so good for white the queen
side pawns will fall and now after rook
f8 fiona rook takes b7 happens i am
still trying to get my rook behind the
pawn and i stole your pawn in the
process this is a really bad turn of
events for yantras of duda yeah
really really dramatic stuff here young
christian tsuda who turned down a draw
for we were so happy he seemed to have a
very very advantageous
position and then sharia finding this
incredible resource with g4 and now it
looks like he is the one
who's not just pressing but it looks
like his position is winning that rook
as you mentioned is now on the second
rank it has taken upon it is attacking
a7 it is also threatening to to get
behind the black h pawn
and what a turn of events here
and not to
be too obvious and quote searching for
bobby fischer but
take the draw and i don't mean to draw
offer i mean at this moment here after
g4
i think that duda should have taken on
g3 he was playing for a win i mean f4
probably just off his radar and after f
takes g3 here black should not be in any
trouble because the knight and the
bishop they compensate for the rook and
the pawn the king is actually perfectly
fine on f5 so he could have likely just
made
a split of the point at this moment
instead fiona he went king to g5 i think
he missed that four check i mean i don't
see why you would walk into this if you
saw of it or maybe he just made an
incorrect assessment
yes and i think the players have just
made uh move 40 so what happened after
on b7 with um
why do i keep calling him richard brian
i went h2 and after uh rook h7 kg3 this
was
uh move 40
but shakira he took a quick last look
back very often the players go away
for a toilet break or to get a drink so
we will come back here in a while for
now uh i think we're gonna keep the
camera on uh the jordan close-up oh
we came back just in time to see jordan
capture not with the rook but with the
bishop on g5
oh my goodness another big moment and
this could be a slip for the player with
the black pieces because bishop takes g5
uh oh
we talked about it there's a pin down
the g file in both directions so as we
bring up the board here and we analyze a
little bit
the rook typically wins a stare down
with the queen but here that is not the
case the queen is winning the stair down
because the rook is not defended i think
just king f1 the king can run away you
need to use this moment to get out of
the g-file and
oh although the engine's not sure about
anything anymore it is anyone's game and
if we just go and move a go i mean what
else is there besides king f1 because
taking on g5 of course is bad your queen
is in the line of fire so i think king
f1 has to happen but perhaps when the
move is played with more depth the
engine says not so fast this is still
unclear
i mean okay i guess as black we have to
find the move now which will defend the
rook
on
g6 and at the same time
maybe try and
keep looking down at the king i'm not
sure how
how we do that
all right well it's going back up so it
went down and then it goes back up so
the more it thinks the more it sits
there uh as it gains depth it is saying
that white's doing well so yeah what
move can you even consider here fiona
after king f1 that's what i'm struggling
to see
so okay let's if i
i was thinking if i get my king out of
the way but i don't want to step onto
age
seven really because then the h file
will will open i'll expose myself to
some checks um okay what if i try king
g7
so king g7 so you're protecting the rook
i guess i just take and your king will
manage to run right if i take wit yes
like that
this is the pro he played king f1 it's
on the board so the problem is that the
black king fiona is also in huge trouble
queen g4 type of moves that's not g4
that's g4 this is f5 these heavy moves
they allow the rook to come down to b7
and it's black's king that gets
checkmated first and if you play rook g1
check here the king can run away king e2
king d2 after queen g4 check there go
your checks there goes the game maybe
you can show why you didn't take the
rook on g1 at first sight it looks like
oh we can get rid of the the two
works and we'll have plenty of material
but
that would be a big mistake because of
queen h3 check
exactly the king goes away and only then
do you take the queen and black's king
has plenty of safety plenty of shelter
to be had and then this king is
in a miserable spot so we see
after king f1 queen a7
it covers the ba check and
there's queen a6 check to look out for
so this is jordan's plan if pawn takes
g5 you're about to see the engine do it
watch the bar
i knew that was gonna happen because
once this take happens on g5 there's now
the check on g1 queen h2 first queen a6
check your king cannot run away rookie 2
is the only way to block it and then
rook g1 check takes takes king takes
queen takes a2 and this actually still
might be like a potential draw somehow
if you can create a little fortress but
it's not what white wants that's for
sure and maybe you can't even get a
fortress the nigel short king walk could
happen
incredible so what do we do after queen
a7 we can't allow this
do we just have to keep running
run for the
for the hills
i think you run for d1
check
because if you play king d2 you get
checkmated on the spot thanks to queen
d3 here so you have to play king d1 and
now when the check on d3 happens your
rook slides to d2 and everything is
defended and your king is actually
tucked away quite nicely it's got like a
blanket uh it's got uh you got your
little favorite stuffed animal and
you're safe and sound ready for a good
night all that's missing is that danny
to read out some bedtime stories
yeah fabiano where are you at come on
fabiano he is uh
he is back in his hotel room after his
draw let's bring back
the overview and maybe we'll come back
to this one very shortly but maybe we
have to for a second uh look uh look at
pragnanda's game i've been promising it
for hours so a quick look there as it
looks like the bar has shut up even
further
in that
game and prague on the verge of his
first victory here in the tata steel
masters
and for niels grendelius he's playing
the lowest rated the youngest player in
the field and he's about to suffer
another defeat it's not his event that
sometimes happens to
chess players but look at the current
position fiona remember how we were all
excited about the attacking prospects
that rook that was on h1
all the way over to a7 and that's what
happens when you're full board awareness
when you're playing objective chess
you're not just going for checkmate if
we go back in time a little bit at first
in this moment a5 was played so trying
to open up the a file we liked that move
bishop g5 queen h3 and the queen went to
g7 but now the queen went back towards
the queen side and we'll get to the live
board just because there isn't that much
time left and it looks like there might
not be many moves left for neil's
castle kingside
can you believe that there's an attack
on the age file he castles he says
you're not gonna checkmate me my king is
gonna be safe and there goes the knight
the rook
and now it's white's turn here i think
bishop g4 take over the light squares
that's a terrible piece this knight is
going to be good on the g4 square
no no no no yeah the black king
is in a lot of trouble those rooks the
white rocks dominating the e file also
attacking along the seventh rank
uh so yeah bishop g4 looks very strong
um and uh pragnanda on the verge here of
uh his first victory we'll come back
here i don't know where to go robert i
want to keep an eye on everything but
there's so many things happening maybe a
quick look at fitted how far from the
time control are we there and just
i was looking at the bar dropping then
coming back we left this off
after
after vetted played queen g4 looking
down at the pawn on h6 and yes panko did
indeed take on c3
but fit it now
not taking on h6 but instead playing
bishop f4
yeah he did queen c5 check king went to
h2 so now the white king is tucked away
safe and sound king h7 h4
d4 play that move the engine at first
glance doesn't love and queen e6 and
they're in time trouble fiona so
mistakes are going to happen at this
stage of the game but i don't really
even consider
these moves mistakes i mean d4 makes
sense you have a past pawn let's push it
queen e6 very logical going after the
knight and also near this enemy king
robert i'm sorry i mean it's madness
here but we have to go back to magnus
who did not play kingy 2 which
i think i had seen in the chat was the
only move to get a winning advantage and
it looks like after queen a6
we are back to being in an equal
position again what an incredible roller
coaster
i mean we have the absolute benefit of
having the eval bar off the side we
don't know it moves but when we see it's
plus a billion we
probably know that the king is running
away magnus doesn't have that as
confirmation if he did he would find it
very quickly but queen g4 he made this
move to attack the rook trying to get
into the enemy position remember the
queen was on a7 so c8 was the square
that queen could have jumped to and now
after king
which one i don't know how to choose
between these two
options um
how do you choose it's so tough
i
i don't know i'm just gonna
okay i picked g1
it's closer to the edge of the board
i'll pick g1 and actually
where's that rook going because as soon
as your rook moves i can take this
bishop
um
do you want to yeah that rook as soon as
that rook moves he will take the bishop
you know what you might leave it there
and play rook g7 because if you take
this the king on g1 is open and so queen
takes f5 you see that there i think
bishop f4 queen f1 is mate oh my god
king h1 checkmate
thanks to all these pieces
what a crazy
crazy game
so magnus okay he has to even be careful
so let's see this again
after king
g1
he went back to g7
so i cannot take you on f5 well i'm
actually the one that's going to get
mated if i don't take you
on f5 then what do i do
um
great question
so if this is as scary as it looks i
think it is can he play queen to e2 and
just
try to trade queens that like seems to
be the safest option
yeah of course i'm not gonna do you that
favor
i don't think although
maybe i could but i would love to keep
this on say to you robert please be my
guest take my bishop
yeah okay i guess you want
this and this and we get an even worse
version for white because if this queen
had somewhere to go on the diagonal
white would be
doing okay but there's no squares on the
diagonal to work with and so the black
queen
will go to a6 if the queen moves if the
queen doesn't move there's rook g1 and
queen h3 checkmate so that's why this is
so winning for
black
yeah so
i mean what an
incredible little game there's still two
moves to make for
for magnus before he reaches the time
control only three and half minutes on
the clock
first this decision which we ended up
just picking a square i don't know i was
going to say at random you chose it
robert so i don't want to do you any
disservice but it's not so easy to
decide uh which of the two squares do
you want to go to
i didn't know and you saw me i was
hovering over them i was like um let's
just pick one and i picked g1 simply
because it was closer to the edge of the
board i don't i mean it probably does
matter but i just felt i know another
difference actually in king g2 there
could be a moment where queen c8 is
really nasty because brook takes f2
check is a threat but with the king on
uh exposing the queen on g4 if the
king's on g1 there's never any kind of
like rook takes f2 as an option so i i
don't really know why this is even in
this variation i understand queenie 2
looks safer now than looking here sorry
robert but we've had a result in the
game between vivid uh but pre-invented
anti-seipenko that has
ended in a draw we can come back to here
later and see what happened i think we
should stick with magnus and see the
last couple of moves
before did they reach mu 40 so magnus
he decided to go with the square that's
closer to the edge of the board the king
is on g1
and now
the question is well rook g7 were also
assisted a little bit by the engine is
it the only move for jordan
a queen c8 is another move that comes to
mind but i don't want to put my queen on
this back rank in line with the king so
for example queen c8 you see that if i
can get my rook to b8 and well actually
it right away is nasty because if you
take i take on f5 hitting your rook so
you don't have any discoveries with your
bishop and then i will take your bishop
next move and your whole position is
done
unbelievable so it could be that uh rook
g7 is the only move it's also not an
obvious move
to find for jordan
no i mean i'm just helped by the
evaluation bar off to the side i'm like
well i mean i don't see initially this
is an even position and that's the huge
difference between sitting and chatting
about the game and taking moves back and
seeing our options i'm drawing arrows
the player is like okay well if i make
this move that doesn't look great but
then you have to just dig deep calculate
and jordan he's fully concentrated here
besides rook to g7 i'm trying to
i think he's sorry to interrupt i think
he's not seeing it yet from what i can
see from his face he's making the kind
of faces when you don't see anything and
and you think that maybe you messed up a
little bit he's shaking his head
and he doesn't look too happy right now
and i don't blame him because you know
there's so many things to calculate rook
g7 is a rook b8 check you always have to
watch out for your own king if you're
jordan so
there are so many options in this
position i don't envy his task here
it is a huge huge assistance to have the
eval bar off the side
yeah and also well his time situation
five minutes uh five minutes for two
moves but this is a really tough move to
find rook g7
with both players here full focus
and i think this is the decisive moment
of the of the game
will he find it he's down to four and a
half minutes he's thinking here and it's
a position where a mutual oversight
could happen because it's very complex
and there are so many options that look
pretty good
the thing is as we keep saying fiona as
soon as we make a move we see how the
eval bar reacts the players are all
calculating this in their head trying to
figure it out and
the rook on f5 is threatened so you have
to deal with that threat you can't move
your bishop from g5 your rook on g6 is
undefended so that's why scooting the
rook back with rook g7 uh does make
sense and is easy to explain but very
difficult to see when you're
in the moment under pressure
there's also a suggestion what about a
c5 which would also do the same
job
of defending the the work on g6
and rook g7 he has found it
just in time before someone stepped in
front of the camera but wow what a move
uh jordan finding rook g7 and now dybala
is once again in magnus's camp there is
also some danger looming
for magnus who has one final move to
make and two minutes 40 on the clock
before the time control is reached
and i don't think we found the move that
keeps equal for magnus we found the move
that kept it equal for jordan i don't
know what magnus should play here
seriously you can't take on g5 because
rook takes g5 you lose your queen you're
gonna get checkmated um
where does magnus go here
we've talked about the check on on b8
what happens after that check
there might be bishop d8 i block you
sacrifice my bishop and then your queen
is pinned to your king so i i i don't
know
what things
i'm seeing in the chat there's a few
suggestions of rook takes c6 rubbers
what is that move
okay well so that makes perfect sense uh
they're obviously using engines unless
we have you know in each geary did you
come to the chat otherwise they're all
just using the uh engines um
that makes sense now that it's mentioned
because the queen is not that can't draw
my arrows is covering this diagonal so
remember the variation we just showed up
the queen takes up five it wasn't bishop
takes e3 we're stopping instead one
square short of expectations because as
you see here you take a rook on
uh c one you get checkmated right away
you're just done it's over so you play
bishop f4 check instead the king can't
go to h2 the king can't go to f1 it
can't go to the g file so you have to go
king h1 and that was the checkmate so
rook takes c6 which is such a difficult
move to find no matter how much time you
have left but it distracts the queen
away so now the queen's on c6 we can
take this rook and if you do any sort of
bishop takes e3 or bishop f4 now the
king can even come to h1 there is no
check on f1 and again the black king is
being checkmated so if magnus finds rook
takes c6 it's jordan who has the burden
of seeing why it's then a draw like both
of these players have so much to work
through and this is peak drama because
it is move 40 how do players wish they
could have made one move more and have
an extra 50 minutes but they don't 30
seconds on the clock for magnus
and i don't think it's rook c6 what did
he move
rook b8 check
oh my gosh okay so he goes rook to b8
can't fault him for not finding rook
takes c6 especially with such a little
time when it's called and the
complications would have continued from
there he plays rook b a check bishop d8
funeral that was the automatic reaction
i was having because all other moves are
bad right and i think jordan has the
same automatic reaction there he goes
bishop g8 is on the board
that's right because other moves just
lose so we were talking as earlier when
someone's in time trouble if their only
moves they're easier to find
magnus is going to take this bishop
he is then going to have to give up his
queen for the rook i'm not sure if
jordan wants to trade the other pair of
rooks first or if he wait a second oh my
gosh king h7 is there rook d7 fiona oh
my goodness
oh my god i think there is you have to
play rook f8 because king h7 rook d7 i
distract your rook from the pin of my
queen and once you take the rook on d7
because i'm throwing the checkmate you
on g7 i take your rook with check and
win your other rook and just win on the
spot so king h7 is losing and that means
that rook f8 is forced here and then we
trade off all of the pieces these come
off this comes off and we had a position
like this earlier fiona where i was
saying that maybe a3 bishop to b4 and
actually this looks like a fortress that
white should not lose
i mean what
what a game robert i don't know what to
say even this i'm looking at you talk
about this fortress
uh
are you not afraid that my black king
will manage to get to f3 will you manage
to stop me
let me pretend to be confident for a
second i've had no idea what's going on
all game so i am imagining that this
should be a fortress but you're
absolutely right we can't just say the
game's a draw it should be a draw no no
no with that king entering the light
squares maybe even to f3 the queen
wrapping around towards the king side
this king could be in big trouble so the
game will continue jordan of course will
not just agree to a draw but i think
that it should be a draw proving it is
another matter altogether and euro then
has of course played rook f8 not
stepping into that uh blonde word king
h7 which would be incredible
so we're gonna see this uh fortress like
end game unfold here and the bird's eye
view well we've had four draws so far
but i think every other game has just
been incredible it looks like both
mamadiarov and pragnanda are on the
verge of winning their games let's
immediately go to prague they aren't on
move 40 yet
still two moves to make four nils grand
alias but look at those rook on the
seventh rank look at the witness after
pawn on e5 on the pawn of the pawn on b6
niels is trying to hold on he has just
played a king g8
trying to get out of the seventh rank
and this is the last move now to make
for prague before he gets an additional
50 minutes
it is a pretty big moment here though
because it's the type of position it's
move 40 and he has 20 something seconds
left is that right
he's like no time
i think that's correct he's reaching out
already
uh i think he has the i the clock at his
eyes on the clock and he has just made
his
final 40th move king f2 and immediately
gets up
from the board now the ball is it needs
this court who's also on just we can see
there 40 seconds
for his
final uh move
but of course it's a lot more difficult
here to make moves uh for black
perennials his position is completely
crammed he's just defending
passively and still it will not be
enough here
i think it's like queen h4 check because
it's a check and it's the last move of
the time patrol it at least gives you
some
faint semblance of hope like oh i gotta
check in maybe my queen will come to h1
it should definitely be losing because
there's this pressure down the seventh
rank and the black king is in trouble
and there he goes queen h4 check uh but
the ghost i don't think it was queen h4
i think it was the other it looked like
something happened towards the the
bottom of the h-fight but it was
actually rook h1
um great move because queen hitch for
check is a big threat trying to go and
checkmate the white king so that's what
happens on move 40. the eval bar still
is in prognando's favor he's about to
hit zeros on the clock but he will gain
more time that's what happens when you
reach the 40th move and fiona as long as
he doesn't blunder queen h4 check and a
mating attack uh for black i think you
should sidestep that check to begin with
king de2
and it's gonna go back up i'm not
worried so you see here that um there's
no check on h4 and if you try to go all
in for some kind of mate this knight has
the h6 square there might be a sacrifice
here at some point the e5 pawn is loose
so you need to create some sort of
threat if you are niels and this king is
just going to walk to the queen side and
try to find safety there indeed so this
is looking good for prague we'll just
have to find a couple of precise moves
we're going to go for a break in a just
a second but let's quickly update the
last remaining game that is mamedyarov
against duda
okay pulling that up right now
and there is an eval bar that's very
high the move king to b3 an accurate
choice by mama jaro because his rook now
can walk back along the c file helping
to
prevent this pawn from
promoting if king g2 the movie you'd
want to play to promote then the rook
comes to c2 with check and you just lose
the pawn on the spot the two rooks team
up and fiona this is another big problem
is that if this rook leaves f8 say to go
rook e8 the end game after rook takes h2
is winning for white
you take the rook you lose your knight
and then you're going to lose this pawn
thanks to how strong this king on b3 is
it will likely walk up the board and the
rook will help out attacking this pawn
the king on h2 is out of the game
absolutely so uh this game i mean what a
wild game this was uh
a dramatic turnaround for uh duda but
i saw earlier in the chat someone was
saying the power of the hoodie well
he certainly has been so resourceful and
it looks like shakia is going to get his
first win
as well
robert i think we're going to take a
quick breather it the day started quite
slowly but then it exploded everywhere
and we still have three games going here
anything could still happen so you don't
want to go anywhere and we'll be back in
a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we are back and we see the discussion
there between
magnus carlsen and jordan
van fereced
who have agreed
to
a draw
so if we bring up
the game between the two players and we
see them
discussing there
so we left
we left off here after rook
rook to a f8 well let's first watch the
players
analyze so what happened here we thought
it was gonna all take some time as they
get an extra minute at 50 minutes on
move 50 but hurden quickly recaptured
magnus gave a check on b4
king g8 so
we thought this was going to go on for a
while but i believe robert was probably
correct in that this is just a fortress
jordan tried to bring his king via g6
which was my idea but it turns out there
was no way in for this black king
the king cannot get further than g4 so
after c5 jordan giving up a pawn to open
the sixth rank for the the black queen
and after bishop takes we just had a
repetition here with queen g6 jack king
f1 queen a6 uh and so on and so forth
and the draw was agreed robert what a
game
seriously that was an awesome finish to
a great game
there will always be mistakes in a game
of chess but that was really exciting
and both players gave it their all
particularly jordan von forrest he
sacrificed not just one pawn but a
second as well and he was ready for a
clash with the world champion absolutely
during our quick break i saw that evan
sokolov who has worked with jordan in
the past tweeted something along the
lines of fortune favors the brave he is
very impressed uh with jordan's
performance here so far i don't know
what we just saw on the screen there
looked like some kind of private uh joke
between the two uh players and
yeah what a game magnus uh definitely i
think the only big chance he missed was
probably this moment with kingi too but
of course
we're sitting here you know we have the
evil bar it is a lot easier and both
players uh well it's very nice to see
their smiles um and i hope we are going
to hear from them um and hear their
thoughts about what was a fascinating
game
that would be great and it looks like
mama jarov has won his game against
yanchus of duda so for all of those
early draws that we've seen from mama
jarv that he's been fighting like no
other you have to give him credit he
comes up with creative innovative lines
and this one was not going his way for a
while but it ended up in his favor as
you just quoted
fortune favors the brave fortune favors
the bold and mama jarov is quite a bold
chess player
absolutely four young christians do that
what a tough loss before the rest day
the draw for we caught it on camera it's
quite rare for us to catch a draw
on camera it was turned down which was i
believe absolutely the right decision
but then uh yeah this moment with g4 f4
uh bolt out of the blue
and jacquia mamedyarov getting his first
win here this year that leaves us with
only one game it all happened so fast
suddenly
robert but the only game remaining is
pragnanda against niels and after move
40 the players got an extra 50 minutes
and pragnanda is still thinking here how
to deal with this threat of queen h4
check
that is correct and
he if you just look at this position
fiona it's one that i would say that you
know black should just resign and i
don't recommend that people resign but
all of the pluses in the position are in
white's favor
these pawns here all on light squares
there's a knight on g4 that can ever be
touched because the dark square bishop
that's only staring into its own pawns
both of which are weak and attacked by
white's pieces two rooks in the seventh
rank you couldn't ask for more the only
thing that's causing pragmatism trouble
is his king on f2 if this king were
somewhere over here like on b3 then the
position would just fall apart for black
i imagine so i think the move king to e2
is a step in the right direction that
way you avoid queen h4 check and if the
queen does come to h4 i'm
not gonna take your bishop on c7 because
you'll see what the evaluation part does
to you there it is queen e1 check king
to d1 and this king is just
too far out in the open king c3
check
king here
check so many checks not really
many places to run to if you go to a2
you lose c4 if you're a queen c3 rook to
b1 so it just what if i want to a4
you run to a4 i'm going to take here you
have to go back to a3 and
i must have some oh i'll trade rooks
because that gives me a check here
it's too tricky
no i just like you you say ask a
question i was like wait how am i gonna
deliver these checks uh i get that check
because queen d3 check i guess that also
takes care of things you can just
because the queen can't block then
there's
the rook coming to a1 so wow the king
wants to run but it doesn't want to
allow the black queen in with a check
and that's why i was going to say
instead of taking this bishop on c7 if
you just back the rook up to a1 you
remove black's only threat in the
position that was the only the one
threat and now if we trade rooks
black's position still remains terrible
the king is actually quite safe the
knight can always retreat the queen's
about to join on the a file e5 is
hanging i think
i i just
i'm having trouble looking at this
position yeah it is certainly a a
very ugly position for me for me it's
always it is quite incredible to look at
this position of course we understand it
is winning for white but material is
even and the engine just says plus 8
this is game over
yeah this is unfortunately uh it looks
worse than that for neil's i mean just
none of his pieces with the exception
being this rook on h1 are really doing
all that much and all of white's pieces
are active so
i think pragnanda he's just
several moves away from ending this game
and getting his first victory in the
masters section
yeah i think it once again it makes a
lot of sense uh when you get an extra 50
minutes
uh and you're on the verge of what will
be a big win for him
for pragnanda you want to take
your time there is no russia he knows he
is winning he knows he just has to take
care
of some final
some last threats by nils but
it looks like he's getting ready to make
a move to me
yeah i was thinking the same thing he's
he's up oh there he goes
and i think he went rook a1 first so
maybe king e2 is not strictly necessary
he brings the rook back and the
advantage yeah it's still tremendous for
him um if the rook is not going to be on
each one for much longer if you trade
then you still have a problem down the a
file problem down the seventh rank
there's a pass pawn on d5 that's
protected and if you think about the
pawn structure fiona white has this
wonderful pawn on d5 and the material is
even so like where's black's pawn is
this one on b6 which makes the bishop
look bad it can't move so it's just
clear that
everything positionally speaking is
favoring white
yes indeed and then niels now
this is a depressing spot and i think
even from neil's face um he knows of
course that this one is gone and he's
had as we mentioned before a really
tough start to the tournament he is most
likely going to walk out of uh out of
the playing hall today on a half out of
four's score which of course is not what
he wanted last year i think in the same
situation going into the first rest day
he was one of the tournament leaders um
but hopefully he will be able to bounce
back he will try and fight here but
as you pointed out there's just too many
problems in this position and the white
king is uh safe enough
for there not really to be too many
tricks here for for black
and as we see the emptying playing hall
i do want to give a quick shout out to
somebody that's not in the masters
section it actually is arjun eric geisse
he won his game today with the black
pieces he moved to three and a half out
of four in the challengers and we know
that the winner of the challengers gets
to take place in the masters tournament
in the following year so to see arjun
continue his success i think at first
fiona people thought that he's a rapid
and blitz specialist because that's
where he had the most opportunity he was
playing online he's been known for so
many years on chess.com as he's been in
the junior speeches championship playing
in all the biggest events title tuesday
blitz reading above 3000 and now he gets
to show the world that no it's not just
the quicker time patrols in all time
patrols any game of chess he's ready to
play against the world's best and he is
right now in the sole lead in the
challengers yeah i mean
for me
uh i'd never kept such a close eye i
think i wasn't so familiar with him i'd
heard of him but suddenly he made such a
big
splash all over the different across
different online offline
rapid blitz classical he's been
everywhere these last
few months i'm so happy he got the
chance to play here
in the challenger section he's off to a
fantastic
start and yeah long may made continue i
believe here um
in vikanzi he's working with suinat
narayanayan but other than that i think
he's been working with none other than
rustam kazanjanov who was done well what
an experienced coach he is for the fide
uh former fiji world champion himself
he's worked with vichy he's worked with
fabiano he's worked with the best of the
best
and isn't rusam also working with abdu
satarov and who recently won the world
rapids championship so not bad
in terms of coaching duty but you know
arjun is one of the many young talents
from india and of course we have
vishyanan to thank for much of the
success of the current generation he's
an inspiration he's a national hero he's
beloved in india and i think arjun you
know nowadays maybe not so much
overlooked because of his success
particularly in rapid and blitz but
we know nihal sarin that's the name that
everyone talks about and then we forget
there's gukesh there's raunch sedwani
there's arjun there's pragnanda i'm
definitely missing like four more names
but india is really thriving it's
blossoming as a chess country
and we have to give a shout out to the
former world chess champion our our
friend vishy anand but also just all the
coaches there you mentioned
master narayanan and so many people who
are supporting indian
grand master ramesh
fantastic coach well known as the leader
of the national team for a long time so
it's really awesome to see that and for
niels he's probably thinking hey someone
root for the swedes why not us but it's
not his event it's not his game and
unfortunately sweden is not as stocked
with
future potential champions
on the bright side this is a long event
and even after today's game there will
still be nine rounds to go very often
most events are only nine rounds long so
hopefully
uh he can
um clear his head tomorrow on the rest
day and then
come back uh
in the fighting mode and i'm sure he
will after
uh after the rest day but yeah robert
you talked about all these uh indian
players i mean this summer the olympiad
is hopefully going to be back after four
years and i don't envy the task of
whoever is going to be in charge of
picking the the indian team
right because there's some people that
are obvious if she decides to play of
course he'll be on the team vidit who is
doing so well here in the master's
tournament three out of four heading
into the rest day you have uh patella
hari krishna and then you're like well
who's next we've got adiban we've got
nihal sarin and then we just enlisted
all these other players in addition to
the slightly older generation than all
the teenagers but you're spoiled for
choice at this point being a fan of
india and it's really awesome to see
so many of these players they take part
in just pretty much every event they
possibly can so uh it's awesome it
really is and pragananda he's making his
mark on this field in the early going
absolutely what they need to do robert
maybe is organize organized olympiad
themselves that way they can field two
or three teams and i believe they could
literally have
at least two teams in the top ten that's
how strong and how many up and coming
players uh there are meanwhile yeah we
are looking at neil's neil's heaven
hasn't uh moved yet
i see a lot of people it is sad looking
looking at him
but
um
for prague it will be a huge moment and
nils he will be back
for sure
yes he can defeat anybody in this field
last year he started off with a bang
this year it's going the complete
opposite direction but it's still a long
tournament
his next opponent i'm not sure who it is
but they better be on the lookout
because neil's grandious he can compete
with all the best players but you know
we see him here you have to feel for him
i've been the last game playing it
around on numerous occasions where i'm
trying my best just trying to come up
with a way to survive some hope here a
little bit of chances there
but realistically he knows that this
position is gone he has no
way in the king is coming to e2 the rook
on b7 followed by the rook eventually
coming back to a7 or queen entering on
the a file e5 b6 all weaknesses the king
on g8 not happy either if the rook
leaves the h file ever there's knight h6
check so just so many issues to deal
with and
white has way too much firepower
robert i didn't want to interrupt you
there you were in such a flow with
pulled up already in the pairings and so
let's take a quick look
um at what awaits us in round five so
that will be after tomorrow's rest day
so on the 20th of january well you were
saying i don't know who niels uh is
gonna be facing but things aren't going
to get easier because he will be playing
white against none other than world
champion magnus carlson
who
like i said i don't know who he's
playing so i mean who is that guy magnus
uh
gosh well that's not actually a fun
pairing to have when you're losing a
bunch of games and then you've played
mags or maybe
you know things can't really get worse
for nils and it's just the opponent he
needed to feel inspired
so that's going to i think niels will be
inspired i think usually likes to to
fight it out against uh the best another
standout pairing i see is well the two
local players anish geary will be
playing his great good friend vidit
gujrati
and jordan ran for race against shahid
mahmoud those are two clashes that i
already very much look forward to
well jordan against mama jarv that could
be my game of the round for round five
both players are extremely creative
especially in the opening stage i think
that rapport getting the white pieces
against pragnanda that should be a fun
battle as well
duda against karjakin both players going
to be disappointed due to losing the
game today a position he probably felt
he would never in a million years lose
and karjakin with the white pieces he
really just didn't do anything he made a
quick draw against nishikiri and he lost
yesterday's game against yes panko so
he's probably not in the best frame of
mind and that will be of course a repeat
of the the world cup uh final match up
with both players qualifying
to the candidates tournament
and meanwhile niels he is still thinking
we haven't
well we keep pointing out the problems
with black's position the reason we
don't talk so much about
what can black do is because simply
there isn't so much we have looked at
the check on h4 but the king is going to
be safe
um
and oh we actually we have an interview
so let's just play your first black game
against magnus golson in your career
an eventful game it was yeah very
eventful
a lot of crazy things happened i
i still have to process the game so
but it was definitely a fun game
probably what i was doing was not
very correct but
i thought if i
slow play it i'm i'm gonna get
positionally squeezed so i wanted to go
for some
complications and uh
at least i think then the white position
is tough to play but yeah it was it was
definitely crazy game
um and then there was all this mess on
on g5
g4 like yeah yeah yeah the pawns on h4
and g5 i could take on g5 but
my head kind of hurt and i couldn't
calculate very well so i was just trying
to attack g5 as many times as possible
and then sacrifice somehow but it was
just insanely complicated to calculate
all the variations for me
so i have no idea what exactly was going
on
um
yeah magnus apparently missed a couple
of ways to uh well to win or get like a
big advantage one of them was like
king h king f1 instead of
queen to g4 i believe yeah yeah i heard
just now actually from uh peter that he
had king e2 but i honestly didn't even
consider
that that possibility there so
yeah just didn't consider it are you
relieved that
yeah did you manage to play the draw
yeah it's very good the result of course
i didn't expect to make a draw um during
the game i was even maybe
moderately optimistic at some point
maybe useful optimism but
yeah probably objectively it was never
good for me and playing against magnus
with black it's definitely a very good
result for me
so how does it work like after the game
like you have work together so
are you like on friendly terms after the
game do you talk about the game or like
yeah we talked about the game i think he
also found an interesting game so we
talked a bit uh
so yeah that's that's what we did
any plans for the rest day um no not not
specifically but we'll see uh what pops
up okay well the best of luck thank you
so much
[Music]
jordan van ferece
he is clearly satisfied with what he
called a crazy game and it certainly was
uh we might have another quick look at
that later on um but here we see once
again well the pairings i think what we
meant to show you i will bring up here
in a moment the results from today for
those of you who might just be tuning in
uh we only had one decisive result with
what mahmoud of beating young kids of
duda but robert as so often that doesn't
tell the whole story
no it certainly does not i mean the game
between carlson and von forest could
have gone either way we are going to get
our second decisive result in this game
unless something very strange happens
but it's looking uh particularly bad for
niels grandilius and some of the other
draws were also full of life uh some
were not some were uh
quite quick but vidiq gujarati against
andreas panko that was a fight that just
so happened to end in an even position
and uh
i was thinking about you know what how
to explain
why this position is as winning as the
engine pointed out to be and so i just
wanted to like make a move i don't know
look back because if you trade your only
active piece you're going to get
squeezed so i thought i could make the
move rook to h7 and what i want to do at
some point is give up my
rook for this bishop i'm not sold i
should do it right now
but i was thinking that
at the moment that i can do it i'm going
to take this pawn on e5 and your
position is going to fall in in part in
its entirety so if you take with the
queen i could even throw in rook a8
check i wouldn't be surprised if that's
the best move because rook f8 is met by
knight f6 check taking advantage of a
pin so now i guess just get that fun
with tactics you go here i take your
rook if you take here it's like oh great
we traded everything it's even now right
no i'll just take this pawn and then
i'll take this pawn or i'll check you
here and grab this pawn or trade queens
and everything is just collapsing for uh
black d6 trying to checkmate your king
it's only one pawn you may say but it's
also plus 7.3
yeah
and that shows you the power of an
active queen
uh
very often especially queen endings it's
not always about just a material uh
balance but how active the queen is how
advanced the pawns are
and yeah
we see there the shake
of uh the head
i know niels well he's a great friend of
mine so i've seen this face before
unfortunately
um
niels he knows uh that this that the
position is lost i know that he has a
lot of fans in the chat he will keep
fighting but uh
i think yeah
i'm repeating myself forever but he will
not let this one slip
nah
just one of these positions where you
look at the eval bar and it says plus a
million and then you look at the
position and that also says plus a
million there's no mismatch sometimes we
have positions where it's like wait it's
that much better for one side no but i
see all these chances for the opponent
we see nothing
to
be afraid of if you're pragnanda and we
hardly see a move for neil's at this
point and i mean from speaking frankly
it's just the most
difficult type of position to have to
sit and try to will yourself to continue
playing i mean look at the guy it's not
fun to see
nils looking like this he's obviously uh
very upset with how the game has gone
with his current position but he is
doing the right thing so he deserves
some credit
by remaining in the game not resigning
because perhaps there is something
that pragnanda can miss it just doesn't
seem apparent to me indeed and for those
wondering about the clock that will
adjust after neil and makes his next
move i think i saw it on the camera i
think niels has spent about 15 minutes
uh after the the time control so he
should i think they are roughly on the
same amount of time now both around the
35 minute mark
yes and it almost looked like he was
about to move
we see 33 minutes and counting down here
but
when you have a position that's even in
material
and you're as lost as this one is that's
just
i've been there and i've been there at a
much earlier stage of the game yeah and
he has just
made a move and it is
rook uh rook h4
and now neil stepping away from the
board prague is back already and prague
is actually spoiled for choice here
i mean you know me
material it's not mine i'm sacrificing
it
rotates c7 does look good
uh to to my eyes because if the rook
takes c7 i'm just collapsing your
position completely e5 now
has lost its defender if you take with
the queen on c7 i can just take that
pawn on e5 this pawn on g6 is under
attack rook a8 check is still on the
horizon i mean if you try to defend this
pawn here rookie 8 king h7 and your king
is about to get mated i feel like and
there's got to be just
some tactic where is it
knight g4 you'll take i see that still
good for white probably winning
but i want to find
the knockout you know that the perfect
chess where is it these positions can be
so frustrating sometimes because it
feels like
i am just a move away i just need to
find a move but what is the damn move
i see one cool tactic i'm not sure if
it's right uh if you take here there's
rook h a check
and after king takes h8 there's knight
f7 oh my goodness
rook is pinned and then that's a fork
that's a lovely tactic actually
yeah i would and one of the things i was
thinking about was here actually playing
rook hh check
because after king takes h8 there's
knight takes g6 and then i get your rook
here but i didn't like
the prospects of leaving your rook on g7
and on the g file
this looks good enough but the other
looks even stronger yeah just having fun
at this point right
yes so
did you mean to take us
from the start
i was trying to refresh the page and i
clicked the wrong thing and i was trying
to uh
you know then go send a message at the
same time so
when you're multitasking
you just go wrong
well i think anyway uh very soon it is
time for us to take another short break
we will let pragnanda think things true
and i will be back with this final
remaining game
from round four so don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
at tata steel we place artificial
intelligence into the center of our
innovation program so we can innovate
faster than ever before
data analyzing techniques are not only
fun to work with but it really helps me
to work on sustainability for example
reducing dust emissions this is a really
important topic for me
we have developed the digital tools to
accurately predict the performance of
our products in the processes of our
customers
quantifying the performance of our
products is key in making our customers
and us successful
we achieved world-class process
stability by using ai to forecast and
control the outcomes of over 2000
simultaneous reactions
we use cameras instead of eyes and
computers instead of human brains so in
the near future our factories can make
their own decisions
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nakamura is playing for the win even
though his opponent has a pawn one step
away from becoming a new queen it's
sensational the amount of risks hikaru
is taking here it seems like black is
making some progress finally and well he
just made the decision to trade off
everything he did get a draw but that
could very easily have been a win it
looks like it should be winning for bb
sarah i mean black only has that one
queen in the attack and white has an
extra piece and lots of pawns i think
we're going to see a little bit of an
upset in this game and music ends up
losing on time and asoba yeva confirms
her excellent form by winning that
matchup this is incredible
bartos sachiko is up a piece against
magnus carlsen sachiko playing in his
native poland has a winning position and
magnus resigns sachiko is on a perfect
score having defeated the reigning world
champion the lead just keeps changing
but soba eva has already been in the
lead and now she's going to get it back
i mean because this game is about to be
over and chuvalova has to resign in the
end she was five pawns down there's no
hope saving that we got cinderella and
fedo save is actually the battle of the
leaders on seven points out of eight
there's a pawn end game now only pawns
remaining and cinderella is going for
the win cinderella is going for the win
try to say it brushes his king back into
defense and the guys agreed to a draw oh
my gosh and both of these players remain
in the lead
a run-in with an extra pawn in the rook
end game and federer say if he's unable
to do anything about the white pawns in
conjunction with the white king just
making their way up the board it's over
levana runyan taking the lead in the
tournament
of ronin rushing his king over to the
left-hand side trying to get rid of
black stroke the king is now coming to
the aid of the pawn that's only two
squares away from becoming a new queen
and of running is making very good
progress here and anish giri resigns the
game lavon aronian 13 points fantastic
result he's playing so confidently
hikaru nakamura is not on the list he
tested positive for covid and had to
withdraw from the tournament bb zara has
a one and a half point lead she's gonna
win it if she wins this one and look at
this bb sarah with her queen can go for
the queen trade if the queens are traded
she's gonna win this game and she does
go for it the queens are traded off the
board the bishop coming in against the
white king to give a check and koyachkin
of recites a sophaeva is the world
champion
a lot of credit to our women's world
blitz champion the young player from
kazakhstan making her name known to the
whole world maxim making his
calculations can he stop that black pawn
in time and he thinks he can do that
after lots of captures it's a runyon
who's down by a pawn but of ronan's king
is unable to assist against the white
king making its way forward and arrogant
now will resign the game and what a
stunning turn around there he made a
couple of mistakes and the frenchman
capitalizes on that dubai trying to get
his pieces pointing in towards black's
king but oliver has a pawn one step away
from becoming a new queen and he has
made a queen and he knows that he can
always stack that queen for the bishop
and that is the end of the game and we
are almost certainly guaranteed a tie
for first place after the final game
he's using his queen to help out that
pawn is moving forward and aronian now
he's gonna have to resign the pawn is
becoming a new queen of ronian does keep
on playing but there's no hope he
resigns the game was that the
championship for ali reza from ruja
actually it's definitely not the
championship because young christoph
duda has managed to win his game so
there will be a tie the question is
whether or not maxim bashar lagrave will
be able to join them and bashar al-arab
has beaten magnus carlsen young
christoph duda and
will be playing for the gold medal
it's less than 30 seconds on the clock
for duda who needs to figure out this
end game and he chooses to push his pawn
forward exactly he chose to protect it
with this rook before not going in for
that trade where he might lose a pawn
yeah the pawns are just getting
exchanged off and the guys agreed to
draw the handshake there a solid game
from duda dude is actually giving away
his bishop a strange decision from the
polish player there he chooses to move
the one knight at losing the other i'm
not thrilled about where white took this
position because certainly he's not
better at all in this end game dude is
going to have to play for a draw yeah
certainly i don't see any danger at all
black they just agreed to a draw now to
find the victor of this tournament we're
going to play one game at a time and if
someone wins that is the world champion
maxim bashar nagrav now in the end game
dude are trying to use his king to stop
white's king from getting into the game
but here with simba shiela craft is able
to capture another pawn on the side of
the board two extra points for him now
dude of resides mcsimba shiela grab the
world champion in 2021
and here we see a maxim bashar grav
being congratulated he is the world
blitz champion
[Music]
[Music]
fastest
[Applause]
welcome back to the final moments of
this fourth round here at the tata steel
gesturement as pregnant is just putting
the finishing touches on his game
against neil scrandelus and robert it
looks like he heard you because
he did indeed
take that bishop on c7
he did and after rook takes e7 he
grabbed the pawn e5 with his queen and
as we get to the live position with
queen e6 devastation all around g6 is
hanging the f7 rook is pinned the knight
is about to join the party on e5 and
black is
not going to be able to deal with all of
these threats and we saw prognonona kind
of look at nils he was like i got this
one this one is mine now you can resign
any time and it won't be too early and
the reason is king g7 protects both the
g6 pawn and gets out of the pin but
knight e5 rook f6 in comes that rook to
a7 with check the king has to run
somewhere if it goes to h8 you have a
fork on f7 and you get to win the rook
for the night and then go check him with
the king if the king goes up to h6 the
knight can come to g4 with check forking
the rook and the king and in a position
like this the queen comes back and is
going to deliver a checkmating attack
right here
yeah and
i really think these are the final
moments pregnant has played this all
very confidently and
the position as you say is just
uh collapsing and there is no holding it
together sometimes there are some
positions in which you can give back
some material and try and hold
a worse end game but here
that's just not happening maybe we can
look at you just highlighted it there
what happens if niels tries to do just
that
well he can survive maybe a couple more
moves let's say you bring your queen out
to f6 which protects the pawn you just
play e5 and even at king g7 you play e5
if you don't take the pawn and they're
connected past pawns walking up the
board if you do take after queen takes
g6 check if you block on g7 here with
your queen i bring my rook in with check
you bring your rook here i take you take
and this is kind of funny you you may
want to take a free pawn it's better to
just transition into a winning king and
pawning game because you're up a pawn
it's a pass pawn you free up a second
one and then the game is very clearly
over and just as we say that while niels
has just captured
uh on g first so we might something see
something like this unfold over the
board
yeah queen takes back for sure is what
uh prague will play because if you take
with the pawn you allow queen h4 check
which
very likely is still great for white but
why allow that check just take with the
queen you have everything in your
position covered but i also like that
he's thinking he's not rushing he has
plenty of time left and with accuracy he
knows he's going to take home this
victory yes indeed he is not rushing but
he is reaching out and i think
it will indeed be queen takes not
allowing any counterplay not ruining the
pawn structure
um
the queen from g4 will still be
attacking the pawn on g6
but plenty of time still on the clock
for pregnant and there he goes green
takes g4 is on the board
and this game has been a different type
of impressive compared to say vidit's
defensive prowess shown against dubai
from yesterday
the program had an advantage as early as
when he pushed his pawn up to h4 and
then cemented his pawn on d5 he was
better and he's been better the whole
game and he never let go of that
adventure in fact there was not a moment
where it seemed like he wasn't going to
be pressing so you have to give the
youngster so much credit for being for
being able to handle
the nuances the subtleties of a game
like this where he first opened the h
file then decided to open up the a file
castled kingside after all that brought
his rooks up the board he has played a
fantastic game very precise uh very s
like solid game but not in the way that
was passive in a way that was improving
his position move after move quite
karpovian
yes which is uh i think if 10 years ago
yet told someone this is the effort
by a 16 year old it would have been hard
to believe but what a mature performance
never losing his cool first as you said
attacking on the the h file then
switching play to playing on the a file
and i loved that move uh when he castled
king side into the open age file a touch
of class and now he's about
to
to earn the rewards of his efforts
yes and neil's just trying to figure out
is there something i can do here maybe i
can play on for a little bit but you can
almost pre-move e5 for white and as you
mentioned after queen f6 e5 is a good
deflection and if king g7 you're not
stopping me from playing e5 and i'm just
going to walk my pawns up the board i
will join my past deepon with a past
epon and it's just
getting going from bad to worse for nils
and we saw niels there shake his head
one more time
these pawns they are unstoppable just
look at them they are going to to
advance not just are they going to
advance your king is also not safe he
has just made a move it is uh king king
g7
and well robert i guess we still want to
just uh push the pawns
look at his face right you know he's
knows he's lost he's playing on but he's
kind of resigned to the fact that it's
going to be a defeat and even if this
were a blitz or bullet game i don't
think that
you can really go wrong for white it's
hard to imagine any way to make a
mistake and well speaking of blitz
title tuesday is about to begin in five
minutes i can't play i did play last
week but i'll be busy here commentating
with you but title tuesday
is about to begin and i believe it is on
uh the chess.chesscom live channel so
twitch.tv chess com live you will not
want to miss that action but maybe you
can wait until after
this round ends
indeed and if you are watching us then
you are a title player
of course go and take a part
for now we see once again the results
today we had only one decisive uh result
so far my media of beating do that but
pragnanda is about
to make uh to make that too and um i
think we were once again
spoiled uh spoiled for action here a few
quiet games which i think is often the
case uh before the rest day so here's
your
i don't know how many reminder but
tomorrow is a rest day so no need to
show up at 2 p.m
and
where the action will resume uh two days
from now on january the 20th as always
same time every round will be at 2 p.m
central european time except for the
last one which will start two hours
early at noon central european time
robert what are you planning to do with
your rest day
there's no rest for me i'm pretty sure
i'm gonna be commentating something
tomorrow if it's not chess it will just
be my thoughts
on chess.com there is winner stays and i
will i think be joined by daniel
naradiski the two of us will cover that
event so
i will continue speaking about chess
that's how my day off will be spent well
maybe then i can spend my day uh
listen to you
commentating on chess we will see
we will see about that but both of us
will be back here two days from now i
think for the players also a much needed
uh rest day after the first four rounds
of vikanze there's a very long
tournament a tough tournament
and um
and the players will be back with
renewed energy two days from now
and i see we have a graphic ready of the
participants in tomorrow's winter stays
it's uh in the master section we have
dina bill and kaya taking anna maya
pizzarian so that will be a great match
up we have the ceo of chess.com eric
taking on samai
samaya of course extremely popular as
both a comedian and as a chess content
creator
you know he's commentated events he's uh
played a ton of you know the who's who
of chess so he'll be at it against eric
and then we have lsv taking on cry baby
carly in the pogba section so it's going
to be a fun day that's tomorrow during
the rest day from vikings day
plenty of action to look forward to anna
maya kazarian of course another local
hero we have two here in the tournament
anish geary
and jordan ran for raised and anamaya
will try and fly and then dutch flag in
winner stays on so plenty to look
forward to even on the rest day
pregnant meanwhile he is still thinking
uh it's one of these positions where
you're you're so happy now robert i
think we can both relate when you sit in
that position you know
unless i lose on time or my phone goes
off
i can barely spoil it
and you're just thinking how do you want
to go on about this i still love your
suggestion of simply pushing that pawn
forward
yeah e5 just looks really strong there's
no drawback that i can see and you have
these central pawns and you're right
prognonda should be happy he should be
very pleased with how he's played and he
should be proud of himself and the
game's not over you don't want to start
jumping for joy before you've actually
won but for all intents and purposes i
think both players know that prognonda
has won this game
yes and
well this game isn't
going to go on for too much longer
and but don't go anywhere we don't want
to lose you two title tuesday just yet
because we will not be done robert uh
after this game there will be a rapid
recap and uh we still haven't completely
made up your mind i'm curious in the
chat let us know what do you think was
the most exciting game of the day which
was the one that had you on the edge of
your seats
i don't want the chat to say their you
know their piece because i'm not going
to listen to them i'm not looking at
what they're going to say
okay and ultimately we're going to
choose what game we want to talk about
surely someone in the chat at least is
going to to be picking the game
that you will be picking
uh so we can at least see what they have
to say
i see i think there are two candidates
and i think that's the two that the chat
is currently torn
between and the magnus game against
jordan
or mamadiarov against um against
duda
well the only torn thing i want to hear
from the chat is if they're playing the
song torn by natalie bruglia because
otherwise like i said i'm just not gonna
listen so if that song is playing please
by all means i will be glad to join in
and listen otherwise yeah i mean they
could say what they want
fiona and robert playing good cop
bandcom is so entertaining
i don't know i mean
i don't really
i don't think it's bad i just think that
you
appreciate and listen to the people and
i just
don't don't bother
don't
but i don't care we see pregnant and uh
he
is
still
thinking uh you don't want to to lose
your focus too soon i was just saying
you are enjoying sitting
in this position but you don't want to
enjoy it too much you want to make sure
you don't allow any chances at all but
as i say this he is getting ready to
reach out neil's not currently at the
boat what you predict the move uh is
going to be road
it has to be e5
i'm trying to think of another move that
makes more sense and i can't your rook
is well positioned on the open file at
some point you may want to swing to the
h file
we already saw the rook on h1 go to the
a file now the work on the a file might
go to the h file but no i think e5 just
makes so much sense and what did he do
queen e6
okay that's fine as well you're gonna be
mcqueen e5 check at some point you're
going after the king
i can't blame that that's a very good
move
so uh well while we let uh niels ponder
his response here is your reminder that
despite the fact that the tata silchas
festival this year uh the tata still
jazz tournament is going ahead without
amateur groups and without spectators
there will still be a tata steel chess
festival which you can all take part in
all the activities will be taking place
online over two days so that's january
22nd and 23rd
you can take part free of charge and you
don't need to register there is a wide
range of activities from taking online
chess lessons participating in an online
football training from sc telstar which
i'm actually very curious about
participating in a virtual visit to tata
steel you can get creative with the
craft videos or you can take a digital
walk through vikanze see what it would
feel like to be here finally there will
also be an online rapid tournament so
head on over to tatasteeljas.com
tata steel chess festival and to see
what activities are on offer and you too
can be a part of it
hey fiona believe it or not i do want to
speak the chat do join have a good time
i know so many people here who have been
watching we do appreciate your continued
support and viewership and why not if
you have time to play it is free of
charge as fiona just said and there's
going to be so many people from all
around the world chess is a wonderful
international game and so
if you want to please go ahead take part
enjoy yourself a good chess tournament
absolutely we would love to see as many
of you as as many as possible of you
it's been a long day i think i need that
rest day too i've been struggling
i've been struggling it started from the
first seconds of our broadcast robert i
almost forgot my own name i've been
confusing players i've been struggling
to find
the words but we almost at the end of
the day here tomorrow i can recalibrate
is that even a word i don't know i will
recalibrate
i will rise
you're just questioning yourself now
it's okay fiona you got this uh just
like pragmata has this game under
control uh if i'm
niels and i'm continuing this game i'm
going to try to play the move queen to
g5 because it stops queen e5 check it
also gives me a g3 check not that that
really does anything because as soon as
the queen goes to g3 the king can just
step away uh but you need to do
something if you sit on the position
there's well really no way
there's no move to even pass i would say
at this point for nils
so let's have a look maybe we can put
that on the board so if queen
g5
yeah my first question is can i just
take that pawn
you're getting greedy
you probably can because queen e5 to try
to take over the diagonal to hit the
rook try to land on d4 there's just this
comm move rook d1 which seems to hold
everything together but queen comes into
c3 that this is the exact type of a
counter play that niels needs if he
doesn't get something like this he can
just resign on the spot but if he does
get a queen here there's queen c2 queen
takes pawn queen e3 check there are
things that white needs to consider
yeah this i agree with you this is the
kind of thing that if i can avoid it i
would like to so maybe i don't actually
want to take the pawn on on b6 maybe i
don't want to
get greedy here
it's probably good i mean
it almost certainly is but maybe there's
something that makes life a bit easier
and now e5 makes less sense because
rookie 7 and that's why you see the
evaluation bar go down quite a lot you
attack the queen the pawn behind it and
that's not at all what you want to do if
you are uh prague so queen to g5 does
make sense queen takes b6
is likely a very good follow-up you just
need to be careful about allowing this
queen from g5 into the game and there he
goes queen and not queen uh g5 queen h
for jack which uh
has similar uh similar ideas
yeah if the king goes to f1 or something
like that you lose your rook that's not
going to be played king did g1
that gets the king out of check but now
your rook can't move off the
first rank because then queenie one
check queen back in g3 would be a draw i
don't think there's any rush to move
that rook for white i still don't know
what black would play in response
because b6 is hanging as we were talking
about before and
yeah i just feel like white should have
everything under control
yes so that looks like a reasonable
move with as you say everything in the
control which is exactly what prague
wants prague uh he doesn't want to see
any kind of player
unlucky for for niels that the work on
f7
is quite restricted if we could somehow
get that work to the age file
but then again the rook also has to
defend our own king so really there is
just no way to get active because that
rook has to stay on an f7 to prevent the
white rook from coming in
to a7 with a check
that's right and if the king runs to e2
the queen will probably just drop back
to g5 and attack this pawn on uh g2 here
so you can only run so far the king can
come back to f1 and it can sit
fine here
but then you're gonna need a follow-up
and well black also needs to find a move
himself it just
with
you know
limiting black's options white should be
able to take this but i do feel like e5
was much easier than queen to e6
yeah i'm
i'm curious as well i think of course it
will still be enough prank the only
thing he needs to watch out for he
doesn't we talk about it every day
doesn't want to drop too low on time
he's now down to 13
minutes but still 14 moves to go until
move 60 and to the second and final time
control
yes plenty of time
and he is
double triple checking
sometimes that can backfire honestly
where you get too cautious i don't want
to lose my advantage but by playing it
too safe that's how you can lose your
advantage here he should not be worried
about that he has everything
under control he can just drop his king
back and
he can play for e5 at some point he just
needs to be able to do it when rookie 7
won't be a problem so b6
we've mentioned is under attack the rook
on a1 is nicely placed in the a file but
if black could just pass the move like
after king the g1 and black did nothing
like just said your turn
then the b6 plane would be captured so i
think that's why the queen has to come
back he hasn't come to
to g1 by the way uh instead choosing e2
okay so
if queen did g3
then he can even bring his queen back
because a queen trade
would win for white but i mean queen e5
check might just end the game as well if
your king goes to age seven in comes my
rook to the party and check might be
down here if your king g8 there's rook
a8 with check and you have to block
because you can't allow
a rook or queen to h8 so you go here and
once we
trade pieces here
i feel like this
position is just
over
because this queen it gets one move one
check here that's the only check it gets
and white's going to go in for the
checkmate
yeah so k2
looking equally
good does nils have any alternatives
apart from
queen g3
uh queen g5 again that's
the only other move that comes to mind
because i don't want to give this
or allow this check i should say on e5
if i'm thinking from nielsen's
perspective
we see him there i think you always get
a little bit of hope especially when
when you still have a queen
remaining
and the the queen gets closer to the
enemy king but
uh the i think it's often just an
illusion and we are going to go uh on a
final quick break here let niels uh
consider this and we'll come back for
the end of the game so we'll see you
very soon
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back
for this final part of the game between
pregnant and niels grandalius
so after queen g5 uh prague has dropped
his king back to f1 defending the pawn
on g2
yes he needed to make sure he did not
lose that pawn because that would be a
really bad turn of events so he brings
his king back to f1 and now he's passed
the turn to black so we're asking the
question is what would white do in this
position and now pragnanda says no niels
what are you about to do if you move
your queen to h4 we're talking about
positions with the queen on e5 check
this is going to be winning for white as
the rook will enter the party if the
king comes to h7
you have to watch out because they're oh
you don't even have to watch out the
rook is protected so if you don't need
to worry about that you can even make
the move d6 uh i was thinking the king
could potentially
jump off the board to e2 but let's push
our pawn it's a passer we can bring our
rook to uh in the center of the board
soon and we're going to use that pawn to
our advantage
what is interesting is nil seems to have
gained some kind of hope compared to
when we saw this position
a while back
of course objectively it is still lost
but
maybe prague had clearer ways of putting
it away although robert it shouldn't
really matter right
but this is one of the things as a coach
so he's working with ramesh right
not that you should be too critical of
his technique
but you'd like your student or as a
player you'd like yourself to be able to
convert without giving your opponent any
chances or making your your life
difficult because while he may still win
this game and probably will
in another he may not
be able to if the position has been more
complex so as we go back in time just a
little bit here
uh where was it
right
here e5
i mean i just don't see how black gets
any activity the queen is well
positioned to deal with any possible
threats the rook takes care of the open
file this pawn is coming up to e6 it
just seemed like there's nothing that
black can do at all whereas here in the
game
there's a big difference queen h1 check
has to be considered what to do with
this king on f1
so i just feel like he gave nils more
opportunities more tricks more chances
to survive than he deserved
yes absolutely and now well after queen
h4 we had uh the queen coming to h for
two moves ago but at that point it was
with a check so king e2 was played uh
queen h1 is a threat but you don't
really want to go king e2 because then
niels goes king g5 and we're back in the
same situation
so you have to at some point uh play
something different and do you want to
do it here is queen e5 check anything
defending the work and then
can we just
write
pushing as you said
yeah the king has to go to h7 no other
choice and maybe you push but then it
looks like your pawn it's no longer
protected so you could worry fiona that
you're gonna lose it if you're not
careful even though it is perfectly fine
there for the time being
i also see a suggestion in the chat
about king g1
that
probably is another option
yeah the king coming to g1 can be played
but then your rook can never leave the
first rank so that's the downside but it
does make sense to me why not you don't
need your rook to leave you want to push
your pawn b6 is still hanging in all
these positions and if you can take b6
without allowing the queen e5 that's
exactly what you want
yes so uh prague here
frank's time is starting soon he will be
under under 10 minutes um there is still
plenty of time but we're only on move 48
so 12 moves
to go
i'm curious what is his move going to be
i think he will give a check
he's really spending so much time and
energy here it's good that there's a
rest day tomorrow because in without the
rest day you would have around tomorrow
and you want to conserve this energy you
don't want to be all concerned about
your game here and then
waste energy that could have been better
saved for the next game but he you know
he's working he's really trying his best
it's not like he's you know wants niels
to be back in the game but niels is
to his credit is fighting till the last
move until he eventually feels like he
must resign
and as he
as he should
craig could become nervous if suddenly
uh it's only a minute on the clock let's
say and he still has a few moves
to go i think he needs to decide now
with a direction because the somehow the
last few moves the position is so good
that you can't really spoil it but the
last moves has have felt like they
lacked a clear direction a clear plan
that's right and that's why he's still
on the clock he still hasn't figured out
a plan that's the key word you used
there fiona he's made moves that were
sensible but now he needs to figure out
a way to end this game and stop giving
nils any hope whatsoever and if your
knees in a way sometimes uh it's almost
you almost feel like you you wish your
opponent played
uh more accurately because
it is uh of course extending the torture
you think okay he is giving me some tiny
chances but not quite enough uh yet for
me to actually fight back how do you
feel in these spots
robert um
yeah i kind of hate it because you want
the game to be over with but then you
get this hope and you're like i can do
this and like no i can't oh yes i can
and then you're having an argument with
yourself
internally so it looks like
prague did just move king jiji one he is
hiding his king and i think for
for neil's queen g5 makes sense because
we've been talking about this queen
takes b6 now he's the threat there's no
queen getting to e5 unless you're queen
g5 and i'm guessing that you can just
take this pawn queen e5 and here
well what can you do because this queen
check is annoying but the king can run
here so maybe just rook a6 and give one
check and that's it
yeah this looks uh
fairly convincing i have to say
it's still taking so much effort it is
convincing in the end but it has taken
quite a lot
it has taken
a hell of a lot but pragnanda at the end
of the day he won't
matter
he
it won't matter he won't mind um because
he will be getting his first win here
uh he could have maybe gotten there a
little bit sooner but
uh
who are we to judge
in some games it will make a difference
here i think at the end of the day
it will lead to the same result he will
be getting the full point here
as you said queen g5 is the move and
nils has just played it
or has he played queen f oh he's played
queen f6
instead
i think he wants to bring his king
up here and then to d4 and try to get
this pawn so queen takes king takes this
would look completely winning and the
evaluation bar is sky high and we have
seen that trade
if rook a6 for example black will play
rook to b7 and this is the idea it's a
very straightforward idea from nils
claiming that your pawns can't really
push too easily you're protected they're
passed with a king coming to e5 that
means that white has something to deal
with himself
yeah and i'm curious if we just go back
to the the live position after the queen
swap
the rookies a6 is the move we made
i wonder do we want to start by bringing
our own king or maybe do we want to go
even further with the rook and not
attacked upon but sort of trying to get
behind with rook a8
i like rookie that move is because the
thing is we know what black is going to
do by bringing the king here and the
king wants to get to d4 and take the
pawn but if the king does take this pawn
perhaps it has wandered too far for
example king here we give a check if you
take on
c4 i go d6 you have to block my pawn and
then i go e5 and i have my second pawn
joining the party
yeah that
is true so very often and black will not
even be able even if he gets to d5 here
at sorry to d4 he will not be able
to take the pawn uh on c4
and do you think pregnant is relieved
that the queen's off the board
yes but also
there were moments where it seemed like
with the queens of the board he could
have just you know had a million threats
so he is probably relieved there's
nothing
that puts him in danger but he still
needs to prove the victory
yes and i'm curious to see what's the
next move going to be king f2 so he
decides to start by bringing
the king i think it is the same story if
black goes king e5
followed by king d4
then what next anyway prague will always
be able to meet that with rook d1 check
that's right and that's really essential
here that the white pawns are too fast
because otherwise black would have some
serious chances to hold if the c4 pawn
fell then the b pawn or the c pawn would
start running you just don't have those
opportunities
yes and we see from a distance here as
we look into the almost empty playing
hall that prague
has
made another move king e2
is now on the board and he is saying to
nils okay if you go further king d4
i will give you that pawn i will just
give you a check from d1 and you cannot
take it as then my pawns will just run
so what can nils do instead can he try
and activate the rook somehow
rook h7
he's gonna have to try but after rook h7
uh i like king d3 because now your king
takes care of the d4 square and if you
play rook h2 i think that white can play
rook b1 you take g2 and i take b6 and
guess what
that's exact things in a mating net very
nice
yeah very little
can go wrong for white i mean if you
can't play king d4 that i play king d3
if you do play king d4 i play rook d1
check that should be that
yeah and
uh although it has taken a while it
feels now i always feel robert that at
the end of the day i always say
oh we're getting there we're getting
there and then at some point i'm like
okay we're really getting there now
yeah it's cool to see the players take
their time because
while they know it's winning you don't
want to make a mistake you don't be
careless and give your opponent like a
real chance not just a chance to maybe
kind of almost survive by a chance to
actually be like wait oh no my advantage
is slipping and i don't know what to do
yes
indeed and uh well
here the advantage won't be slipping
with
[Music]
nils
literally i think out of defensive uh
options either
the white king will activate there's
still
too many weak pawns in the black kang
b6 is still weak g6 is weak
the white rook is on a nice and open
file
um
and yeah we see it once again on the
camera
with nils going through the motions here
yeah and uh once he figures that the
king's not getting to d4 it's a clear
technical win for pragnanda and then
there's nothing at that point too much
left to play for because b6 is still a
target this rook you point out this idea
before fiona bringing the rook up
to a8 and then the rook can swing around
to e8 or c8 or b8 depending on where the
black work is and there's just too many
weaknesses too many threats for white to
use and exploit those weaknesses
and niels is switching out he has gone
king d4 so i'm curious
what his response will be
after rook d won
check will he go back there we see
pragnanda immediately
giving the check
and uh neil's stepping back to e5
and now what so king
okay so if you played d6
you're trying to go d7 and that looks
pretty good because if the king go if
the rook goes back the rook checks on d5
the king goes to e6 and then you play e5
so maybe that's all it takes
interestingly enough prague very quickly
decided
i'm i'm so confused like of course
prague won't repeat three times but i'm
still a little confused as to what he's
doing
some coaches teach this that uh always
repeat
at least once you gain time on the clock
you also get closer to move 60 so he has
plenty of time left but still you don't
want to have seven moves left you'd
rather have five when you have a winning
position
so i guess now is where he will play
something
else than rook a2 and what do you think
that move is going to be
i mean d6 should win because you have
rook d5 you pawn e5 after it uh
i guess the one potential worry is that
if you
do start pushing very far that black
could have a move like b5 or
i mean b5 is
it's not going to do anything right b5
tries to undermine the defense of the
rook here but the king can just come to
d3 to reinforce it c5 is going to fall
so yeah i'm trying my best to
find a way for nils to cling onto hope
yeah i mean we haven't this whole time
we've been looking uh at this end game
unfortunately for nils and i think that
shows just how hopeless the position has
been
this whole time i think we've barely
found a single variation uh
where he could trick rangananda in one
way or another
yeah credits of prague i mean we were
thinking that he was wavering a bit he
wasn't finding that
you know a knockout there was no
knockout yet but he also figured out
another way to win so maybe it took a
little bit longer maybe he spent more
time thinking about it but a win is a
win and that's all that he came here for
today
yes so we see him there
with the time taking down but now we're
a lot closer to uh the final time
control a reminder for everyone that on
move 60 the players get an additional
15 minutes so that is the last extra
time of the game and of course they
continue
having their 30-second increment
per move so we're now almost 55 which
means that
five moves from now the two players will
get an extra
um minutes
yeah plenty of time
for them and you know unfortunately too
much time if you're kneels like no no
more time let's just play a blitz game
here this isn't title tuesday even
though that's going on right now and
king to d3 was in fact played fiona so
he decides to bring his king up the
board first
to take control of the d4 square and the
only way to get access back is to play
rook a7 and then when you play rook a7
you need to play rook a3 but that means
that your rook isn't going to be in
front of the pawn and that's not good
for when the pawn springs free
yes indeed so i guess if 4k 7 here
can we try and activate our own work do
we want to bring that rook to to b1
maybe looking down at the pawn on b6 or
how do we want to proceed
yeah eventually you can't let rook to b1
you can't buy king c3
black needs to do something at some
point and in fact let's say black does
nothing and you play king c3 and rook d7
and you play king b3 and then you just
continue sort of shuffling then white
can play king a14 to b5 and if you take
away the a4 square why can play d6
because this type of position we still
have rook d5 check and pawn to e5 and we
protect everything and win the game so
it seems like
no matter what we're coming to the same
conclusion and
rook a7 king c3 was played if you check
the king steps back and then you have to
deal with the d-pawn
yeah so um
although the work has finally the
blackboard has finally
managed to get to an open file
it can simply not activate itself as it
has to help in the defense
of those passports moving
forward and
yeah pragnanda here move by move
getting closer to that first win in the
statistics masters
and that was the 57th move by pragmatic
to c3 so he just needs to reach move 60
before gaining more time the clock and
even without that there's the increment
30 seconds added to the clock per move
so
pragnanda could win this position
without the extra time but he will get
it for good measure and niels
he's known for a very long time that he
was going to lose this game so this
isn't a surprise isn't a shock but it is
a disappointment because he didn't want
to start his tournament half out of four
and for prague on the other hand two out
of four against this field you have to
be feeling good about that start in the
master section
for sure what a what a debut for him
yeah for nils i mean one thing
of course is
his start into the tournament
another is just it's so just can be so
tough i mean he's never really had a
position where you want to resign
because you still have a queen you still
have
some hopes uh but it's been lost for so
long and as you say he knows it and um
those games are just not much fun like
frank has been in the driver's seat for
so long uh first with a small ledge then
a winning edge and we see here the
results from today
we also see that those two players are
the last two remaining in the playing
hall
and
one decisive game here today shahid
mahmedir of beating
duda
which means that
gujarati remains in the lead
yeah for sure he he was able to
stabilize against yasupanko yes spencer
would have loved to somehow win that
game and overtake vidit but did it three
out of four very impressive start for
him beating dubov beating shanklin and
drawing into caruana on yes banco
yes and uh well neil still
is thinking
i mean it's just we're getting to that
that point where i just find it uh so
so hard to to make a move
you don't you can't really go forward
with your work so you have to again play
a
a passive defensive move
uh again
so what what do you do
um
let's think what could he be thinking
maybe king back to d6
but the problem is king to d6 doesn't
solve many of the other issues king to
b3 happens and now there's no access
along the a file for the black rook and
if you stay on the a file this white
rook can go to h1 right both files are
open and it would allow the rook to get
in the game here if the rook ever leaves
the a file white's king goes up to b5
you can't cover everything there's just
no way possible for niels to do that
yeah and we see nils there uh
he is going into the tank while i want
to give a big shout out to our
photographer leonard oates who's here
in the room with us he's done such
fantastic work these days you can find
oh
too bad
leonard is here
saying hello
you can find all of his photographs he's
been taking so many great pictures from
the tournament he's going to take a
picture of you right now robert it looks
like
you can find his pictures on our
official website tatastiljas.com
as well as on the social
media i think on our facebook page you
can find some of them uh on twitter go
and follow him at leonardo yes
you know what robert i have known
leonard
for so many years and i every time i
don't remember how to pronounce it
literally every time i mispronounced his
name and every time i'm like yeah i
think i'm doing it right now and every
time i'm not
he will forgive you if he hasn't already
uh you know i can't speak for him but
knowing leonard and he's forgiven you
[Laughter]
there he is we're having way too much
fun here in the what are we in it's
almost eight o'clock again
wow yeah it's been a long round
probably none that he didn't want us to
get an early day here he said that no
fiona robert you're staying put because
i'm i'm gonna win and i'm gonna win on
my own time
yeah he certainly uh did well with
neil's also
putting up
the maximum
fight
here
but it is just
as you demonstrated what to do now there
it simply doesn't seem
anything in
and neil's deciding to push the jeep on
but shaking his head at the same time he
knows of course that this one is gone
d6 should be my
move
pretty immediately because i'm threading
d7 i will force either the king to come
back to e6 or the rook to d7 i don't
know if it makes too much of a
difference because after king e6
now the king and pawn end game might
just be winning and that's
this actually is important so i'm glad
we got to this moment but we need to
calculate i'm not just going to play d7
and hope that it's winning i see the
evaluation bar says winning we don't
have the move the bar could be winning
because rook d5 followed by e5 that
looks great but let's do a little bit of
calculation d7
we will trade the rooks on the square so
we know that the king will end up on d7
without the pawn on d6 now from my
experience i can tell you
for a fact that white is winning because
white will march the king up to a4 and
we have this nice protected past pawn
whereas your extra pawn for black is not
passed and my one pawn here is taking
care of your two so to put that all
on display for you
the eval bar has not changed because
king b3
king a4 is coming you can't play b5 i
simply take your pawn if you play king
c6 i play king to a4 i'm going to push
your king back and then once we get here
i'm going to use my pawn as a decoy you
will win this pawn
good for you but i will take b6 i will
take c5 and thus i win the game so
sometimes you need to transfer your
advantage from an extra pawn and then
liquidate into a winning king and
pawning game so you need to make the
most of these situations and that's why
this position is just completely losing
even if you gain material back you still
are on the bad side of an ending because
your pawn is stopped your two pounds i
should say stop by one pawn and my pawns
are not i can spring free a second
passer
i think that's such an instructive
moment here how
frank maybe has the opportunity to
liquidate into a winning uh pawn end
game and i think that's exactly why he
is thinking right now he is certainly i
guess considering
at
d6 and do you think he will play it
i don't know what to think anymore but i
hope he will play d6 it seems like the
best move uh that means if no king e6
the only one was rook to d7 to deal with
that past pawn but we just talked about
what happens if the rooks get traded
even if you went upon i could play rook
d5 check and e5 and save my pawn but if
i play king to b3 and we get here once
again we know the results of this game
after king c6 i play e5 you go win my
pawn i win both of yours and i end up
upon ahead my c4 pawn will queen
greg says i am not in a rush i'm not
gonna do that just yet instead he just
brings the king over
to b3
you know i really like prague seems like
a great kid he's a fantastic chess
player
but right now let's just say he's not on
my uh best list because
he is making this game go longer when he
doesn't need to
uh it's completely winning if the king
goes to d6 to block the pawn then rook
h1 rook h6 he can win in a thousand
different ways but i just want him to
win at this point because he is winning
not because i'm rooting for him or
against neil's or anything like that but
finish the game
yeah it feels like
it feels like we have been here uh for a
very long
long time in a position which has seemed
winning
for so long and i think at this stage
we want it
we want this game to be over
is there anyone who doesn't right niels
wants the game to be over pragnanda i'm
not sure if he wants to be the game to
be over i'm sure you know his family and
friends
as they watch they want him to get the
victory his coach so it seems like it's
only
pragananda who hasn't quite convinced
himself that he wants to stand maybe
he's savoring the moment
well uh indeed i don't know what to
think any longer
um
but poor needs yeah i'm sure he wants
this torture to be over now the rook has
no entry squares a d6 is still a threat
so um
what's he gonna do maybe king d6
try and get in front of the pawn
only thing i see and then rook h1 and
the rook joins the party anyway so uh
yeah you can stop the pawn for a turn or
two but the rook will enter and
that
hey what's he doing
sorry
did he go g4 he did dance
got it so he's
trying for something but even d6 again
even your neighbors roberts clearly
wants the torture to be over they're
like
knocking on the walls like make it stop
we don't want to hear what we're talking
about chess any longer
those are our neighbors that's a
drilling and um yeah like i've been
trying to mute myself so i'm glad you
brought attention to it because yeah i
purposely will stop talking and then
mute my microphone but now everybody
knows what's happening here uh so i'm
sorry i couldn't keep the secret any
longer the drillers won the game to be
over
at g4
and
is d6
finally gonna be played robert
uh yes i mean it's winning so it should
be played
um
you could probably just take the pawn i
don't think that there's anything wrong
with that but d6 rook to d7 and we get
to the positions we've been talking
about with the king
entering v6 robert is
on the board
okay d6 it is
and
at long last
we are going to see this king
walk into b5 and
yeah just trade on f3
so prag recaptures and
maybe we'll see a resignation here
let's see
oh so okay king is six
so then if he plays d7
then will niels resign because he knows
the king of pawn game is losing that's
what pragmata is calculating right now
and that's what they're drilling into
our heads behind me
we have also just
a maid move 60 so prague he now has
around uh
20 minutes on the clock to
figure out i think not to figure out
just to make uh to double check because
he knows i think that this is winning
but when you've been fighting for so
long for the win
uh
you just want to make extra double sure
he's
done um
everything right enough like maybe there
were ways he could have gone played
whiter if that makes sense but he's
never lost control of the position and
now uh this is the final step and there
we go d7 is on the board and robert i
agree with you i think we might see
resignation here
well there's only one choice and rook
takes d7 is the only move because
white's about to queen so you better
take it and once you do take it you know
the white king will enter via b5 he has
captured uh
quickly programmer will capture play
king dave for push his pawn to e5 and
distract the black king
and win these pawns here
yeah so we are waiting for the king and
there he goes king a4
is on the board king c6
played
and now
sorry the camera is ready
for the
the final moves here in ae5
sorry
i guess this position has gotten to you
oh my goodness it's been an intense it's
been an intense day
but i think
here
i think the fun um well not the fun
and the torture ends now because
the king the black king will have to go
back to deal with the pawn and as you
said the the black b and b6 and c5 pawns
will fall and that will be that
and it's interesting that niels is
sitting and thinking here because he
knows for sure that this is over but
yeah there he goes he resigns it's about
you know it's about time in a way but
you know pragnando wasn't super
convincing at points and that's why
niels kept the game going i see a
comment in the chat from
donald truman who says if i had an extra
hour of life for every time fiona has
said we might see resignation here i'd
be near immortal
oh well you know it felt like it was
about to end from a chess perspective
but from a time perspective they had
plenty left on the clock so they used it
and that is a good thing to do to use
your time don't rush you may be winning
but the hardest game to one is a one
game that's what they say so
good job by pragnanda he gets his first
victory in the masters and he moves a
two out of four
yeah absolutely congratulations to him
he was made to work hard for his victory
by niels gwendelus who's had a tough
start to his tournament of course we
hope to see neil's bounce back after
tomorrow's rest day but for now robert
we're going to take a final quick break
of the day and there we have the results
so two decisive results today i win for
shahid medeirov against
duda and well the one we've been
following for the last few hours uh
pregnant and uh beating nin squanders
and we see those two players still
in the playing hall discussing their
game we're gonna go on a short break and
we will be back with our rapid recap so
don't go anywhere and we'll see you in
just a moment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there should be one but i don't remember
which one
exactly the times okay
welcome back here as you can see prague
is almost ready for the interview but
not just yet so we're going to wait to
hear uh from prague
his thoughts on the game are they still
just testing i don't know i can see
prank talking but i don't know if it's
the interviewer if they sit there
setting up i'm not sure
um i'm robert i know you're still muted
because i think i'm not muted and you're
not created
no no no i'm here don't worry
it's it looks like an interview
okay let's go there
um quite convincing
it's your first win in the tata seal
masters um how important is it for you
to finally get this thing started
yeah it's uh it's a very important win
for me um it gives huge confidence of
course and
um yeah i really wanted to win today
with the white pieces yeah i guess this
is like the strongest tournament you
ever played yeah definitely classical
yeah so how did you prepare for the
tournament like uh to to play the likes
of magnus carlsen anish geary
yeah um yeah i was just preparing
normally like um
i was also preparing mentally you know
trying to be ready because you know um
things go could go very wrong easily so
i was also preparing mentally
how do you prepare mentally like i was
just uh trying to say to me like just be
calm and so
like if something goes wrong in case
um
one thing that went wrong and it was
shared on twitter by by your trainer
ramesh is that he he tested positive on
on kovit
how is he
uh he's fine
uh he's isolated now in a in a different
room but yeah i'm staying alone now it's
it's a difficult thing for me because
it's
like the first tournament i'm staying
alone in a room
and yeah
it's a important event as well
um but you can still like prepare
together
i know online we can do yeah but
yeah it's definitely a good thing that
uh
we can do online at least
so you're now at uh so it's 50 percent
yeah right um so things are going well
in the tournament like what is your uh
your prospect for the next next few
rounds
ah
like haven't thought about it like yeah
just to play good chess and
see what comes
um
and then the rest day is coming up uh
and like you said like you're the first
thing that you're like really like alone
in the tournament like do you have any
friends in the tournament where you can
spend the rest yeah i'm not so sure like
i can go and uh you know meet other
people because i was in contact with the
positive person so i'm not sure probably
i'll just stay stay in the room and see
maybe go for a walk alone
do you enjoy the the beach here if i can
say yeah i haven't gone there so maybe
i'll go tomorrow okay all the best thank
you
well that is a happy winner of today's
game he gets the rest day tomorrow so he
will probably need that going into round
five we had two decisive games here in
round four vikings a but without further
ado this is your rapid recap and fiona
no surprise here that our game of the
day is between magnus carlson the world
champion and his second the defending
tata steel champion jordan von forest
and what a game it was magnus said
yesterday he was curious to see what
jordan had up his sleeve but it was
magnus himself who dictated at the tempo
in the opening
deciding he didn't want any big
theoretical
debates
i feel like we were lied to because when
this game started we're looking at this
position symmetrical it was going to be
boring right fiona absolutely it started
off
quietly and we weren't too sure what we
were in for
jordan did a great job of
keeping things under control with the
black pieces but very soon uh things
started coming to life here
and i think this was the first moment
bishop to f1 the rook cleared out of the
way and the point is the bishop on e4
there's a wall of pawns on light squares
which restricts the mobility of black's
bishop so if he didn't take on f3 let's
say he made some random move like king
h8 in comes knight d2 then comes pawn to
f3 this bishop is going to get trapped
as it only has a couple squares so that
bishop on the light squares needed to
capture on f3 jordan did just that and
the fiona the knight jumped into the
middle of the board
yes absolutely that knight cannot
or shouldn't be captured because then
the bishop from the
g7 comes to life captures on
c3 so instead
magnus he just dropped his bishop back
and the knight jumped into e4
magnus tried to attack the knight with
bishop to d3 and now jordan with an
interesting decision f5
uh we really like the decision during
the game he is solidifying the e4 square
and then he tried to take it firmly
under his control but there was a bit of
an issue or so we thought when after g5
and g4 bishop takes e4 you don't really
want to lose the ponies place here but
if you take on e4 with the d pawn
black's position is in shambles after d5
you see first the rook on d1 then after
some captures in the d5 square if we
trade and take a free pawn it's not so
free after all because here comes a rook
2c5 we're hitting the d5 pawn behind it
is a weak f5 pawn all of white's pieces
have come to life and black's position
is really terrible
so it turns out the whole idea of jordan
of course he had seen this coming his
idea was to give up uh dupont by
capturing with the f-pawn and leaving
the pawn on g4 undefended magnus took it
at first we weren't sure what was going
on here
no we weren't because a pawn is a pawn
except there is clear compensation down
the f file the rook on f8 the pawn on e4
they team up quite nicely and after the
next few moves we saw that jordan had a
plan to just strike on the king side so
fiona it seemed like magnus needed to
find something for himself on the queen
side but it was feeling like it might be
a little bit too slow and his king was
the one in danger yes and you're then
well it wasn't enough for him to give up
just one pawn so here magnus uh trying
to get some play on the queen side and
jordan
he decides well after g4 magnus is uh
threatening to consolidate wit by
playing h3 himself so jordan says no no
no magnus no h3 for you take my own pawn
there
that's right without pawns there are
open files and that's what black needed
in this game was trying first the f5 but
why not the h file as well so queen
takes h3 the rook came to f8 and then we
saw this moment here with rook g6 g5
rook f5 very clearly going after this
pawn h4 defends and this is where things
got really out of control bishop of f8
the rook came back bishop e7 fiona we
saw the clear point of this bishop takes
g5 was the big threat
indeed but after magnus's next move
rook b2
now the question is uh you want to take
on g5 and jordan did but he took with
the bishop uh robert why was that maybe
not ideal
you tend to want to take with the less
valuable p so bishop takes g5 makes
sense from that principle but
unfortunately after bishop takes g5 your
bishop is pinned and king f1 was a great
move by max but before we look at the
game continuation what should have
played was rook takes g5 pawn takes on
g5 and after this rook takes g5 we see
that it's going to be a queen for black
two rooks for white it's kind of
reminiscent of yonda pomneshi magnus
carlson game six but in fact here the
position he was according to eval bar is
zeros it's because the white king will
be exposed so while the rooks will try
to attack unfortunately the king is too
exposed
yes so
this would most likely have led to a
draw but jordan maybe uh after playing
such brilliant moves giving up two pawns
maybe the first misstep capturing
wit the bishop on g5 and magnus finding
the reason why bishop g5 wasn't the best
because king f1 just steps out of the
g-file and suddenly we look down at
jordan's work on g6 which is unprotected
that's right because the bishop can't
move the rook is loose and even the
evaluation wasn't sure the players
certainly were not they had no idea they
were just trying to calculate as best
they could without much time you see on
the left-hand side of the screen here 10
plus minutes for white seven and change
for black that's not a lot of time and
we saw queen a7 which actually was a big
mistake because of king to e2 it was not
seen by the players it's much easier to
see a move like this with the help of an
engine the point is if a queen a6 check
king comes to d1 and after queen d3
check you are out of checks the rook
comes to d2 the king is nice and snug on
d1 i will win your bishop thank you very
much so that was a missed chance by
magnus carlson and then instead of that
king the e2 he didn't want to walk away
he said queen g4 and after queen a6
check fiona we were wondering what white
could do here and chat helped us out
didn't they yes absolutely i mean this
was such a critical moment as well
because it was move 40 so the last move
before the time control and we saw
magnus carlsen go down to his last
seconds before giving the check on v8
yeah he went here just to show everybody
queen takes f5 is a losing move you win
a rook but you lose the game you do not
want any part of the reason the king on
g1 bishop f4 is check where can the king
go it certainly can't go to f1 thank you
the queen covers that square leaves only
h1 and then the queen will go to f1
itself that is check and mate so in this
position
the queen couldn't take on f5 but chat
told us rook takes c6 was in the air and
the point is after queen takes c6 queen
takes f5 is now available there's no f1
control that means if this bishop were
to move and play go to f4 the same as we
were looking just a moment ago the king
slides over to h1 there is no checkmate
the game remains complicated but that
would have allowed magnus to scoop off
the rook but fionan said we saw a
different approach yeah good to see
magnus is only human uh
king e2 earlier would have been the
first moment rook c2 but he is human but
rook b8
seemed to also just be enough we weren't
too sure at first is jordan suddenly
gonna get some chances he instantly
played bishop d8 which uncovers uh the
skewer along the g file uh but once
again although magnus said he doesn't
believe in fortresses that is what was
about to happen here
it was just one careful move by jordan
because king h7 trying to play for a win
i want to keep more material on the
board your king is worse than mine i
have a queen unfortunately this move
loses because of the beautiful
deflection rook to d7 you can't take my
queen because your rook is pinned if you
take what looks like a free rook queen
takes a five comes in with check down
goes your rook on d7 white wins the game
so that was not played and said rook f8
in this moment here but the trade the
queen gives itself up for the rook but i
like throwing in the check first and
then after a3 this was a fortress that
jordan could not break
indeed there are few more moves were
played with jordan trying to get his
king closer to the enemy king but
finally this final pawn sacrifice with
c5 to open the sixth rank and activate
uh the black queen led to this uh
perpetual check here along the sixth
rank robert what a stunning fighting
draw between magnus carlsen and his
second here at inventories
yeah they're friends today they were
foes but they still had a friendly split
of the point even if the game was
extremely combative both players having
chances but last the game was a draw and
this was your round four rapid recap
fiona what a day it was here in vikings
a four rounds are in the books and we
have the results on screen two decisive
games we just showed you a game that was
not decisive but that was such a barn
burner absolutely and
the other game of the day i think it was
a close toss-up between the two if you
haven't seen shahid mamidyarov's win
over yanchez love duda that was
a very exciting one as well
and quite a turnaround in that game uh
and while prague playing the longest
game of the day to beat nils grandelius
and let's look at the standings robert
after four rounds
we have vida gujarati his many fans will
celebrate his lead but we shouldn't be
celebrating early no matter who you're a
fan of it's only four rounds done there
are 13 total rounds nine to go and so
vida guzrati he is in the lead magnus
carlson chakra mama jarv i have to say
mama jarb has made some draws by
agreement some offers that i have been
very vocal about i love the way he plays
the game that's why i want to see more
moves from him and today his draw offer
declined by yanchez dub duda and he goes
on to win the game he's joined by report
and yesapanko and von forrest at the top
indeed he is always a force to be
reckoned with and i'm very curious to
see how the players uh deal with their
rest day i think we're gonna look uh at
the pairings for uh the day after
tomorrow tomorrow is the rest day we'll
have niels gondalius who's been
struggling it will be interesting to see
what he can do with the white pieces
against magnus carlsen
another very interesting game our leader
vidit gujarati he will be playing black
against his good friend
anish geary what are your expectations
for that game
anisha is going to come prepared we know
he had an early day today he drew the
black piece against karjakin without
much effort it was just a standard
opening draw and he gets white so he's
going to want to take down vidit it's
his friend but when you play
competitions nobody is really your
friend anymore after the game is done
you can have a bite to eat enjoy each
other's company but i think anisha is
really going to go for it and i said
this earlier fiona and you can disagree
with me but my game of the round at
least in advance is jordan yvonne forest
with the white pieces against shocker
and mama jarv two of the most creative
players in the game yes i'm
very much looking forward to that also
another game between euphenex viewer and
cesapanko against karana plenty to look
forward to but first we will have a rest
day
tomorrow and then robert you and i will
be back two days from now on january the
20th at 2 p.m central european time
that's 5 a.m pacific uh we look forward
to having you back robert it's been
quite the day
thank you so much uh for being here by
my side thank you
to everyone uh in the chat who was
watching us
and um i hope you all enjoy your rest
day and we will see you two days from
now robert any final words
yeah they don't get a rest yet we get to
go we do whatever we want they're
staying put because title tuesday is
coming to this channel right here right
now we're off fiona it's been an
absolute pleasure chat you've been okay
no in all seriousness i appreciate your
support your viewership it really means
the world to us but now you have to
watch those speeches players blitz it
out it is title tuesday you don't want
to miss it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]